Here
we go.
Break break. Take it down.
Here
we go.
on.
Hey
Heat. Heat.
One
heat.
Welcome back, Rift Bounders, here at the
regional qualifier in Vancouver, Canada.
I'm Barrett Bryant, joined with Ursiday
Day, and we are here to finally deliver
what everyone has been waiting for. It's
time to commence our top eight, but
we're of course going to sprinkle in a
little bit of excitement because I know
our players are ready, but we've got to
prepare you all at home for the
excitement that we have in store for you
cuz boy howdy, it's quite a lot.
>> I cannot wait to see the top eight
today.
>> It's It's going to be filled with
bangers. Absolutely. So, but of course,
we want to recap a little bit from
today. So, we did play our five rounds
of Swiss after yesterday's five or eight
rounds of Swiss where we saw incredible
matchups. Of course, you know, this is
going to be our standings that we're
finalizing from all of that hard work.
So, you can see already this is your top
eight all the way from TSS Houses are
big who we just got to witness now
locking in that first seed. Dewali, Alan
EQ, Rocklo, Sam D Sherman, Arto, Swag
Yolo, 420. Yeah, and Bow Bows as well.
>> This is going to be such a fantastic top
eight and so many great names in it as
well.
>> I I cannot wait. And if you're paying
attention everybody at home, uh that's
correct. We did have two X and2s make it
in for that top cut. But if you look
closely in the middle and if you look at
the names, we have three returning
regional qualifier champions. But we
also want to say homage and thank you to
the rest of the players that came so
close but are still going to be going
home with that invite to that regional
championship.
>> I think that's what a lot of these
players came here fighting for, but so
many great names as well. I mean, even
CTCG Alexander the Great, we did see
earlier today
Rob as well. So many fantastic names, so
many different of these decks.
>> Absolutely. So, we just want to say
thank you so much for everybody who is
playing and Incredible Legends as well,
which I know some bests are being handed
out basically as we speak. And so, with
that, we're going to continue moving
along. We want to go ahead and do some
deck list showcases. We're going to do
it here basically instead of before the
match because we got to hype up some of
these matches. And that's right, we're
going to be featuring Sam Oh, the altar
of unity. Uh we're gonna be featuring
Sam D. Sherman on that Rengar list, your
Las Vegas regional qualifier champion
and he is going to be playing against
Rocklow. This is now his fourth best of
Azir and his first ever top eight.
>> I'm sure he is so excited. He really
knows how to play Azir. I mean, he's
shown over and over with this being his
fourth best of that you mentioned. And
what an awesome deck. We I think we saw
him earlier in this shadow call is so
interesting. The list
>> just being able to draw more cards,
sacrifice being added to the deck as
well. The new vibe for ambush, you know,
stun tricks as well. We we've already
seen how powerful this deck can be when
you mentioned Alexander the Great is
being on stream unfortunately with a
loss. But
>> Azir has already won a regional
qualifier before and now it is here
again in a top eight performance. Some
region success in China as well. like
you we you really can't sell this legend
short and I think this is a great meta
for this legend to really thrive and you
have to also consider Rocklo himself is
just a specialist at this deck.
>> Yeah, I mean I think it's really when
you get decks like this into the hands
of specialists into players who know how
to play it that it thrives.
>> All right, and we're going to move on to
his opponent as well with Sam D.
Sherman. There's so much to say about
this player because he showed up
playing, you know, the in the Draven
format, but showed that he was the best
one in Las Vegas. The format shifts, the
format changes. He tries out Lucian.
Doesn't necessarily go the way that he
wants to in Atlanta, but here he is back
on the same domains, but now with the
Rengar in the jungle, and this list is
so amazing. We got to witness this way
early on in day one during Swiss. And I
we wanted to get him again at some point
today, but he kept getting paired
against someone we had already
showcased. But look at this list. So
much aggro, so much increases of mites
from these units, and just really
showcases what this deck can do right
now in the format.
>> Yeah, and I really think it showcases
that ambush keyword as well. Not new to
unleash, per se, but definitely getting
showcased in this newest set. And also,
I don't think anyone expected a Rengar
to do well today, much less making it
into that top eight.
>> Absolutely. And of course, one of my
favorite call outs is that Grim
Apothecary. I really hope we can see
some intense gameplay with it, included
with things like Starring the
battlefield because you can do some
crazy saving plays. It's as if you
played your own Flash in the deck, but
you save those those units that you
might have onto the battlefield by
returning one to hand and then also
bringing something back to your base.
So, we've got an incredible matchup here
for your first one in top eight here in
Vancouver. But, of course, we did
promise the people something a little
special.
>> Ooh, what's that?
>> Well, we do have some more sets in
Riftbound coming out later this year,
and I was lucky enough to sit down with
Trick from Riot to give us a little
preview on some upcoming Vendetta and
Radiance information. Let's take a look.
Hello everybody. I'm Barrett Bryant and
I have the wonderful pleasure to be
joined by Trick from Riot Games and I
hear you have some exciting stuff to
tell us about some upcoming sets. Now,
of course, Unleashed is in full force
here at the regional qualifier, but um I
hear you have some fun stuff to talk
about. Why don't you introduce yourself?
>> I do. Thank you, Barrett. Uh I'm Trick
Jared. I'm the editor-in chief for
Riftbound. So, I oversee a lot of our
content and community and all of those
activations and fun stuff. And a lot of
my job is helping talk about when we're
going to talk about things. And so
obviously, as we said, Unleashed is out.
We're excited. Players are excited. But
that leads to what's coming next. So we
wanted to tell fans and look ahead a
little bit, give a peek into the future
and share a little bit more. We teased
some on social this weekend already, but
players will have seen, you know, a look
at some packaging for Vendetta, which
you may have already seen. Packaging
Hey.
Of
course, we're excited here for V. We're
excited here because we have some
exciting information for Vendetta and
Radiance as well. But, you know, we got
to kind of tease the audience a little
bit. So, I got to ask you, you know, we
have, you know, opposite domains that
we've been promised for this upcoming
set that's going to be going in with
Vendetta. You know, is there maybe a
particular color combination that you're
excited for?
>> Ooh. Is there one that I'm excited for?
Let's see. I
>> Come on. Endless possibilities, right?
What's What's the coolest like mind body
deck that you could imagine? Because
we've been watching Dazzling Aurora all
weekend.
>> Yeah, there's got to be so many new
options with Aurora. That's going to be
definitely for sure. be really excited
to see something like that.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Of course, I know a
lot of people out there at home are
excited for things like a Chaos and
Order domain pairing. Of course, there's
just so many cool interactions. And, you
know, I got to think all the way back to
Origins as well. When you look at the
like Twisted Fate champion unit that we
were given that seemed a little awkward
because you couldn't unlock that um that
order effect because, you know, a legend
didn't exist yet, but apparently we're
going to be getting one. Yeah, I
actually remember how much people were
excited about that twisted fade and like
wait, what is coming up that this could
happen and now we're finding it out.
>> And of course, we have to at least talk
about the last one. So, Fury and Calm.
Now, we've talked about how Fury is been
a little misrepresented, but as we
already know, Sandy Sherman here, we're
going to watch with Rengar, which has
the Fury domain, of course, actually
making this top eight performance. So,
I'm excited to see maybe it comes to
rise when it's paired with something
incredibly strong, a domain that we keep
talking about. If you go back to the
most played cards here in Vancouver,
things like Zonia's Hourglass and
Guardians Angel are included in that
domain. So now with the aggressiveness
that Fury can bring to the table and the
defensive counter ability of green as
well.
>> Yeah, that's going to be really
interesting. I remember during set one,
I actually was like, it would be so cool
if these two colors were together and
people like, yeah, that's why they're
not. They're like, but it's going to be
exciting to see what players can do with
it.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Now, of course, we're
also going to get a little bit of
information hopefully from uh Radiance.
Um, not too much to be said about that
one, but you know, I'm excited. As soon
as we get some more uh technical
difficulties managed with, we'll get
that brought to you back. So, let we can
even focus back to our top cut scenario.
Okay, so we have Rockllo versus Sam D.
Sherman. So, we're going to go ahead and
show off the bracket here so we can at
least talk about not just that match,
but on the same side of that bracket, so
everybody paying attention to the top,
we have, of course, the secret sauce.
houses are big on that Master Yi and our
first seed versus Bow Bows here playing
Ireelia. What do you think about that
matchup?
>> I feel like that's going to be so
interesting. Obviously, these both are
calm decks and can just see so much
might. And honestly, we've kind of seen
how these might increasing decks can
have some really interesting gameplay.
>> Interesting gameplay, I think, is the
name of the game for sure.
>> Oh, that is for sure. Yeah. Now, on the
other side of the bracket, I have to
just kind of bring up and, you know,
preface
uh we have Allen's EQ, of course, on
Diana versus Arto on Ireelia, which I
think is going to be a tough match up
for both of those players, but of
course, we know that Allen is very
tailored towards fighting against these
calm decks. Meanwhile,
>> man, Ali versus Dewali on the other
side. That's a rematch from Swiss today,
by the way. Uh, I mean very well that
bottom bracket could be either way. I do
believe I know depending how these games
go, we could see a lot of rematches and
some fantastic matches between some of
these RQ winners. I mean, this bracket
is definitely a difficult one.
>> The just I just can't believe in the
fact in general that we have three of
our returning regional qualifier
champions in the same bracket and not a
single one of them has to play each
other in this first round. It means that
there's potentiality where Dewali and
Allen DQ have to play against each other
if they continue to move on, you know,
depending on what that storyline looks
like. Meanwhile, Sam D. Sherman on the
other side of the bracket could
potentially ride his way all the way to
the finals. But we're going to make sure
and we'll get our uh video fixed for
everybody at home hopefully. But we are
going to go ahead and send it to our
casters because we do not want to delay
our top eight any longer.
All right, guys. It's Alex here
>> and I'm Silverfuse here
>> and we're going to be talking about this
finals here. Well, we're not quite in
the finals yet. We are in the
quarterfinals, I should say. And I'm
actually super excited as you are as
well because we do have Azir on the
table here. So, let's take a look at the
first deck here as we get ready to get
into this quarterfinal matchup. We have
Azir versus Rengar. I couldn't be more
excited.
>> Oh, absolutely. to see a Rengar, not
only from just anyone, we're seeing it
from Sam D. Sherman, who has actually
already won on Draven before.
>> Yeah, I was in Las Vegas. I watched it
happen and uh to be completely honest
with you, it was one of those metas
where a lot of people expected Draven to
do well. You had almost that miracle
Draven and uh with Battering Ram and
everything. And uh Sandy Sherman said,
"No, no, no. I got my own flavor on
that. I got my own take on that. I think
that this is the best way to play
Draven. I think that this is the best
way to play Fury." And that's exactly
what you saw on the screen here. We do
have rock low and they are on Azir.
>> Absolutely love this take from Azir
overall. Of course, we've talked about
Vi all weekend being very strong. And we
also have so many utility pieces here
from the cold the week for instance as a
one of and Ong Guard as a one of as well
just for that extra surprise factor as a
whole.
>> You do see an aggressive setup here with
the arena's greatest. It would have
served Azir and Rocklo very very well
throughout the course of this
tournament. We still do have potentially
some matchups with Dazzling Aurora
upcoming, but in the meantime here it's
going to be about closing out these
games quickly and also trying to manage
the aggression from Sam Sherman.
>> Absolutely. So, notably the salvage is
going to be a little bit hard to find
anything for, but let's take a look
closer into the Rengar list. First thing
is is we have determined Sentry. This is
a card that we really haven't seen
anyone take advantage of as you can't
return it from the base. So, a lot of
players have said, "Ooh, if I have a one
might unit, it's just not going to be
worth it." But Sam says, "You know what?
I can actually do a lot with this deck
because of the pride stalker passive
from Rengar. Being able to give units an
extra might for each unit that you play
each turn. And then on top of that, we
have the Emperor's Das as well is a
battlefield that is key into getting
extra value for this determined sentry."
And also that determined sentry won't
just be stranded because you do have the
grim apothecary as well. That grim
apothecary can be used to bring back
that sentry if required. It's just one
of the options here. But there is a card
I do want to shout out here. It is one
of the best in the new set and that is
thrill of the hunt. If you're going to
be playing Rengar, it's all about the
three of thrill of the hunt. This is an
absolutely remarkable ability. One of
the best of the entire set. It is one to
keep an eye on. Absolutely a great
signature spell overall and I just love
all the interaction that we have in this
deck as well from in the form of
sabotage for instance is often seen to
hit Aurora but it can hit so much more.
It can hit gear. It can hit spells. It
can stop removal against your board
overall. So a really nice tech choice
there. There's two more things I want to
highlight here. One of which being three
of Kai'Sa survivor. We have seen Kai'Sa
survivor being a major contributor to
the success of many of the Fury decks
this weekend. For anyone that thought
that Kaiser Survivor was losing
relevance, you would be wrong.
>> So, I have a question for you. We have a
already a regional champion here against
a fourtime Azir best of player. Who do
you think is going to take this?
>> You're asking me a near impossible
question. My heart tells me Azir, but my
body it's telling me Rengar because I do
think that honestly these decks are
incredibly welldesigned. I love the
punch first here as well. double
sabotage, which we know can be
remarkably uh effective at essentially
not only getting information, but of
course being incredibly disruptive. I'm
not entirely sure if we're ready to see
the matches, but I think we are actually
ready to see the matches. So, let's go
to it here. Let's get into the action as
we get started in this quarterfinal
match.
First, okay, we got the first
battlefields here. Round of eight, we
have the playoffs. This is game one. And
we have Azir versus Rengar.
>> Just waiting for the feed here. And we
got it. There's the fist bump. It's Hall
of Legends vers against the Emperor's
Diaz here.
Hall of Legends is going to be an
extremely valuable battlefield for the
Azir player because what it allows you
to do is allows you to conquer. And once
you actually activate your legend in
order to generate the sand soldier,
you're able to then conquer that,
refresh your legend, and then actually
do it again, which is extremely
valuable. Generates a lot of momentum
for you. And then, of course, we do have
the Emperor's Das. Now, the the
advantage of the Emperor's Das is that
you're able to conquer that battlefield
and then bounce the unit back to your
hand for a single uh rune, resulting in
you leaving a sand soldier present.
Ironically, both Rocklo and Sam D
Sherman can take advantage of the
Emperor's Dice.
>> And something to note here is that we
did not find the equipment here for
Rocklo. Just a tough start overall ish
just no equipment so early. I also want
to note that on that hall of legends
that for pride stalker it doesn't do
anything for the Rengar. So this only
benefits Rockllo.
>> Absolutely. Rengar is going to be a
passive ability does not need to be
exhausted at any point in time. We do
have a sand soldier coming into play
here as Sami Sherman takes over the
turn.
>> I hope I shuffle those. And this
determined sentry is exactly what we
wanted to see here from Sam D Sherman
because we have uh we were able to have
two drop two uh drops on the turn one
being able to really put a lot of
pressure on the board expecting to get
some early points here.
>> It's one of those situations as well
with both of these players knowing that
the leadup here is going to uh probably
run through dowsing aurora control decks
and etc. So they design their main deck
to be aggressive. They know what their
decks are good at. And now you're in a
position, well, you got two aggrocentric
decks against one another. Sami
Sherman's thinking out their play here.
Looks like we can see a punch first in
hand. A great combat trick for the
future.
>> The irresistible faith folk as well.
Incredibly uh disruptive. Not quite in
this given situation and this board
state. It looks like determined sentry
is going to go into the emperor's dis.
>> Will we see the balance with the sand
soldier left? It looks like we will
>> have a sand soldier.
>> Absolutely. Just getting the sand
soldier here. Leaving two my on the
board rather than leaving one. On top of
that, we're able to replay this sentry
in the future whenever we want.
>> And an important consideration here is
that the Emperor's Das does say that uh
you actually play a two might sand
soldier and that play does trigger the
pride stalker buff from Rengar which
does improve the might of the
irresistible faith folk. And we do see a
second one come down as well.
>> And the inferna as well. So we'll go
ahead and move in here with the
irresistible fo. And with its ability,
we are able to move another unit in. So
at four might, we are able to conquer
this and take care of the sand soldier
as well.
>> It's like a bunny charm almost in some
ways. It's a charming little Is that a
rabbit? I'm not sure.
>> Squirrel rabbit.
>> Looks like something in Bandalwood. Not
sure what it is, but uh also look at
this board from Sam Sherman right now. I
feel like this is exactly where Rengar
wants to be. It has to be a comfort zone
for sure, especially with Ozer missing
that first equipment as well. It's going
to have to really battle to get back on
this board.
>> I think I see a BF sword there. We do
see the BF sword
and the BF sword is going to come down
and we are going to get the sand soldier
with weapon master equipped with that
sword. passing turn. Double uh points
held here.
>> And the VF sword is one of the stronger
options here for Azir just because it is
usually a Hieromite unit and with Pride
Stalker.
>> We'll have to see what Sam D. Sherman
puts on the board next.
>> Taking out the turn. They did get the
hold points there.
>> This is five. Yes.
Just double checking that might there.
Five with a BF sword. Have to decide
what to do here. Can bring these back if
needed.
>> Yeah, that BF sword does provide a lot
of utility throughout the game. It's an
initial high cost, but with every sand
soldier, you're able to uh get a lot of
value from the might being generated
there.
>> You could consider returning. Yep. I was
going to say the irresistible faithful
could be returned.
>> Sam's soldier could as well
>> and then you could uh Yeah, that's
absolutely true.
>> We do know we have the determined sentry
in board. However, getting all these
price buffs isn't going to do all that
much until we want to attack in again.
>> And we're bringing in the sand soldier
with the other one. And we are going to
have the Rengar come in from the
champion zone. And that is going to take
out the sand soldier. Sam D Sherman is
taking control of the board state here
and it is going to be the Rengar that
gets the Pride Stalker buff.
>> Sand Soldier comes back. It's notable
that the Emperor's Das cannot be used on
this turn because you held it and you
have to conquer to get the effect.
>> And something that's really interesting
to see here is although we are playing
an aggressive deck on Sami Sherman's
side, we're essentially playing as an
aggressive control deck. It's very
token, which I love these type of style
decks because you have so much
flexibility and utility and just getting
that little bit of extra might moving
units in. And we're seeing how tough it
is to be in Rocklo's spot. Now,
>> I like the thought that Sam is giving to
this play here. You could you could play
the the uh the determined sentry down,
but that one might unit, that one cost
one might unit could be valuable to
apply a might increase using the Pride
Stucker uh buff in the next turn, right?
Okay, cuz you can play it down, start
buffing up your units, and then perhaps
push into a battlefield. So, he's trying
to determine whether or not playing it
is the correct call. And it looks like
he is going to play it down and pass
turn.
>> I'm wondering what we are looking to
play this determined sentry along with
the Rengar. Of course, we have to get
we're getting to that seven might. So,
it looks like if we're thinking if
there's um potentially an arise here,
But there's something
>> there's an arizon in hand,
>> but you might get a little more value. I
mean, you're not in desperation yet. You
could consider trying to play out the
equipment still.
You might be able to actually play
equipment and arise.
>> That would definitely be ideal.
>> Might have been a soul soul uh sword in
hand.
There it is. And then you arise. Yep.
That's going to be the most high value
play. You even have one up if you want
to send another sand soldier down as
well.
>> Yep. And Arise, we're going to be
playing two Sandra or two sand soldier
units for each equipment that we have.
Two mites and then we ready two of them.
>> And they do have weapon master as well.
And that brutalizer is going to give
them an additional buff if equipped for
this turnover.
>> I think it will which one to ready.
Okay. Mhm. So he said he was thinking
which ones he wants to ready here of big
decision overall.
>> That sand soldier with a BF sword and a
brutalizer is going to come in.
>> Yep. Coming in for a nine might here.
>> Punch first. Plus five might.
It's on the ring there.
That's enough to hold that battlefield.
>> So, one of the ways that you counter
punch first is by just sending a little
bit more might than your opponent, just
like what we just saw. So, this is a
very well calculated move by Rocklo.
>> Yes.
>> Soldier comes down here fully exhausted.
>> The equipment's there.
thinking
>> hidden card options here. Of course,
hidden blade always on the table.
>> Guards as well.
>> Now, I'm really interested to see the
way that Sam Sherman decides to navigate
this. Um, still has a lot of options on
the table as a whole. We did find some
body rooms there which could be very
helpful.
Rockwell is behind here but still not
out when you have all that equipment.
Another Arise completely changes the
board state. Punch first was utilized to
repel that initial attack. I'm sure
Rockler would have liked to have taken
that battlefield, taken out that Rengar.
>> And we do also have Azir still a
possibility in the future as well.
>> That Azir Sovereign is a fantastic
legend for trying to close out the game,
but from one point might not be the
right time.
Rocklo doesn't look too phased though.
>> Doesn't look too phased at all. So the
question becomes for Sam. Do we want to
contest this Emperor's Das or not?
>> Inferno comes in. We're going to reveal
there. And it is going to be Guards.
So Guards is going to play a sand
soldier.
You see that weapon master applied.
>> Nope. And inferno coming in here for
three might. Isn't quite able to
overtake this yet. Sam has to decide if
there is something else he wants to add
to this battlefield as well.
>> Also notable is that that it is a
brutalizer that was attached.
>> Very important as well.
>> Sam thinking this through does have
available runes.
>> So you have seven seven and I have
three.
>> Yes.
>> Yep. Seven to three as they stated. And
it's Niti. So this is going to come in
ambushing. If this is successful in
winning this combat, it will draw a
card.
>> It's not successful in winning the
combat. Well, the combat's won, but it
has to survive in order to get that
draw.
>> And we can potentially see Emperor's Das
being used here.
>> Has to decide. Yep.
>> Yep. There it is.
>> And again, an Inferno coming back to
hand is a great option.
>> And we go to six.
And with this irresistible faolk is
going to target another sand soldier
moving this. So we go ahead and kill the
one with the sword and the Rengar is
able to take that down while retreating
back as well.
>> Very well played by Sam Sherman
showcasing why they are a former
regional winner in Las Vegas
and Arise might be one of your few ways
out here.
rides would give so much value here
overall.
>> We don't have a zero out, so we can't
move all those tokens together, but Sam
is at six points right now. Is looking
to reconquer for a potential win here.
We have to find something for Rocklow.
And with the rise being off the table,
>> it becomes really tough here.
>> How many cuts do you have in that?
>> Two. Yeah, this hold here will take Sam
D. Sherman 27 points and then a little
stroll into the battlefield to win that
eighth point.
>> I've absolutely loved the way that Sam
has navigated this overall. Taking
advantage of the irresistible fave folk
over and over again. Definitely been the
MVP of the game and just the comfort
level of this deck has been so cool to
see from Sam. Yeah, realistically
Rockler will be able to clear that sand
soldier, but there is a lot of might
coming at him on the next turn for that
double conquer. Not to mention, you do
get the additional might reach from the
Pride Stalker depending on how many
cards are in Sam's hand. You can buff up
those cards as you play cards down into
base and then utilize that push with the
additional might. Also noting that
inferno does have assault, so it can
reach a little higher than perhaps may
look like on the board state now.
>> Uh
yeah, pay to ready. Yep.
>> And does go ahead and pay for that Hall
of Legends to rer the Emperor of Sands.
>> We have a hidden card play to try to
hold down one of the battlefields to try
to discourage Sam from taking that
there.
Good chance you're going to hold the
Emperor's uh Das.
Okay. Uh hold the seven. Yes.
So needs to find out a way to conquer
this final battlefield for that eighth
point. Has the Rengar available, a sand
soldier as well as inferna. There is a
hidden card in the way. So has to
calculate their might very carefully
here.
>> Hidden blade always a potential option
>> yeah likely and unlikely that rock would
want to use hidden blade like on his own
token naturally. So, you'd expect Hidden
Blade to be utilized. And uh Sam, it
might give Sam more options, too. A lot
of his cards are ambushed. So, it's not
the end of the world if he does see two
additional draws.
>> Yep. Has three cards to work with here.
Uh with units can add additional might.
Has to be careful where this might goes
because of potential hidden blade. So,
has to do the calculations here. The
other option would be to try to hold
this other battlefield if we are worried
about hidden blade as it can only be
targeting that battlefield when it is a
hidden card like that. So, we need to
take a look at both of these options. It
is a bit of a fork here. So, we have to
find out, can we play around a potential
hidden blade? And how do we do that?
>> You could even maybe try to do something
like something cheeky like uh I don't
know, you play a couple cards down,
increase the might of the Rengar Trophy
Hunter, try a challenge.
>> That'll prevent I'm just thinking.
>> Yes.
>> Two cards in hand for Rocklo.
We don't know Sam's hand, so it's hard
to see what his plan could possibly be.
I
>> think I saw a groomary. That's not quite
what we're looking for here.
>> Does have ambush though.
>> Does have ambush. That's three extra
might.
>> Still trying to get a peek into that
hand.
>> Adding up all the might here together.
Now, at reaction speed for the Grim
Apothecary, you could even consider
trying to bait out that hidden card and
then reacting with the Grim Apothecary
and perhaps pulling that card to hand.
>> And also on top of that, because we have
Grim Apothecary available, Pride Stalker
does work with that because it is
considered a played unit. So, we could
have a surprise amount of might come out
with that Grim Apothecary.
Silence on the stage as Sam considers
the
>> trip
or so. Thank you.
>> Tough decision here. Really having to
decide, do I want to contest this
battlefield or not?
>> I think you can test it. I think
Rockllo's in a position. He's on the
back foot. You can seal the game right
here.
And the problem is even if you try to
think, okay, what if I just hold this
next one? You absolutely can. Okay,
>> that's the initiate, we do have more
than five might available. It's going to
be a drawn card.
>> Draw card.
>> Yeah,
>> more options. also putting that might on
the sand soldier from the initiate,
which is might be a way that we see this
sand soldier sent in to potentially
well along with other units of course to
potentially try to break this hold. But
diversifying the mic here is really
important because we need to play around
hidden blade if we were to go for that.
>> And one of the challenges they're trying
to hold is there are two brutalizers on
the other side. We do have the hidden
blade. It's going to target the Rengar.
Do we see a reaction here?
potentially grim apothecary potentially
says actually I would like to draw these
cards as well.
>> Yes, he's drawn cards.
>> Uh, okay.
>> Let's see if these will help us out.
>> Six to six. Yes,
>> Grim Apothecary does not have to bounce
a unit back. It may bounce a unit back.
There's still two up here for Rocklo and
we are running Ong Guard in the deck. We
don't know the hand for sure, but Ong
Guard could be a big piece here. If Sam
decides to throw a ambush unit out,
>> so Grim Apothecary does come down. It is
going to do the Pride Stalker buff. An
additional Might's being applied. Who
does it go on? It's going to go on
Inferna.
>> The Inferno.
>> Hidden Blade on the Inferno. Two cards
drawn.
>> Yes.
>> Now, here's where a determined sentry
could be potentially interesting.
>> Oh, no. It can't be played during the
showdown. So, you need an ambush. And it
is just going to be a straightup trade.
>> Yes. And now we'll be able to re-equip
these in the future here as well. So,
Sam Sherman deciding that I need to
bring these back because I have to go
for a double conquer now. The hold is no
longer an option.
Rocklo could potentially start to climb
back, but you need you need an Arise. It
looks like we're going next. Yeah,
that's the Dor and Shield. I think that
was top decked as well. That's not going
to be enough at all.
>> Yep.
>> Going to the second game. First game
taken by Sam D. Sherman.
>> Yeah, once again, Azir not really
finding that early equipment. Found it a
little bit too late. So, we'll have to
see what Rocklo is able to do to try to
clinch the second game. I think one of
the key moments there, so up there, one
of the key moments there as well was I
think Rockwell committed a lot of
resources in that punch first exchange.
Punch first just kind of really took the
wind out of Rockh.
>> And this time we do find that Doran
Shield able to get the sand soldier out
right away.
>> It's a good first turn. That's exact
exactly what Rockloo wants to do. This
is an arena's greatest game, so we do
start with the one point from each. It
looks like both have declared that
point.
It's so hard like if I put like this,
you know, like
>> because some people want to see the
might, some want to see this. It's like
I can't like I can't hold it like this
if you want.
>> Yeah. Here I This is This is what I
usually do. So you can see the R and the
M. But
>> the roof.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah. Now Starspring is a very important
battlefield here. Um
>> how do you think Rengar can use that to
maximum effectiveness? Well, the big
thing is it also kind of adds ganking to
units and we have very cheap units that
we can play that can move them very
easily. We have the Kinko Initiate
coming out. Not drawing us any cards
this time as we don't have any mighty
units. However, it is a nice turn one
play going second.
>> We do have the guardian angel coming out
here. Sand Soldier as well.
>> Rocklo choosing not to go into a
battlefield here.
So this guardian angel is on the
sideboard. So this was one of these
sideboarded cards in
a much better start for Rocklo here. A
lot more the comfort zone. We'll have to
see what Sam Sherman's hand looks like.
It could be a big difference. Uh we
aren't likely going to be playing the
Rengar anytime soon. Looks like if
unless we just don't have cards
available to us. We see Niti in hand
there for us.
>> Yeah, Nit. Oh, we have an auction as
well. That's actually a big deal.
Probably a little bit too much of an
additional cost to pay right now though.
>> That two uh that two power is a
significant price to pay.
>> Yes, but I bet it will come into play.
>> Just an auction and he's paying it and
steal your guardian angel.
>> Guardian angel being stolen. Now's also
fantastic for the BF sword as well.
>> Guardian angel's good hit. We did see
the star spring trigger as well. So the
Kinko initiate is back to base.
I mean stealing guardian angel is I mean
outside of Aurora of course one of the
prime targets is guardian angel. It's so
good into Ireelia. It's really good into
Azir here as well.
>> Do you think that will die this game?
>> It's it's hard to say. The thing is as
well is that uh Brocklo had a fantastic
start even with this uh this brutalizer.
This is a strong start, but Sam D.
Sherman with that auction has definitely
taken control back, but Rock's not out.
And also dramping to power is
significant here
for Sam Sherman.
>> Well, big swing in. That's going to be
enough.
>> Well, Octron did die this turn. Kind of.
Not exactly.
>> It's kind of sad that Rocklo does not
get the equipment. He gets the equipment
back, but it's in his trash.
Sand soldier does come out as well.
>> Trying to get a peek into the hand now,
but he is moving those cards.
>> He's going really fast there.
>> Uh I thought I saw discipline in there
as well.
>> Lots of combat tricks will help a lot in
this matchup for sure. There's so much
might available as we see these cards
come down.
>> So that sand soldier now sits at four
might.
>> We see a punch first in hand for Sam.
>> We've seen a lot of Damps from Sam
already, but at the same time,
>> it's been very effective. We have
Inferno being played into the base.
Pride stalker buff being considered here
is given to the auction comes on in.
It's five
>> discipline.
>> It's discipline plus two might draw one.
>> So we're at six might now. Six verse
five.
>> Might be looking to use the punch first
here. Potentially
>> Apothecary perhaps
>> that also works.
>> And also you have the pride stalker
buff.
>> Uh bounce itself and send a back to
base.
>> Yes.
uh and get plus one here.
>> Oh, very interesting play there.
>> So, a great play here is that with the
Grim Apothecary did bounce itself.
Starring was also triggered. So, we move
back the Auction here. So, was able to
save all of his units and that's a great
reason why Grim Apothecary has been so
great and unleashed.
>> That was an absolutely phenomenal play
by Sam Sherman.
Very well practiced with both the
battlefield and of course the units
being played.
Turn switch over over to Rocklo.
>> You hold the three because
>> this game so far is going much better
for Rocklo. The equipment present does
give him a little bit of optionality.
Let's see what he draws.
>> A lot of runes available this turn. If
we can get some good equipment out and
start really buffing up these sand
soldiers, potentially setting up for an
Arise in the future. We It looks like we
have a guardian angel in hand ready for
the future.
considering moving a sand soldier in to
start a showdown.
>> Yeah, maybe looking at contesting this
Kinko initiate. Sam is tapped out, so
that's very important to note that this
should just be a conquer ready to go.
>> One of the sand soldiers down to four.
>> The thing is though is you cannot count
out Rengar and leaving units in the
battlefields. You're just staring at
that champion zone. You're thinking,
well, the trophy hunter might come
hunting.
>> Absolutely. And we will see Azir come
out here with that guardian angel once
again. We do know that Sam is running
multiple auctions. So, it'd be
interesting to see if we have another
stolen guardian angel as it was a prime
target. It is not being equipped here
though.
>> Now, with the guardian angel, it is a
sideboarded card. We're not sure how
many have been sideboarded in. it is
often held for the Azir sovereign. Uh so
h that being potentially the last one or
the like well perhaps not I didn't see
another one in hand. One of the reasons
why he may not have attached it is
because he does want to save it for the
Azir sovereign which might be a play
he's considering in the near future.
>> Still with four runes up here. Taking a
good look at this board. Both of these
decks do want to be fairly aggressive
overall. Of course, Sam kind of played
that more re reactive in some ways. It
was like a proactive reactive in some
ways with those irresistible fay folks.
Doesn't have that option this time. So,
it doesn't have those control tools the
same way that we saw before. We do see
the Azir sovereign come out, but it is
not equipped and we are tapped out. Uh
Sam is running into reactions such as
challenge in the deck. So, we could see
this Azir potentially get killed. We'll
see what happens. It's very notable that
that Azir Sovereign can also be
accelerated, which is absolutely huge.
It looks like he's considering doing the
attachment of the guardian angel here.
>> Yes. And these players do have access to
each other's deck list at this point, so
they got to look it over. They don't get
to look at it right now, but does know
that challenge could potentially be in
the hand.
>> Like this play a lot from Rocklo. You
need to protect that Azir sovereign. It
is one of your win conditions, one of
the ways that you can uh take two
battlefields in the later stages of the
game.
>> It looks like we do see Thrill the Hunt
in there in the hand as well. So, we
could potentially blink one of these
units, including our Auction.
And just like we said prior for Sam,
this is now a turn where Rocklo is
completely out of runes, unable to
respond. You're a little vulnerable in
these situations in Riftbound,
>> especially when you're a deck with calm
in it. You're so used to being able defy
or to play on guard or to play
discipline. You usually have so many
different options and right now they're
just not going to be there. So Sam, if
he's able to figure out a way to deal
with this board, could become in a
dominant spot.
One of the challenges with Defy as well
is unfortunately it will not stump stop
something like a punch first due to its
power cost. That might be something that
Rockler has been thinking about. But you
are right. Usually as a comp player like
you're prepared to make plays and react
to the the board situation. We saw it
with the discipline prior. One of the
best reactions of the game. But here he
just has to sit and watch. And I'll be
honest with you, you might look at that
sand soldier and think to yourself, "Ah,
who cares if a sand soldier goes down?"
But with that Azir sovereign, those sand
soldiers really do make a difference
because you're able to reposition them
and make bigger pushes in terms of their
might.
>> Yeah, I wonder if we're considering
trying to push points here with the
inferna. We could technically play
Thrill the Hunt on it and then go over
to the other battlefield, but that's
pretty expensive for that point. Uh
there's usually going to be better uses
of it, but we do have aggressive lines
that we could take into development. I'm
really interested to see the way that
Sam decides to navigate this. And we
could actually do it with the Aon too
where we just blink the Aon and take the
guardian angel as well.
>> We are in top eight. These players do
need to take their time to ensure that
they're making the most optimum plays
they can. It looks like Oxan going into
the Sand Soldier and Inferna into
Starring. That's going to be a two
points scored, bringing Sandy Sherman to
five
>> and playing that pretty quickly there
because Rocklo is tapped out. Both
players understand there is no reaction
window. They've played the game enough
where they can just play like normal.
Grim apothecary coming out to save this
inferna. Oxon will be left and we do
have enough for thrill of the hunt which
I would be not I would be unsurprised if
that's what the plan is here.
>> Playing it reactively rather than
proactively is definitely a better way
to go about it. We do see Ash come out
and Sam does have an option to play any
reactions here, including that potential
Thrill of the Hunt.
>> That Ash is a great card. It gives a ton
of information. Looks like we're going
to be having a thrill of the hunt being
played. That window being utilized to
thrill the hunt Aan
>> here. Pay the two orange and steal the
guardian angel.
>> And guardian angel being stolen once
again. Uh
>> I get a plus one. and I'll put it on
auction.
>> And why can you play it there?
>> Thrill the hunt plays to any battlefield
>> as our players are discussing. Indeed,
thrill the hunt
will be. Yeah,
>> first your ash thing will resolve.
>> It is a conquer because it is on the
opponent's turn. They're able to take
that point.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm good for that.
>> And we finally do get to take a look at
that hand. We see the niti. We see the
punch first. We know about the inferna
from earlier and of course there is a
Kaiso survivor in there as well.
>> That Kaiso Survivor as an accelerate
card could be useful as he looks to
close out these uh these final points
for the game.
>> And once again, we love the play of the
thrill of the hunt onto the auction.
Part of the reason because I pointed out
beforehand, but also
>> I love when that happens.
>> And uh taking the guardian angel away
from the Oz course. You said that was
the main thing that you want to hit with
Guardian Angel. And like I said, having
that reaction window to be able to play
the Thrill beforehand is fantasters
card draw. Kai'Sa offers card draw
potentially. The Infernals, Inferno is
definitely the lowest value. Punch first
though, also very high value. Overall,
this is a tough decision. Personally,
I'd be looking to eliminate card draw
one way or the other, and that would be
in the form of the Kai'Sa or the Niti.
Of course, the Nitali with the ambush
does make her very easy to play in for
only three energy, but does cost one
power.
>> Looks like Inferna has been chosen. It's
been banished.
>> Then, uh,
>> so the reason why you might pick Inferna
here is because it is a low energy unit.
It does really work well with Pride
Stalker, for instance. So, I could see
that's why we decided to manage the
Inferna.
>> I do see that Rocklo is identifying that
we don't want Sam D. Sherman to be
getting to six points going into that
next turn.
Does commit a lot of resources and now
Sam's hand is now two cards larger.
Well, one card larger. We did banish
one.
>> Having our eyes on the Starring going up
to five here. A very close game going to
six once again. Sam's going to have to
have a big turn here to make sure that
we are able to clear these battlefields.
Azir still hanging back out in the back.
>> You do have the trophy hunter available
from the champion zone for Sam D
Sherman.
>> That can be played directly to either of
the battlefields if chosen.
>> And make sure we don't forget about this
Ash down here. Azir and Ash, I guess
they don't really like each other that
much because they're staying really far
away from each other.
They I think uh that that's actually
hilarious. Absolutely.
Really far from each other here. Almost
like, hey, forget that this card's here.
We do see an irresistible faith folk
drawn, but it is not going to be there's
no way to ready it here, but it has done
so much work moving units in the past.
>> I Yeah, you're actually you're right.
Ash is like literally in the champion
zone there. Almost. Almost.
Not quite.
>> Sam Sherman carefully considering this
play. So much is on the line here for
these players in top eight.
>> A big thing is there's not a lot of
reactive tools. I think that's another
reason why Rocklo decided to take out
that Inferno. Uh we have Niti as an
ambush of course, but we don't have we
have a lot of units that aren't really
reactive. We don't really have the
spells that we'd look for that are
reactive
>> there.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. But one of the challenges here too
is of course this turn looks very
different had he scored that sixth point
on the last turn.
>> Six
>> exactly
>> and we can contest this battlefield with
Rengar.
>> Rengar is going to come in. They're
going to score two points here.
>> We only did have one rune up from
Rocklo.
>> Grim apothecary played down. Looks like
it's more of a hold formation here.
going to have to clear both in this
given circumstance. Holding will result
in the win and Sam would move on. This
is a critical turn here.
>> Absolutely. So going for a hold on
either one wins this game. We have lots
of equipment available. So we can look
at cascading equipment potentially.
That's often a common thing that we see
in these lists. I don't think we have a
rise in hand. It looks like was that a
coal the week that we saw?
>> Yeah, but you do have the soul sword
here. you're going to be able to
generate a token and then Azir can
utilize that token despite the fact that
it will come in exhausted in the base.
So you have a little more reach than
maybe it looks like. Here you can also
attach the brutalizer to that token
being generated
>> thanks to weapon master.
>> We did recycle runes ready to use
floating, right?
>> I have three uh two floating.
>> Yeah,
>> I have three uh three power floating.
>> Yes, three power floating there to use
this equipment in the future.
This is a do or die moment here for
Rockl.
>> Yes. Most take must take care of both of
these battlefields.
>> Now against body, we do see one rune up
on Sam D. Sherman. You know what that
means though, right?
>> Oh, punch first all day.
>> You know, punch first is available here.
And this is really fascinating. If Sam
holds, he wins. If Rockclaw clears both
battlefields, he wins. Well, not if he
clears. He has to actually conquer them.
>> That's what I meant by clear. Yeah,
you're using more precise language. My
apologies. But yeah, this is actually a
very, very intense turn. I encourage
both these guys to take their time on
their decision-m.
>> Yeah, I'll give everything to Ash.
>> Okay. And that's 10. Is it?
>> Uh, nine.
>> Nine might on the board to the seven
here. I passed.
If you're going to punch first, now's
the time
>> only needs to hold one of these
battlefields. So, it's a really crucial
decision here of which one do you want
to hold. As I mentioned prior though,
that is your sovereign with a token
generated could show more power than
perhaps expected on that Rengar. So,
we'll have to see what Sam decides here.
>> It is really tough to say because you
don't want to make this equipment go
back onto the Azir. So, you might
consider giving up this battlefield for
that reason, but it is it is so close. I
can see why we're taking so much time
for this. Absolutely a critical decision
here for Sam
>> on this turn here. You're right though
because if that equipment gets sent back
to the base, you can just pay all the
power you want, re-equip it all. If
you're able to close out the game, the
cost doesn't really matter
and it might just be enough to send you
above that Rengar on the other side as
well, but we'll have to see.
>> This is
>> I like this decision here. I think
saying I don't want you to get the
equipment back. However, of course,
there is a
>> call the week. Azir goes in, gets that
eighth point, and Rocklow does make the
miraculous comeback here to tie this
series up. Absolutely unbelievable.
>> That was such a tremendously close game.
We go to game three.
>> So, something to note is cold of the
week was something that was going to be
really hard to play around. Was kind of
forked there. It's really easy to say
like, "Oh, why didn't Sam play around
this cold a week?" Well, it was the best
really he could do there because it's
either all these weapons get cascaded or
the coal the week happens. There is one
coal the week in the main board. So
playing around that and also does know
the sideboard too. So
>> scar point.
>> Yes,
>> that was his best option.
>> We do have an arena's greatest game.
Both players do take the point on their
beginning phase. Irresistible faith folk
making its presence known. And also
Trifarium War Camp here is just as good
for Sam as it is for Rocklow.
>> Yeah, usually as an Azir player, you
have all these sand soldier tokens in
the Trifarian War Camp and usually
against like other decks, h you got the
advantage there. With Sam Sherman,
you're right, it is beneficial for them.
>> Absolutely.
And taking a look at this hand here, a
lot of three energy units potentially. I
was going to say Sam is really good at
just like teasing us with potentially
being able to see the hand.
>> I see that punch first there.
>> Punch first. Yeah,
>> one one energy, two power. What can that
be there?
>> Man, if if this has
>> potentially in Italy,
>> this wouldn't have three. That would be
so scary. You play two units. GG
>> turn one. GG's.
>> Yes. Because the way it is that scary is
because the pride stalker
>> suck this up.
>> Yes. What are you playing
>> and it's the grim apothecary coming down
>> as the ambush.
>> And I love this combo here is that
you're able to save your irresistible
faith folk this way. It is so cool to
see it getting the buffing itself for
instance and then throwing that back to
safety and then also just being able to
conquer as well. So it's just a really
cool interaction overall. That play is
exactly why Rengar is phenomenal right
there. You get that a little bit
additional reach on the might and
sometimes it makes all the difference
especially in these early stages. That
is a massive tempo swing in favor of Sam
D Sherman.
>> Could be.
>> And now that we see the irresistible
faith folk of this game, we didn't
really see it the last game. We were
missing it a lot and that's really what
pushed us ahead in the first match. So
there's a good chance that we're going
to continue to see that in the second
one. And it looks like we do have a call
the week in hand for Rocklo once again.
And we saw the work that it did. We do
have a hidden card and that's going to
be the Pike.
>> Yep. Pike ready to go
with that call the week played.
>> Guards comes up. It's accelerated
perhaps based on the price paid. Nope,
not accelerated.
Uh
>> hold three.
>> Yes.
Holding the three here for Sam is really
in the driver's seat in this match.
We'll have to see what Rockllo can do
with the ganking takes the additional
point here with Pike. Such a great card.
>> Yeah, Pike's phenomenal. It's one of the
biggest additions
>> to Fury and you're seeing it across many
different archetypes. It's ability to
gank in there. Obviously coming out from
hidden as well is extremely valuable.
Four to one for Sami Sherman on their
turn. Rocklo Tapto.
>> We also see that pesky Inferna in hand.
A card that has done a lot of work for
these Fury decks this weekend.
Expect to see some development here
potentially.
>> Saw the Axon. That has been a uh a
definite pain for Rocklo.
>> This here is my base. Go.
>> All right. Determined sentry into the
irresistible fa folk.
>> On top of that, inferno as well. A bunch
of might would have been out of there,
but because we weren't moving anything,
didn't need to use those die.
>> Now, in the Trifarian War Camp, those
two cards are a little more mighty than
they traditionally are, which is one of
the benefits of that particular
battlefield.
Yeah, once again Rockless Battlefield
helping Sam out just a bit more because
of not playing against that many
aggressive decks usually does benefit
Azir more often with the Trifarian War
camp, but we have seen multiple players
take advantage of Triarium War camp this
weekend.
>> Rocklo saying that they need a second to
think.
>> Take as much time as you need, my
friend.
>> We do see a discipline in hand there.
likely not going to look to contest this
battlefield just because oh well at
tapped out maybe we will see the contest
here
>> targeting for the draw to see if the
options change here
additional might applied
>> up to five might if we attack in it is
six might
>> now the trifarian war camp doing work
>> all of Sam's runes are exhausted
>> so minus 5 six you have five Yeah,
>> I have the Herald.
>> Double checking the math here. Good to
go.
>> Will we use Azir here potentially?
Our Emperor of Sands.
>> Looks like he's going to attach this,
bring this in. It's going to generate a
token which is going to take advantage
of the Trifarian War camp and this
should allow for the conquer. Very well
played there by Rocklo. Well thought out
there. Generating that extra recruit
with the eye of the herald is enough to
wipe out that battlefield.
>> And I love using the weapon master here
with the Azir so we're able to re-equip
that and be able to move it in the
future while protecting it as well.
>> So I want to see what tricks are up
Sam's sleeve with this irresistible fay
folk. We've seen it do work over and
over again. And first we'll see a
sabotage to reveal the hand. And looks
like we aren't defying it. So we're
either getting rid of the defy or the
brutalizer. We also know about this ash
in hand as well. Now
>> yeah, that's potentially a defy play
there. Don't want to reveal the hand.
Brutalizer is taken away.
>> Little heartbreaking is that brutalizer
of course is extremely valuable. Rocklos
absolutely want want to uh try to
establish as many equipment as possible.
It improves the arise play when that
comes up.
>> So a big thing is Sam's deck does go a
little bit taller than Azir overall does
have ways to refill the hand in the
future with a only twocard hand for
Rocklow that isn't very high value
overall. Of course the Ash is helpful,
but the defy is not really hitting all
that much. It hits Thrill the Hunt for
instance, but that's not even something
that's really needed right now. So if
Sam is able to find a way to navigate
through this game where we are able to
deal with this Trifarian war camp, we
could find ourselves to be in a really
good spot for Samar.
>> Potentially Rengar here. Yep, Rengar is
coming in. It's going to take out the
patrons of the Trifarian War Camp.
>> Rengar trophy hunter is one of the cards
of body that's not called Dowsing
Aurora.
>> Uh I kind of only dies, right? Yeah.
>> And does find the way of course. Inferno
was up to a full four might there. So
the sand soldier cannot even take it
out. What a great play from Sam here.
One of the great things about Rengar is
indeed having access to one of the best
cards in Unleashed is Rengar Trophy
Hunter.
>> Absolutely. We do have the Arise here.
So we can accelerate
two of the tokens that could contest,
but then that Rengar represents a pretty
strong body.
Yeah, we found the value, but the issue
is we lost our equipment and
>> we can't we don't have, you know,
usually you want to have a ton of
equipment just ready for all these sand
soldiers so you just get a little bit
more value from it. But when you don't
have the equipment that you're looking
for, it makes this really tough. Sam is
at six points right now, so the arise
must be played to have a chance at
contesting this.
>> Fortunately, the Eye of the Herald will
help in Trifarian War Camp.
But we know with that one rune up
>> I know. I was just going to say and
unfortunately that defy is not going to
be enough here. We're going to see if we
can take the infernal battlefield here
>> and they're just going to make sure that
uh Okay. Yeah. Going in with the uh the
six.
>> Could decide to punch first here.
That's what we expect to see here.
Poor Inferna not having the assault. So
still only at one might. It is 6 to1
here. Punch first giving five might
potentially.
>> All right, it seems worth it.
>> Okay, punch first does come down. Two
power paid.
>> Trad everything.
>> Yes,
>> everything dies.
>> Sam will not close out the game this
turn, but we'll hold to seven.
>> Well, we got to find
>> Kai'Sa.
>> That's what we want to find as Sam. This
top deck could make a huge difference
here as Kai'Sa would be able to end the
game as we hold to seven and if we can
find a way to accelerate. Pike would
also do it for instance.
>> Darius not going to quite be there just
because we don't have a way to set him
up for that
>> to ready him.
>> We just don't have enough runes.
>> Grill the hunt would also do it. Like
there's so many outs here to win the
game.
>> There's so many ways to win here. So, we
do have the Kinko initiated in hand,
which would allow us to draw one through
the hunt would be a way to win the game
instantly, but also does add a little
bit more value.
>> I'm curious as to how many cards are in
Rocklo's hand. What are the chances
there's a second arise? Can you try to
position for a hold for the trophy
hunter? Cuz you're right, getting over
to that other battlefield without that
Kai'Sa. And it is. Oh, they're going for
the draw. You called it.
>> Will we see a thrill of the hunt here
potentially? Nope. was thinking about
whether or not to pull back. This does
make sense. Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> I wonder what he found though. I mean,
it's another setup for a conquer here.
Azir, once again, these sand soldiers
from Azir can only be played to base and
they aren't readied. And
>> Ash
draw an Ash there.
>> Had an Ash in hand earlier. So, I'm not
sure if it was a second Ash that you saw
or if we drew Yep. Or Ash to see or Azir
coming in to
>> accelerate it. accelerated. Yep. Has to
>> trigger Triarian War camp
>> recruit.
>> I'm two.
>> This is This is my base.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. I know. I know. I
know. I know.
>> Uh yeah, two plus five plus six.
>> Uh yeah, it's eight total here.
>> Eight.
>> You a three.
>> Yeah.
>> I like when they do the math for us.
>> Yeah. Thank you guys.
>> Appreciate you all. And we are going to
get the sand soldier here.
>> Surely I can win from here.
>> I mean, if you have one ambush card, if
you have one ambush, you can show me. I
I'll I'll concede how.
>> It's for the fans.
>> What ambush card? I mean, I have
>> I have a wealth of options here. All
right.
>> That is absolutely phenomenal. Sam D.
Sherman does get the victory over Azir.
We are going to see a Rengar move on
through the top eight.
>> I love seeing that ending there. So much
fun.
>> I like that. These are two players
obviously remarkably talented. Rocklo
has been so successful on Azir. It
doesn't get much better than that. That
was an absolutely remarkable game. What
was something that stood out to you in
that game that ultimately created the
result that we saw there?
>> I we have to talk about irresistible fa.
It did so much being able to use control
tokens essentially and the way that Sam
navigated that. Exceptional.
>> All right, we guys guys, we got more
Riftbound to talk about here cuz we're
going to go into game number two from
the next match here. This is actually
pretty exciting. We're seeing the
quarterfinals really shape up into
something exciting here. I'm actually
really happy that we get to see game two
here because as much as I was excited to
see the Azir versus Rengar because
listen, I love both of those uh those
legends, I also was really excited about
this next matchup.
>> Yep, we'll be getting into that shortly.
>> We have Diana with Dewali. Now, we saw
Dewali earlier here and he's made his
way into the top eight. What stands out
to you from this deck? So a big thing is
Dwali has opted to use the frigid jewel
which is something that a lot of Diana
players have been deciding is this worth
it. It's a very meta- dependent call
overall if you need might to get over
certain units. Also has consult the pass
which is not used in most Diana decks
saying you know we've seen Diana's gas
out multiple times and consult the pass
is a way to hide a card that's outside
of the tide turner but also being able
to draw a little bit extra and it works
better with the frigid duel as well. one
power draw two. Nothing wrong with that.
As we move on to our second deck list
here, we're going to see it's Civer from
Swag YOLO 420. Yeah, this deck is one
that we did see in phenomenal action
earlier into the tournament. I like it a
lot. In the main deck, you do have the
three sabotages, of course, looking to
try to work with the mirror mash
successfully. Anything else for you here
that really stands out? I mean, of
course, we have the Elder Dragon and the
Mindblower that do so much work, but I
really want to take a look at the
harrowing play a unit from your trash,
ignoring its energy cost. Just another
way to get some of these highquality
units back onto the board as we see
Civer sometimes will have the Aurora out
and won't have any more units. So, the
heroing is a good way to counteract
this.
>> What I want to see, I want to see if
Swag Yolo 420 Yaka can win some Swag.
So, let's go to the match as we are
taking over from game number two. We
have Dewali versus Mr. Swag. Let's see
it.
>> I'll play.
>> And of course, we have the Aspirants
climb because that is one of the best
battlefields for Civer as a whole. So,
of course, we have to run it. And of
course, we have the other best
battlefield arguably for Diana as well.
We have the abandoned hall. And it looks
like Dewali did take that first game.
Would have loved to have seen the way
that he navigated that, especially
without using the abandoned hall in that
first game, too. And I really do like
the way Swag Yolo 420 uh plays this
Aurora deck. Multiple options. We saw
some incredible sideboard stuff. We We
actually saw your Weatherman segment
where you discussed it. Nice little fist
bump there. We love that. I I just I
just love that he is such a well
practiced Aurora player and in fact the
only Aurora player in top eight if my
memory serves me correct
>> and does have the Aurora in hand. Has to
pretend like this is a hard decision
when we all know it is not from that
stack deck.
>> Not at all.
>> Hey, Scrier's Bloom coming on down.
That is going to allow him to do a
little bit of a uh prediction a little
later on.
Very efficient turn there overall for
Swag Yellow 420. Yeah.
>> Taking a play here.
>> One of the benefits of playing Diana,
you have three runes. What do you think
you're doing? You're playing Diana.
>> It's one of the best parts about Diana
is having access to a strong turn one
when going second.
>> Swag Yellow 420 considering their play
here. Scrier Bloom likely to Okay, hold
on.
>> Has that Elder Dragon in hand? Is that
two? That's two Elder Dragons in hand.
So knows that if we play Aurora, there
is a 50% chance of mind spplitter and a
50% chance of Elder Dragon. This could
be a little bit of a nightmare
potentially.
>> Seeing a little smile there as well as
they look at their hand and what's been
going on.
Also want to shout out that really fancy
pants aspirin's climb we see down there.
I love it. I love the art in this game
so much.
>> We just saw the mindsplitter there. So
if we do play Aurora, it is going to be
100% hitting the Elder Dragon.
>> Another Scrier's Bloom.
>> So the real nightmare scenario here
would be drawing the Elder Dragon before
playing the Aurora.
And it is a possibility. I have put it
into the universe. I am sorry.
>> Dwalli here looking to take advantage
here. You don't want to allow a Aurora
player, especially in an aspirin climb
game to have any advantage. You want
these early points. Dewali carefully
considering their options here. Again,
we're in the quarterfinals. We're in top
eight. Every single decision carries a
significant amount of weight.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and Dewali being undefeated
so far as well has obviously navigated
this Diana deck despite really difficult
games.
>> Two runes
frigid jewel score point
>> and right away does say yes I do want
this Diana trigger. So, we will be able
to take a look and predict here.
Deciding if he wants to keep this card
or not. If it's a spell, we could
potentially keep it and draw it.
Not only is there a lot on the line,
which of course does in some ways result
in much more conscientious play, but I
think one thing that you realize in the
top eight is that your opponent is
capable of taking uh advantage of every
single opportunity you give. These are
incredibly talented players and not just
because they made it to the top eight,
but in this case and in particular with
what we have here, we have these very
consistent high-performing players from
Riftbound. And so you know that every
single advantage that they will take,
they will.
>> Yes. And for our viewers at home, Dewali
was the winner of the Houston regional
qualifier with Annie.
>> I can't even believe what I'm looking
at. I was just talking about how much I
loved it. And for some reason, Swag a
yolo 420 Yak comes in with the
absolutely massive aspirin climb. It
only gets better from here
>> for sure. And taking a good look once
again at this hand. We could really use
some ramp right now. We need more runes.
>> I don't know why I got so excited.
>> The other Elder Dragon there, there was
a potential that we drew that if we did
not predict it. So now we know that it's
Mindsplitter into Elder Dragon whenever
we do play that Aurora.
>> I'm just thinking in my head, someone
from production, please get him a bigger
one. Please get him a bigger one. What a
bit that would be. An even bigger
aspirin climb. I don't know if they make
them any bigger than that though. Lunar
Boon does come out. Discard one, draw
two.
>> Using a stupify onto our own unit just
to filter through our deck a little bit
more.
may have lost the player audio here.
>> We have a treasure trove in hand
potentially.
>> Stack deck also in hand.
All right.
All right, we're taking a look here at
the Diana play now.
We're going to
Let's see. Going to speed this up a
little bit with the Diana coming in to
the Aspirin's climb, triggering Diana
instantly. Not liking the prediction
there, revealing a ride the wind, which
is a key part in this Diana deck as a
whole. It's very good with Weey and then
also scoring the early points against
Aurora is so critical. You definitely
want to use that ride the wind.
That's definitely going to be a factor
later on here as you said, especially if
you start to lose units on battlefields.
Those elder dragons start coming out,
you get something onto a battlefield and
perhaps you contend for that eighth
point.
>> I would really like to see if we do have
a way here in the future. Doing some
math here. Worried about potential
Aurora in the future. It's not going to
be quite there yet as we only have six
turns available. So we'll have eight for
the next turn. So Dewali here has to
calculate the next couple turns because
he does need to play around in Elder
Dragon potential in Aurora in the next
two turns. So not only thinking about
this turn has to do the calculations for
this the next two turns as well to make
sure that his units are close to one
location. So if there is an Elder
Dragon, we don't use all the units. So
that's why we're seeing the pullback
here as well.
We have a little bit of a discussion
here with the judges.
Now, this board state right now does
favor Dewali.
Once we get to that Aurora, though, he's
going to have to be very careful leaving
units on those battlefields.
We also have the opportunity to
potentially in this Aspirin climb game,
Swag YOLO 420. Yeah. will have the
opportunity to eventually just straight
up hard cast these Elder Dragons as well
that we saw in hand.
>> Yes, those Elder Dragons at hand. Uh we
do have we do have the option for
Oh no, we don't with Lunar Boon that it
goes to the trash instead. So only last
rights could get it back if we were to
do that. Yeah, hard casting is going to
be the best option in a lot of cases.
Okay, Tai Turner does come out, swaps
the Diana.
>> Turn is passed.
>> We'll see if this is a development term
to perhaps accelerate towards that
dowsing Aurora.
>> Yeah, Civer is available, but won't be
seeing that quite yet. Looks like we are
playing that mindspplitter
>> which means the next time we play Aurora
it is a guaranteed elder dragon there as
the mind spplitter did not go back to
the deck it did go to hand earlier
>> so we are seeing the wall's hand we have
a ride the wind stacked deck
>> turn to dust okay there's a turn to dust
there we do have flash star cross and is
that a second turn I was going to say
that is a second turn to dust that is
incredibly important Important
information for Mr. Swag as that is
going to be problematic for the dowsing
Aurora. Now thankfully it does I mean no
not even I mean you will get a proc
it'll give a temporary it'll go into the
next turn and it'll just dissipate. So
turn the dust a very good answer towards
that Aurora. So Swag Yolo does see that
uh perhaps those dragons in hand might
actually be useful at some point if
those Auroras start to take a punish uh
a beating there. So because we know that
turn to dust is going to be hitting the
Aurora no matter what. Swago 420 Ya
decides to take away the star cross
instead. This is a really good play
because first off we have the Mind
Splitter already on board. So we avoid
getting that star crossed and then on
top of that when we do have those elder
dragons they won't get starcrossed. We
already have two in hand. So we
absolutely can't afford those getting
balanced if we do have to hard cast them
from hand or a play from Aurora. Right
now, we're saying, okay, Aurora is just
a nine cost, two orange power elder
dragon, and we're okay with that. It's
going to get turned to dust. It also
makes our opponent spend two energy is
another way to think about it.
>> Dewali considering their play here,
scoring that fourth point. The
mindslitter fortunately does represent
seven might does give Swag Yolo 420 some
optionality as to how they want to start
scoring points. Get on the board. Ride
the wind. Shown in hand.
Well, on the trigger.
>> Really good hit there.
We'll have to see what Dewali decides to
do against the potential Elder Dragon
next turn.
And it looks like we will be doing just
that. Trying to get all the units at the
same location if possible just because
Elder Dragon is able to do so much. and
we will see stack deck. I'm excited to
see what we get from that.
>> The only doing an excellent job making
sure that we cannot see what he's
getting from that.
>> And of course, these players are
experienced and we're no longer on time,
so they can take their time and pretend
like it's a hard decision even if it's
not.
>> Selection has been made. Two cards
recycled.
Still lots of runes up for Dewali. This
turn is not even close from being done.
would really like to find a way in the
future. Of course, Elder Dragon can
potentially take that out, but we did
see a pretty decent hand from Dewali
overall. So, we will see the Fizz and it
will bring back a looks like a star.
>> I think they're just short-handing what
happen. Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> Experienced players will do that
sometimes.
They're trying to save time
when no time needs to be saved.
>> It looks like we'll go back to Swag
Yellow 420 Yaz turn. And will we see the
Aurora just slam down here? We can hit
two targets potentially. Although Dewali
does have five runes available. That's a
lot of energy that can be played with.
>> The turn to dust may also be uh weighing
on their conscious as well.
>> A little peek at the hand there.
Taking a look at those stack decks in
the stupify.
>> Is there value in playing the mind
spplitter again?
>> Uh unlikely cuz we know about a good
amount of the hand. We are just going to
play that Aurora and say okay this is an
Elder Dragon in a lot of cases. So it
should be an Elder Dragon because we've
seen the Mindsplitter already for
instance. It's just going to be a bit
until we find it. This is a lot of
information that Dwali is going to gain.
The fact that we know there's two elder
dragons in hand. Dewali might actually
get the raid that there are. Oh, there
is the mind spplitter there.
>> Additional mind spplitter does come
down. Was looking for that elder dragon.
Didn't get it.
>> Okay, there is the reminder. This is
game two. So, there has been an
additional mindsplitter cited into the
board. That's why it wasn't a guaranteed
Elder Dragon there.
So Dewali's considering here will be uh
will be forced to reveal their hand
but does have an option to play a
reaction here if they would like.
>> There is a trigger available for Dewali.
>> Always a tough decision here
>> and it is starcrossed. Yeah, I know.
It's just Yeah, it's all good.
>> Uh this and this. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I know. And there we have the mind
spplitter and the tie turner back to
hand. And we will reveal the hand once
again.
>> Just wonder.
>> We do have the turn to dust still there.
>> Flash fizz ride the wind times two.
>> Fizz selected.
>> Ride ride. Let me start just one second.
Ride ride. Two dust. One flash,
>> two dust, two ride, flash, turner.
>> Good nose to take there. Low unit hand
overall. So still really have to keep
these units alive.
>> Six total play.
>> Swag 420. Yeah, knows that this Aurora
is only going to be very temporary as
that will probably be one of the first
things that Dewali decides to do here.
might have seen a second one there in SW
YOLO 420 Ya's hand,
but even then we we did draming
Aurora will eventually be able to get
back into just again just hard casting
these Elder Dragons. And as you saw,
Dewali does not have much in his hand
from units and so the game could slowly
slip away from him. But right now, he
does have six points. But here's the
thing about dazzling Aurora. You could
be down. You could be down eight nothing
and then come all the way back
>> if the circumstances allow.
>> Yes, Aspirin's climb helping out just a
little bit here potentially.
>> And a reminder, this is the second game.
So, we'll see if Swag 420. Yeah. Can
find a way to get back here. Does have
sabotage giving us a nice view of the
hand there. Challenge. It's just so hard
when you don't have the units available
for it. A pretty unfortunate hand
overall to get the Elder Dragon stuck.
>> Ride the wind over to Aspir.
>> I really like the aggressive play here
with the Aspirin's cl or into aspirin's
climb because ride the wind and then on
top of that we are looking for things
from Diana does decide to keep the Raven
Bloom student there.
>> Hulk can can't discard it. So we know
about one more unit that we'll be
getting very soon. Moves the Diana back.
So, we're at the same location and that
will set up for the future if there is
another Aurora played. So, we'll
probably see the turn of dust come here
as well. Uh, Swag Yellow 420. Yad knew
that it was coming because it's seen it
multiple times at this point.
>> This is expected. Now, the thing is
though,
this is a very difficult swap for for
Swigilo 420. Yeah, because
unfortunately,
you're going to have to deal with these
units on board.
You do have runes to play with here.
>> Yeah, even an Aurora here summoning an
Elder Dragon just doesn't do it because
there's so much good defense here from
Dewali of actually having all these
units at the same location. If they were
spread out, trying to be greedy, trying
to say, "Oh, I'm just going to hold for
the win." Of course, the Elder Dragon
could change this game up a lot in that
case. But instead, we have a nice solid
base setup here for Dewali. deadly.
>> Yeah,
I think uh Swago 420 is taking a look at
their hand trying to figure out if they
do have an out. But as you said, Dewali
masterfully positioned in the base ready
to take these vital last two points
to go to nine.
>> Doing some calculations here because we
do have one ride dust flash.
Looking at those notes from the hand
earlier knowing that there is another
ride the wind flash and turn to dust as
well. Just a really tough spot to
navigate here. There has
just like I said these elder dragons
stuck in hand are just so tough.
Oh boy.
Even the dowsing Aurora just doesn't
quite do what they need.
Yes. And if it did, Swag Yellow 420 Ya
being a great player would have just
slammed it down right away. Is trying to
see is there a different line? An
incredible player that we have seen
perform over and over again. Has
multiple best of civers now. Very
familiar with the deck.
>> Tremendously talented Aurora flare. No
question.
>> The champion unit for Civer is going to
come out.
>> Can be accelerated.
But I'm not sure what optionality this
buys.
>> Yeah, can go into the abandoned hall.
Does have ways to buff it up with spells
in the future. Is looking to hold
potentially just stop the double conquer
next turn with this civer one way or the
other.
>> Every turn you survive as a dowsing
aurora player is helpful. They're going
to challenge, take out the Diana,
chance for Dwallie to react.
>> It's going to go through
>> and because Swag Yellow 420 Yat knew the
handed to Wally knew that there wasn't
an option for the challenge to be
reacted to. So, pretty quick play there.
>> This is probably about the as good as
you can get here.
Hopefully, you're able to put up a bit
of a stand, but you do have that second
turn to dust in hand that we already
saw. So, the other dowsing aurora
>> will have the opportunity perhaps to
survive a turn, bring out another unit.
Hopefully, that elder dragon
>> could change the course of this game,
but
>> it's looking a little dire here as it
looks like Swag Yolo 42i is considering
perhaps a final play before passing
turn.
So, we do have our markers up there as
we have the minus three from the
challenge earlier because it is not just
a unit uh combat in a showdown. It does
not heal itself up yet. It would
actually have to have a real showdown
for that to happen. But we also have
plus two because we accelerated the
civer. On top of that, we are now having
to decide is there a way to hold and
fortify this battlefield or not. Um
because Dewali does have access to ride
the wind which with the frigid jewel
maybe potentially being able to draw
another card and then give it plus two
might maybe we do find a way to overtake
this battlefield that civer is sitting
on. So there are a couple options to
potentially get the win here for Dewali
off the top deck but is going to require
a top deck to do that. One of the ma
major challenges here for a dowsing
aurora player is the decks aren't really
designed for for these situations,
right? Like you don't have access to the
disciplines, the defies. That's not what
this deck is built for. This deck is
built for getting that dazzling out,
starting to get those massive dragons
onto the field of play and then all of a
sudden those dragons are your opponent's
problem. But if you can't get them on
the field of play, you just don't have
that many options. And thinking back to
what we saw from the original deck, I do
know that we do have gusts, but that
that might only help you survive for so
long,
it's pretty much the only trick he has
available.
>> Yeah, not too many options here. Gust
would do it. I don't think we saw it in
the hand when it was fanned out earlier,
but I can't say for sure on that.
>> Okay,
the other one.
>> It looks like that point is going
through.
And that is the end of the showdown
there. So Civer does get to heal up now.
>> Every turn so critically important here.
Sabotage.
>> Sabotage being done. Let's see what's in
hand.
Frigid jewel. Turn to dust. Ride the
wind and a flash. So no units. Very
important information here. No units
available. Two on board obviously with
the tie turners.
>> Yep. Just getting a little bit of extra
information here as we get to see that
other frigid jewel as well.
>> The double flurry. Maybe
>> we hear the double flurry baby as being
a way to stop because of the tide
turners. still really trying to figure
out a way to win this game because
reality is with the civer deck is if
you're able to just eke out these close
games you do have the ability to
stabilize sometimes. The biggest thing
is this turn to dust just offers so many
issues overall.
>> Take
ride the wind
>> ride the wind being targeted
from the sabotage.
>> So jewel dust and flash right
>> definitely the best take here as the
ride the wind could offer a double
conquer here. Now, this does buy Swag
Yellow 420. Yeah. A lot more time.
>> We'll have to see if he can survive
another turn.
>> There is a chance here honestly. And
then if you start developing that board,
>> Dewali might run out of steam like you
won't he likely won't be able to
overcome a dragon if it gets to perch
itself onto a battlefield.
>> Really great line from Swag 420. Yeah,
here giving himself the best outs
possible.
>> It might have been the only play that
they had realistically.
>> You want a seven runes?
>> But again, that amount of experience
that they have playing Aurora showcased
here
>> does have seven runes with two runes
available for Swagolo 420. Yeah, Dewali
has to decide what can be done here. of
course looking to potentially hold the
aspir's climb after scoring here if we
don't see a double blade flurry of
course.
>> Yeah, the amount of damping that uh Swag
420 has had to do unfortunately does
present a bit of a problem here.
>> Yes, those elder dragon has just been
stuck in hand and we do have a stack
deck available for us as well.
>> Response stack deck. Mhm. Good.
>> We do see the flurry.
>> Just what we were looking for here.
>> That's fine. Eight.
>> They go to E.
>> So, this was the out that Swagol 420 Yao
was talking about was double flurry. So,
we did actually find that from the stack
deck and maybe we are able to clear a
tide turner for that reason and you do
have to either hold or double conquer.
But now we have a way to stop this hold.
So, playing to his out is working in his
favor here.
>> There is still hope here.
But Dewali is very carefully considering
their next action.
>> Yes. And we know a good part of the
hand. We know that there is a flash
there. The ride of the wind was taken
away. There is a drool and of course
there is a turn to dust. And then we
don't know about that top deck.
If it's a unit, it gives Dewali some
options here. But right now, these tide
turners are incredibly valuable
because we actually have seen in prior
games today that if you lose your units
and then you start to, you know, have to
try to top deck those units, you just
fall behind so rapidly.
Of course, those elder dragons, they
have a way of dealing with units sitting
around on the board.
Really interested to see what this is.
Is it another unit looking to hold? Is
that a Raven Bloom student? Yes. Well,
we're getting good at the same.
>> It is definitely a Raven Bloom, but will
it be played is the question. Trying to
do the calculations here. And Raven
Bloom does become a bit more scary for
Swag 420. Yeah, because it can be buffed
up. However, I mean, flash is one of the
buff up options and turn to dust maybe
isn't a way to buff this up either. So,
this flurry at the blades might be able
to do a lot for us.
Does have flash, but of course, that'll
just bring it back to the the base
there.
>> You're right. The hand composition is
such that the Raven Bloom student is not
I mean, it's not quite vulnerable. You
still have that flash opportunity there.
Yes. Um, absolutely has to do this
though to play around Aurora into the
dragon for this reason because if you
are able to play the Elder Dragon from
Aurora, you're able to clear two units
and then you're not able to hold
anymore. So, this is a really smart play
from Dewali was very fortunate to find a
unit of course, but the reason for this
battlefield is so important. So, such a
smart play overall. It gives Swag Yolo
420. Yeah. Just one less option to win
this game.
>> Three cards. Three. Three.
>> Three cards in hand for Dewali.
>> And we know them all. They are turn to
dust, Flash, and Frigid Jewel.
>> Not the greatest hand, but it might be
enough to hold out this game.
Potential play here.
And every single rune is so valuable
here.
>> Absolutely.
Lot of cards in my hand. Pardon?
>> A lot of cards in my hand. A
>> lot of cards, but not necessarily the
one that he is looking for. The
>> sabotage.
>> Sabotage.
The power paid with the gold.
Dewali is going to flash. Just flash.
One second.
And deciding which units and deciding do
we react now. This is on the stack now
currently.
>> Looks like Swag YOLO 420. Yeah,
considering what this chain might look
like.
>> Trigger on the stack.
>> Yep. Just mentioned that the trigger is
on the stack now.
>> There's a flurry of blades.
>> Flurry of blades.
>> Yep.
>> Okay, there we go.
>> So good here.
>> Very, very well played there.
>> Excellent.
So yeah, I'm interested to think about
Dewali's choice there. I mean, of
course, we know that Swag 420 Yat knew
about the flash in hand and decided to
play the sabotage. So, of course, double
flurry though is very hard to play
around.
>> Now, we're in a position though that if
that tie uh turner gets into that
battlefield, we know there's no extra
units in his hand.
If swagillo 420 is able to get an elder
dragon out, it can target that tide
turner. And then suddenly this game
rapidly shifts as Dewali goes into unit
top deck mode.
>> It's also notable this is the aspirin's
climb game and this is where that ninth
point is so valuable.
>> Having to decide what to do for next
turn. I mean, we do see that mobilize in
hand, which I have to take a look at for
sure.
That's definitely a consideration here.
>> I see the trumpet.
>> Mobilize being played.
>> And is there anything else available
here?
Come on.
>> Very difficult position to be in.
>> That's another sabotage.
>> Is considering it here.
>> You do have the gold. That does help you
not damp.
>> Just taking one more option out of the
hand potentially.
And he's going to use the sabotage, use
the gold token,
>> and that turn to dust has instead turned
to dust itself.
>> It is literally dust and it's gone.
Oh, very notable that the civer is
readied. Could consider the thing here
is
>> unless like I don't know if the wall
will be able to contest both. Do you
bring Civer back to base to then punish
Ty Turner with an a unit itself? But
then again, Dwali still can't win the
game unless he does conquer both.
>> But he can draw.
>> Yeah, it's only one card available.
That's going to be really tough here.
>> I wish he would have shown us the card.
>> He's going to want to grab that second
card.
is Swag Yolo 420 going to stage an
absolutely miraculous comeback here. Two
cards in hand. Ty Turner at Aspirin's
climb.
>> Yes, is not able to score that ninth
point because not able to double
conquer, but does get an extra card draw
as a replacement for that instead. So
maybe we do see something here. Of
course, the dream would be way and ride
the wind here of course, but that's
asking for a lot. Is it exact? Well,
it's Fizz. Okay, Fizz gives some options
here.
>> That's actually a great top deck.
>> Fantastic top deck.
>> Notable that on the next turn,
>> Swag 420 Ya is capable of hard casting
an Elder Dragon if necessary,
>> but you also have the Dowsing Aurora as
you've
>> essentially just dismantled the
Wallally's hand. So, it looks like we
will be playing the star cross onto the
Fizz and the Civer.
>> And by doing that, we can just play the
Fizz again.
>> Fizz and the Civer.
>> And then is there a ride the wind in the
trash pile right now? Because if that's
the case, we are able to conquer here.
>> My hand is at the bottom.
>> Let's see it.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, the way.
>> It is way.
Are we going to see Fizz?
>> Ride the one.
>> It's Fizz. Ride the wind.
>> Wow. What a great play there. Just
finding the exact need.
>> Unbelievable.
>> Absolutely unbelievable.
>> Yeah, good game.
>> There's no answer from Swagill 420.
Yeah, Dwalli does come away with a
victory. Absolutely unbelievable game.
That was one of the most intense matches
of Riftbound I have ever watched.
>> Wow. And really just Swaggy little 420.
Yeah, did a really great job navigate
that making it really tough. Coming
right down to a nailbiter at the end
there.
We are going to be going to a break
here, but rest assured we have a ton of
more Riftbound action to be seen. We are
going into the semi-finals and then of
course the finals. Guys, enjoy this
break and of course stay tuned for more
Riftbound action.
I'm Bryant and I had the pleasure to be
joined here by the one and only Frodan
who has been playing Riffbound since the
Houston regional qualifier. I genuinely
I had the pleasure to meet you then and
I was on your team the entire time as
you were chasing that best of Leona. So
I got to ask you I mean it's good to see
you again here in Vancouver. How has
your experience been across the entire
weekend? It's been great. I think every
single regional qualifier so far has
been better than the last. I've only
been able to make it out to one regional
qualifier every single set. And I always
want to make sure the one I go to really
counts and the the first one in North
America always bangs. So I had a really
wonderful time. It's the biggest event I
heard so far of any RQ. Yeah, we've had
a lot of people here inside the venue
itself. The tournament was about the
same size on the main event, but so many
people coming out not just for these
side events, but in general. And I've
heard that you've kind of been
participating in a lot of these new
heightened to the light side events such
as 2v2.
>> Yeah, that's right. So, one of the big
things for this weekend, even though I
do play in the main event and I try to
do my fun metal chase for the best of, I
also got a chance to play in the new
Champions of the Rift 2v2 super high
stakes challenge. It's actually kind of
crazy. The winning team gets something
crazy like 500 and change prize tickets.
Uh so you basically get anything you
want and some for your family, some for
your your next generation, however you
want to spread it out. Uh really really
cool initiative and it creates such a
different environment for 2v2. I did not
know how crazy this format can get with
2v2. There are some insane combos that I
would never have dared dream of. Some
people are just deep in the sauce
cooking up crazy combos. You can ask me
about any of them if you want.
>> No, absolutely. I mean, that's my
favorite part is that, so not to gloat
about myself, but actually Pastry Time,
fellow caster, uh, and I are the
reigning production champions for 2v2.
Okay. Um, because we play, he plays a
hook deck like Leona,
>> and I play Rexi because Rexi Breacher
says any friendly units not played FROM
HAND.
>> OH, AND NOT ONLY THAT, baited hook can
also target your opponent's stuff as
well to find units off the top. So trust
me, the
>> I didn't even know that. So Rexi went
really far today uh in 2v2. I believe
they went undefeated. So it was a crazy
setup that we didn't protect cuz a lot
of people thought this could be like
mastery. You just help defend with a
plus two. But there are some really
really cool stuff. So, I saw a forgotten
promises where you like have your ally
play a card and they immediately play
Aurora and then they just like and then
and then then they did it again and then
it played another Aurora and then all of
a sudden you just had this crazy
combinations that I was like, "Wow, I
did not even know I could even use these
cards in these ways." It it's incredible
and I really think that it's just the
tip of the iceberg as more people will
get involved. I I genuinely even think
there's some room here where there could
be a sort of side event competitive
format where there's a little bit more
focus on 2v2. But even like you said,
such the high stakes of these sitments
here. So I got to ask, you know, how did
you do? We top 32. I got to pair with
disguise toast. Uh it was his first ever
riftbound competitive event, right? He's
played casual matches with friends and
hung out and drafted and whatnot, but
this was his first time ever playing
competitively and I think it's a
natural. I mean, something tells me that
he's pretty good at card games. I would
believe you uh as I have been a big fan
of him and you as well competitive in
other strategic games as well with the
TFT scene. though. But Frodin, I want to
thank you so much for not only coming to
this event this weekend, but for having
such a great time in 2v2, and hopefully
I'll see you in the Rift itself, playing
some 2v2 myself, right?
>> Yeah, absolutely. It's such a pleasure
to make it out. If you've never been to
a Rift Battle event and it's anywhere
close to you, you got to make it out.
It's a really special thing and I think
it's such a cool unification of all
kinds of communities, right? We have
people from League of Legends who are
right standing like right there waiting
for me to go to dinner. We have like the
Valerant scene that shows up and even
people from other games. Just all all
different kinds of walks of background,
different range of ages. I see young
teenagers and people who've been playing
TGS for 30 years, right? Uh it's just a
really good good community gathering.
Great energy. So, please make it out to
a local regional qualifier if you ever
can. I promise you it's worth the time.
Absolutely. And that means we're going
to keep continuing the action here at
the regional qualifier in Vancouver.
Barrett Bryant here joined by one of
your top eight locked in for the
Vancouver regional qualifier, Allen ZQ.
This is not the first time, nor do I
think it's the last time I've been
standing next to you, Diana. And you've
already been working on this list since
Sydney two times in a row now, making
top eight. How does it feel?
>> Uh, amazing. Just proves the deck is
good. Just piloted well and it does
perform miracles. And I'm got to bring
up the fact that of course you are
already a regional qualifier champion
going all the way back to Bolognia and
you are now going to be against two
other contenders that have locked in
regional qualifier championships as well
with Sammy Sherman and Dewali.
There could potentially be a twotime
regional qualifier champion happening
here in Vancouver and it could be you.
Are you feeling confident?
>> Uh yeah. I mean again I'm not playing uh
like I'm not resultoriented. It's just
about the playing the best game you can
play and uh hopefully that's enough.
>> And I sure hope that it is. Allan, I
wish you luck as you're going to have a
tough competition here at this regional,
but I do believe you can easily do it.
We'll send it back.
Bear Bryant here and I am joined by one
of your autolocked top eight contenders.
You know him, you love him. The first
ever regional qualifier champion,
Dewali. Dwey, how does it feel not only
to be locked in, but you're going to be
on the top half of the bracket here with
Diana?
>> I've been uh chasing another top eight
for, you know, the last few regionals
and getting close bunch of top 16s and
feels really good to break through again
and also with Diana, super fun champion.
Uh I'm in competition with Allen for a
best of still. So, and me and him have
uh played before in Houston, right? So,
it's kind of a cool story line there and
it's pretty honestly just feeling on top
of the world.
It's not even just that about the
competition and working together on this
deck, you know, playing slightly
different versions of course, but the
biggest thing is that both of you are
now in the running to potentially be the
first ever twotime regional qualifier
champion. Dwali, if that were to happen
to you, I don't want to jinx anything.
If that were to happen to you, do you
know how quickly that would skyrocket
you into the deepest of conversations
that you're already a part of in this
game of Ripbound already still within
the first year of the game? Yeah, I mean
I can't imagine like I've thought about
it obviously, but it would be crazy if
I'm the first person to have uh two
wins, but we also have Allan and Sam
that are in the top eight. So, there's
actually a good chance we find out who's
the first two time. And I hope it's me,
honestly. It'd be crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm excited to find out with you. I
wish you luck, Dewali. We're going to
send it back.
Welcome back, Rift Bounders. I'm Bear
Bryant and I am riding solo on this one.
Of course, we promised you some vendetta
and radiance information and we're going
to give it to you. Of course, we had
some issues, so we're going to go ahead
and do it live here for you all. So, of
course, set 4 is on the horizon. Of
course, set 4 vendetta features rivals
and how an enemy can define you. We It
features some of Run Terra's iconic
rivalries to showcase that greatness is
not forged alone. Each legend, including
you, is sharpened by the person,
philosophy, or force that stands against
them. Now, of course, this also
signifies the release parody for English
and Chinese simplified. The set will
include 160 cards with more than 50
showcase cards. Now, this time there's
nine new champion legends and
introducing for the first time ever in
Riftbound, the enemy color pairs for
legends. Now, of course, the dev video
and previews for Vendetta are going to
kick off on July 6th. Pre- riffs are
going to kick off July 24th, and
Vendetta, it will officially release
July 31st. Now, of course, that's the
set that we want to keep in mind is
going to be coming up here soon, but we
want to give you a little bit of
information about set five as well.
Radiance is on the horizon.
Now, radiance is a great name for this
set because radiance can mean brightness
as in light, but also as in personality
and mentality. This set is about players
being ingenious and letting their
brilliance shine as they find creative
solutions to challenges that they face.
Now, we've shown this key art in the
state of the game earlier this year. So,
I think it's fitting that we also talk
about Radiance for set five this week as
the French Origins release just happened
earlier on Friday and they will they
will reach release parody with the
English and Chinese sets when this set
releases. So, let's talk about the
actual product itself.
Now, within this product, you can
already see champion legends like
Saraphene, Ekko, and Ziggs, and Jarvin
also shown off on the box. Now, for
these dates here, we want to go over
them. We're aim we're aiming to kind of
kick off the previews for this set
September 28th, and they'll run through
October 9th. Pre-Rift is going to start
on October 16th through the 22nd and the
global release of Radiance will be
October 23rd. Now, we are continuing a
product here with the release for
Radiance, which is the showdown decks
for set five featuring Evelyn and
Saraphine. Two ready to play decks out
of the box, perfect to grab for just you
and your friend. Now, of course, you can
see here some domains also being shown
off for Saraphene and Evelyn. And of
course, we already do have a champion
unit legal for play from Unleashed with
Evelyn on the Chaos Domain.
Another product returning with Radiance
is going to be the Vault and of course
the pre- Rift kits. So, the Vault still
going to be bringing out here, of
course, a product that we continue to
move forward with. And then, of course,
these pre- Rift kits are going to
feature nine different champion precons
within it. Of course, you'll have the
booster packs to supplement it as well.
Now, this is all a bunch of information
you're all very happy to see. Of course,
I know I'm very happy to see, but let's
get to some more interesting parts of
the set. We're going to feature some
more art that will be within the set,
and this is one of the new pieces for
Evelyn
in control. Now, this is going to be
another champion unit for the Chaos
Domain.
Very lovingly art here. Of course, we
know that it's very fitting for Evelyn
because she is on that chaos domain. She
wants to stay in control with game
mechanics. But we have another one as
well. Ekko will be featured, of course,
within this set, and we want to show off
his new champion unit, an Echo Ingenious
for the Mind Domain.
Now, the last piece and nice piece of
information I can show you guys is going
to be a full card reveal, but let's look
at the art first here. Saraphene
reaching out for her loving fans,
showing that she is truly
not alone. Saraphene not alone is a five
energy, one power for the order domain
with one might. When you play me or when
I become exhausted, play a one might
recruit unit token to your base. And I
also get plus one might for each other
exhausted enemy unit you control. Of
course, the previews are slated to kick
off fully September 28th and run through
October 9th for Radiance. And the
pre-ift will go October 16th through the
22nd. The full release of Radiance will
come out October 23rd globally. once
again. Now everybody, I apologize for
the delay on getting this information to
you all earlier, but I still wanted to
bring it out for the world, but we're
we're going to go ahead and send it to
the casters as we have our top four very
closely heating up.
>> All right, thank you very much, Barrett,
for showing off our first look into
Radiance. Really excited about that. But
I'm also excited for our top four today.
>> Yeah, this top four is going to be so
exciting. I will note some of those
cards look so cool and absolutely
beautiful. them and try to collect them.
>> Definitely. And uh we do have our uh
standings here. We're going to look at
the top eight bracket as we've got it.
So, we did have a top eight of again a
good variety of legends. And uh you
know, I'm still trying to find the
Leblanc that you said would be up there.
Where's which match was that again?
>> I I think you're misremembering. I think
my number one pick was Rengar.
>> Oh, I must be. I must be. Well, good for
you. It is going to be in one of our
quarter or sorry, semifinals. But we do
have one right now. It's Allen's EQ
versus Dwali. not only fighting for
first place but for the best of Diana.
>> Yeah, this is going to be absolutely
insane. I mean, both of these players
are almost mini bosses in themselves.
The RQ
uh Houston winner with Dewali as well as
the RQ Bolognia winner with with Allen's
EQ. Both players so great.
>> Yeah. And the three that we know are in
the semi-finals have all won in RQ
before. So, this could be the event
where we have our first twotime winner.
>> That would be so fantastic. I would love
to see it.
>> Yeah. So, we're going to look at the
deck list real quick. We've got Dewali
uh with the uh build here. Again,
they're both playing Diana, but I think
the most key point is if we're playing
the Frigid Jewel.
>> Yeah, I think this is a big difference
in Dewali's list is that Frigid Jewel,
it does also turn on that last text in
Houi where you can discard a gear. We
don't have that the same in uh in
Allen's EQ's list, but also be
interesting to see how that might change
the might of these units.
>> Yeah, the Hawaii has been a really
strong card for Diana once it hits the
board. I know it's been a little bit
difficult to see it consistently, but
offering another draw and with the gear
discard, we do get to ready up two more
runes, which ends up being really
helpful. I also do like the tech of the
consult the past. Uh something we don't
normally see, but since it lets us draw
two cards on our opponent's turn, that
means it can activate the frigid jewel.
So, not only are you getting those two
cards, but an additional plus two might.
>> Yeah. And that's going to be so strong
in your opponent's turn, as you were
mentioning, just because even if your
own runes are not up to be used, that
draw two suddenly coming out of nowhere
as a hidden card can really catch your
opponents off guard. All right, so
here's the wallally's list and let's
look at Allen's EQ's list uh for some
differences. We're going to play spot
the difference here. Probably the
biggest one is the acceptable losses in
the main though.
>> Yeah, that is for sure both different
choices here. Acceptable losses, it is a
spell that lets you kill gear, which
will be uh usable in this matchup and
you will not have to sacrifice your own
gear cuz he doesn't have any. However,
Hui can't get that ready to run. Yeah,
but I do really appreciate this. Just
another one cost spell that we can play
for all of our, you know, characters
that, you know, matter about. So, the
student, the uh, you know, potentially
the discard for Haye, the abandoned
hall, all that. Very good. And since
we're also very spell focused, we do
have the Raven Bloom Conservatory as one
of our unique battlefields, too.
>> Yeah, that's going to be so nice. Nice.
I feel like it synergizes so well with
this this spellheavy deck. Uh letting
you check to see if on the top of your
deck is a spell, and if so, put it into
your hand. Otherwise, recycle it.
>> All right. Well, I've waited long
enough. I want to see which is not only
the best Diana player, but the best
build. And we've got our top four.
Dewali on the left with Diana. Uh we've
got Ellen's EQ on the right with Diana.
And we're starting off our top four.
>> Yeah, we'll have to see what happens.
Obviously, I feel like both players I uh
obviously know how this Diana match up.
I'm sure they put in hundreds of games
into it, and it's time to find out who
can win the match.
>> All right, we got the fist bump here. On
the left, we've got the Rockfall path.
Uh it says you cannot play units here,
which is pretty helpful. I do know that
playing units to battlefields have been,
I think, kind of a little bit stronger
in this meta compared to others. And
then on the right, Allen's ZQ has the
Raven Bloom Conservatory as we
mentioned, uh, and will let us draw a
little bit more consistently since we
are a more spell focused build for Allen
ZQ.
>> Yeah, that's going to be really nice. As
you said, consistency, we absolutely
love it in card games. And so, we'll
have to see what we can find and
hopefully find some spells that help us
out.
>> All right, and we're getting started
here. We've got two runes to Wali ending
up going first since they were the
second seed for the Swiss standings.
>> Yep. just getting out that Raven Bloom
student. Really nice to get our first
unit down.
>> All right, three for Allen ZQ. This
could be just a quick and easy Diana.
And looks like they agree getting the
three and passing it back to Dewali.
>> Yeah, I mean I'm sure these players have
played these turns so many times. They
know exactly what they need to do to try
to get ahead.
>> Yeah, and you know, if you're a Raven
Bloom student, you got to go to the
conservatory, I think. Right. Makes
sense. uh just from the flavor of it and
also if you're the first one on there,
it's going to be helpful for you to get
more of these defense uh triggers here.
So, Dwali taking a think here what we're
wanting to do with these four runes on
turn number two.
>> Yeah, and finding some early spells
potentially getting that extra draw is
be really nice. Raven Bloom Student also
gets might for each spell that you play
that turn, which does mean getting more
spells to hand from that Raven Bloom
Conservatory will be really nice.
>> All right. And thinking here also, you
know, if we're on four, it could be a
fun turn to play the student and then
playing something like Vex. That can be
a lot of power here. But we're actually
just going to play out the Diana for
three and pass it back, not wanting to
force a showdown.
>> Yeah, I feel like both of these players,
they the deck in general obviously can
wait till that later game. Uh but when
you're facing off against what is almost
a mirror match, it can kind of you're
both just kind of stalling. You're
trying to say who's going to go in
first.
>> Yeah. And you know, if you pass, it
means that they didn't use their Diana
legend ability, right? So, being able to
say, well, they, you know, lost out on
some room potential or some energy
potential. Uh, that makes a lot of
difference as we're going further and
further into the game.
>> Yeah, that is a great point. You always
are trying to make sure that you're
getting to use all your runes, all your
energies, and but by denying these
showdowns, you're denying that usage as
well.
>> All right, we're going to get our first
move to a battlefield. We're going to
use our Diana champion effect to use our
uh you know additional energy from our
our uh energy uh from our Diana legend
here. So uh we are going to get the
point and just play out two more
students onto the board.
>> Yeah, and it does look like we got that
stupify off the raven and bloom
conservatory as well. So really nice
just get that added to our hand. That is
just kind of threatening, right? That
like if you decide to attack, I can
minus one you these and in the future
these Raven Blooms could both be three.
>> Yeah. And additionally too, uh, if we,
you know, cause it to be on defense, it
could offer another draw. And, uh, you
know, currently Allen's has the
potential to get, you know, a plus two
card advantage, which again adds up in a
mirror match like this one.
>> That is for sure. Uh, I mean, Dwi
definitely he's kind of waiting back.
He's only he has two units. He did go
first. Uh,
I wonder if he's going to decide to come
in one of these battlefields. I assume
that he may start, but it looks like
that frigid jewel that we talked about a
lot during his deck list is going to
come into play.
>> Yeah. And so it's uh when you draw your
second card each turn, you get the
friendly unit plus two might. And it's
not a you know, when I see you draw
cards, it is strictly the second card of
that turn. So if we draw one more after
the draw for turn, we would be able to
get a plus two might.
>> Conservatory happens first and then you
can pay for the
>> D. Yeah. So we've got the uh
conservatory looking at the top card. It
is an acceptable losses, a very apt card
when you just played your first gear off
the frrigid jewel. We see a little bit
of a smile from Allen's EQ. And we are
going to see a ride the wind off the uh
Diana effect as well. And this is our
second draw. So we will be able to get a
plus two might
>> and we're going to respond with the gust
here.
Currently three mites.
>> I wonder if we have anything that could
help us here.
>> Yeah, we don't normally have ways to
increase uh the might like that. I'm
looking through the hand that we see. Uh
there could be a chance of maybe a star
cross to get rid of their Diana as well.
And yeah, I could see that being a
decision for this point here. But
we're going to see on the decision four
runes up. We have used the Diana
ability. We're going to let the Diana go
back to hand.
>> We will be able to get the student moved
up.
>> Pretty good.
>> Yeah. And also uh we did play one spell,
so I think the students in the back both
have a plus one.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, they should be plus one for now.
Right now, do you think the showdown
though two to three? uh currently two to
three, but if we do end up playing uh
yeah the Moonfall, this could be a big
change here. So, we'll be able to move
one of these one.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh you know, both these players well
aware. Uh both all these are plus one.
So, it's going to be a three to one and
the student is able to take the
conservatory back.
>> Yeah, Moonville is such a strong
signature card. Not only essentially
bring a charm up into that battlefield,
but decreasing both units there. Yeah,
it's really just a mix of like the
supify and charm as we've seen before.
Uh, and just really really helpful to
not only kind of win battles, but also
get some really good trad.
>> Yes.
>> Mhm.
>> One to one here. We're going to have a
Raven Bloom student off. We're going to
see off the top. Do we have a spell?
It's a Vex, unfortunately. So, uh, yeah,
we do have to recycle that as well.
>> And we are going to use the acceptable
losses here again drawn off the
conservatory. And you know a really good
tech in the main as we've been talking
and good against a gear focused build
like Dewall's.
>> Yeah. And because of that spell we are
just slightly above uh on Alz's side.
Stack deck will potentially even us out
again.
>> Yeah. So currently both these students
have a plus one each. So it's three
might to three. And uh we're going to
resolve this stack deck first.
>> You have how many cards? five.
>> See? Uh, you know, making sure five
cards in hand for Ellen's EQ.
>> We've got a lot of runes right now, so
we will have to activate one if we want
to again have our student be bigger than
theirs.
>> Yeah, we're going to need something, but
we don't have any runes up to be able to
do it. Uh, so we are potentially just
going.
>> All right, so we get our one here. Plus
one might a piece. And then for one,
we're going to play our own stack deck.
So that's going to be four might to
three and uh Allen's EQ should be able
to take back the conservatory.
>> Yeah, that's going be really nice for
Alen EQ. Also just getting that extra
card to, you know, add to his deck. Also
just picking out of those top three to
really curate what he wants in hand.
>> Just confirming the cards that we wanted
there.
>> And then passing focus, that's going to
be four to three. Allen EQ two points of
the required date and once again taken
back the conservatory.
>> It is gonna put
>> We still do have so many runes up
though. Six runes to try to figure out
how we want to step here. Obviously we
could play more units. Uh and we want to
make it as hard as possible for Dwalli
to be able to kind of get set back up,
get some units into the battlefield and
come back.
>> Yeah. And looks like Alan EQ may have
access to uh what looks like maybe a
Kha'Zix. I know that he's been uh
experimenting with the card in their
build, right? I think they're running
just the one, but uh you know, we don't
love recycling. If we had a Hawaii, this
could be a good time for it right now.
Uh we'd only have one rune left active,
but it would be a little bit difficult
to interact with it. And we're actually
going to choose the Vex uh the five drop
from Spirit Forged here. uh nothing
really doing uh in the base, but if we
do uh find ourselves in combat that, you
know, an addition uh of to the cost uh
is going to be really hurtful for
Dwalli.
>> Yeah, especially when both of these
decks rely so heavily on spells. I would
not want to get into combat with this
Vex cheerless.
>> All right, back to Dewali. One point to
three. We currently have seven runes
active here. Only one on the defense for
Allen's EQ here. And again, that Vex is
quite the scary card if left unchecked.
>> Yeah, I mean, and I'm sure Dwalli knows
that as well. He I mean, he has seven,
but his base is completely empty. He's
got no units, not really anything set up
here.
>> Yeah, and we're kind of behind on tempo
as well. Uh, and you know, because we
were able to get so much removal, uh,
since we had these Raven Bloom students
as well for these trades, you know,
Allen's EQ is definitely on the front
foot here.
And then once again like being able to
get that additional card draw from the
conservatory has been very strong. Looks
like Dewali is going to play the first
away of the top four here. Uh if it's
able to survive, it's in a pretty good
spot. Also, if we do have access to ride
the wind, which maybe we do if we're
spending the extra two, uh we would be
able to not only force the combat, but
be able to uh get the additional draw
and discard.
>> Yep.
>> Blue trigger.
>> All right. Oh, Starcross being added to
hand. Uh we're drawing two cards so far
so far off the conservatory for Allen's
EQ.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Star cross. Nice. and yeah,
gets the
gonna need the movement trigger from Hui
as well.
>> Yeah, I think it's one of our first
movement triggers that we've actually
gotten to see of way. So, I'm excited to
see what they decide to discard here and
which of the abilities we're going to
get to use.
>> Yeah, there's nothing
>> discard.
>> Yeah, draw.
>> It does look like it's going to be that
spell that dust getting discarded.
All right. And then we're going to move
it back. We're going to get another draw
>> and deciding again since we do have
access to gears in Dwali's deck. Having
an additional two runes up could be
pretty important here. And it is going
to be the frigid jewel. So, we do have
two runes open for the defense. Uh, and
we still have our Diana leader uh legend
ability. So, we do have that there. And,
uh, we're going to go back to Allen's
EQ.
We still luckily do have Vex there for
Alen ZQ able to move her into one of
these battlefields and so many different
runes to kind of get even more developed
uh and hopefully get us into these
battlefields successfully.
>> Yeah. So, uh for Vex tier list is
specifically while I'm in a combat, not
in a showdown or a battlefield. So, uh
you do need to be in a combat. So, it's
not going to be very easy to do right
now since uh you know there aren't any
units specifically at the battlefields.
But with the uh signature spell from
Diana, we can force a combat and the
Haye move as well.
>> Yeah, that is a fantastic point. I mean,
that moonfall does feel like it could be
great here. We've seen that multiple
times. People really rush to get rid of
uh so it Oh, instead it looks like it's
going to be Tide Turner bringing that
back safely back to base.
>> Yep. Uh, and again, if we did have the
Moonfall, there could be a chance to uh
interact with that. But we're actually
going to use the star cross that we drew
uh with the Tide Turner. And I love this
sequencing. It let you get the point
with Vex, but it does keep the
battlefield clear. Uh, so you're not as
afraid of losing your Vex. And yeah,
we're going to play out a I think this
is our third student. I don't think one
has returned to hand. So, uh, yeah,
we're at a pretty good spot for Allen's
EQ. Yeah, Alan's EQ is probably very
happy getting to see all these Urban
Bloom students. They do just feel so
strong. Uh especially now as we're
getting more and more of these spells.
>> Yeah, and we're back to seven runes for
Dwali. We had to recycle two off of the
Haye and the Ride the Wind. So, we could
develop another one, too. But it would
mean uh you know, we'd have to pretty
much have another ride the wind if we
want to try to get the uh the value from
it.
>> Yeah.
Looks like Dwali is trying to figure out
what to do here. Again, he's finding
himself at the beginning of his turn
without any units in play. Uh he's
>> That's correct.
>> I mean, only slightly behind Allen's EQ
in points, but you want to get a
foothold. You want to get your tempo
moving.
>> Yeah. And uh you know, I think Diana is
definitely a momentum based deck, right?
You have all these abilities, but they
really do require you to have units
already on the board here. So, uh, by
keeping that board clear, it's been very
difficult for Dwali to really develop
anything.
>> Yeah, 100%. Uh, it looks like Huay is
going to be coming back down, but it
does again cost those five energy and
one power to bring her out. I mean, it
does leave us with two more runes, but I
want to get moving, I feel like, as do.
>> Yeah. And I've I've played this kind of
match up before and it really kind of
lends itself to this kind of scary like
starcross loop, right? If there's a copy
of Fizz on the board, we can use it with
the starcross and then we do get rid of
the Hawaii again. You spent three and uh
to get rid of it and then they have to
redevelop us, you know, a third time
essentially, right?
>> Yeah. And it just doesn't feel good
having to set up over and over and over
again. instead. Okay, Riven Bloom is up
in conservatory as well. Honestly, the
homeland
student.
>> Yeah, and I don't know what it is.
Allen's EQ. Uh the conservatory uh finds
the spells and usually the spell that
makes the most sense at that spot. So,
uh it's been very kind to Allen's EQ
already this weekend. and we saw the
unacceptable losses and we'll have to
see uh if we're able to get another but
looks like we are going to react with
the stack deck uh using our Diana legend
ability.
>> Yeah, I mean that doesn't let us draw
three cards and select one of them at
the least. It does let us use that Diana
energy like you were saying earlier and
hopefully find something that can help
us in a position like this. This one go
to four.
>> Right. Going to four for Allen's EQ
after the stack deck
and thinking about another tide turner
potentially.
>> It's so interesting watching both of
these RQ winners. They know exactly what
their plan is. Obviously, it's difficult
getting there right now. Uh but you can
just tell they know their exact game
plan. Yeah, I mean, uh, they've been
playing so much of this deck and, uh, I
believe was you said, yeah, we've seen
Allen's EQ really find themselves at
home with the, you know, the runes that
we're playing. We saw it with Ezreal,
right, in those domains. Uh, we're
seeing it even, you know, further
explored with Diana. Uh, just very, very
confident.
>> Yeah, 100%. They feel very at home.
oment feels like we're going to be
developing our own way here uh and
getting set up protecting that Raven
Bloom student back in base moving it
with that tide turner that you'd called
out.
>> Yeah, and every time I see Tide Turner,
I'm like, man, this is such a good card.
It gets better every time I see it. And
the flexibility that it offers just
worst case. It's just the, you know, the
first card you play in a game uh and
with late game scaling. Very solid card.
Yeah, it has been so nice especially
keep these just keep us moving forward
here on LZQ's side.
>> So Zwali has been fortunate that you
know their Hawaii has survived another
turn uh at the risk of their Huawei also
being developed on the board. So we do
have to be aware of that. We do have
eight runes I believe for Dewali to play
with here. uh up to two and the legend
ability for Allen CQ. But we're just
going to go five here. Get the draw
and we're going to get a discard.
Currently 5 to2, but there will also be
the defense trigger once again from
Raven Bloom Conservatory.
>> Yeah, it's so interesting. They continue
to contest this Raven Bloom
Conservatory. It shows what a priority
it is and just how powerful the text on
that battlefield is for them to keep
going at it.
>> Yeah. Rockpole says we can't play units
here. You can still move them there. We
haven't seen that happen this match yet,
but uh you know it is something that we
can do. We do have a Hawaii, so Raven
Bloom can miss and unfortunately not
getting a draw one and losing a Hawaii.
But we did discard the Diana and is
currently 8 to2 on the conservatory.
>> Yeah, it does feel like we're definitely
beating that titer yet. Titer will go to
the trash and away is taken that Raven
Bloom Conservatory.
>> All right, and we still have all of our
runes ready for Dwalli. We're at three
points to four here and looks like we
have our own tide turner again. Such
value, especially with the Haye. So, we
are going to have it study at the
conservatory there. Way is going to move
back, get another draw one, and discard.
And again, we've got a lot of runes left
open. Yeah, I mean that's going to be
concerning for Allen's ZQ if he decides
to try to take over uh the conservatory
again, but still I think
>> we're going to see what else Dwall has
here. He could develop more units. He
could maybe try to do something here.
>> Yeah. Uh if we have like a our own copy
of X perhaps. I could see that being
pretty strong. Uh if we have another tie
turner, we could put it in the
conservatory and move the Hawaii a third
time. where we are going to use our star
cross. Love this flexibility here. Get
the tide turner back to hand where it
can offer another movement for our HOA.
It prevents their Hawaii from going off
again. Just a lot of back and forth
here.
>> Yeah, 100%. And it kind of shows that we
kind of don't care too much about
holding it, I guess, per se. We've
already gotten that point. We got Hawaii
back safe at home. And
>> getting their way off the board is going
to be really nice. We do use another two
runes to play our own Raven Bloom
student, but we pass to Alz with one
rune up and our Diana energy has not
been used yet.
>> Yeah, and we just are very very safe. We
do not want to overextend. We do not
want to give our opponent too much
value. I think there have been a lot of
like safe back and forths and just
trying to extract as much value as we
can.
>> 100%.
Uh Alan Allen CQ has so many runes as
well. I'm excited to see what they do to
develop here if we're going to see
somebody move into that rockfall path as
well.
>> Yeah, we should have 10 runes right now.
>> Three to four
>> and uh yeah, four for Allen ZQ, three
for Dewali, and I think we've got about
five cards in hand. We've got the Fizz,
>> and uh just automatically, yeah, we're
just going to play the Star Cross on the
Fizz and on the Haye there. Such a good
combo that this deck gets to do. Yeah, I
absolutely love Fizz. We saw it used so
much in set two. Obviously, getting to
reuse those spells is just going to be
so nice. And allowing it to bounce
itself back in hand means you're going
to be able to do it again.
>> And we do also have our signature spell
from uh Diana, which does fit into the
requirements. So, there's just so many
good choices that Fizz can do.
>> He pairs so well into the spellheavy
deck.
You're going to move the soon to the
conservatory once again.
>> Getting our fifth point here for Allen
ZQ. We're going to move the Vex to the
Rockfall path going all the way to six.
So, uh, you know, one double uh, conquer
away from winning this game as we've
been inching closer and closer to eight
points.
>> I feel like at six point the pressure
really is put on. I mean, what is Dolly
supposed to do? He only has three
points. He has one unit in play.
Meanwhile, Allen ZQ's board seems pretty
well set up.
>> Yeah. And you know, uh, if we go the
student to student, that's going to be
very tough to contest. Uh, and yeah, I
think Allan has really really applied
the right amount of pressure to get him
to this point.
>> All right, looks like we've got I think
nine runes for Dewali here. We've got
you, as you mentioned, the Raven Bloom
suit. I think we've got a Hawaii in
hand. Uh, but we would have loved the
have the Hawaii stay on board here. Um,
and we do have a good amount of uh,
spells in our trash. So, if we do end up
having our own copy of Fizz, there can
be some interaction, but we're really
primed to, you know, have to interact
with both these battlefields, right?
>> Yeah, it would be really nice to clear
up both battle builds. We do only need
to do one to, you know, potentially save
off an extra turn, but we'd feel a lot
more confident if we can remove both the
Vex and that Raven Bloom Student.
>> All right, looking at paying what looks
like three, so could be again a copy of
Fizz here.
>> And it is. All right, recycling two. And
uh yeah, Allen's EQ knows what's going
on. These guys have been playing a lot
of Diana. real quick. Star crossed into
Fizz
Hawaii.
>> I kind of love seeing it. You can tell,
as you said, how much these players been
playing. Even when Alan ZQ played his
last star cross, Volley just scooped up
the Hawaii. I don't even think Alen EQ
really had to point it out that much. He
knew exactly what the target was going
to be.
>> Yeah, currently three might on the Raven
Bloom student here due to the star cross
though. So, it can contest the
conservatory with a three might to two,
but obviously there's a lot of potential
for spells here.
Just making a check of spells.
Obviously, if Fizz goes back to hand,
uh, you know, we do have a quote second
hand of spells in that trash here.
I think it's an interesting resource
that a lot of these purple decks do have
with Fizz is having that additional
access. Obviously, we also see it uh
with Annie at times, but it doesn't feel
like Annie has the same loop that Fizz
does.
>> Yeah.
All right, we're going to move uh the
student to the conservatory. Top card of
the deck here. Let's see it. It is a
another losses here which worst case you
can spend one to give the plus one might
>> yeah pass
>> sometimes that's all you need with a
spell right even though the text reads
one thing
>> sometimes it can serve a different role
but it does look like stupify is going
to be what we try to do
>> look it
>> yeah and uh yeah obviously yeah these
guys are in the zone right this is not
the first time they've played they know
that there is a reaction window here. So
targeting supify and we're going to
supify their
>> blue resolve
>> resolves
>> yours. Yes.
>> So yes plus two.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. So making sure they resolve.
>> Okay.
>> Making sure his resolves too.
>> Minus one. Yours is regular.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So plus one minus one.
>> I'll pass. There you go.
>> So again, we're just back to three and
two, right?
>> 100.
>> Yes.
>> It's so cool seeing just how well they
know it. They're super calm. They're
just slowly going through exactly what
they know they need to do.
>> Yeah. And here's the acceptable losses
here. Uh you don't really, you know,
this doesn't really target either. You
can just play it for one
>> and this will offer a three for three
trade.
>> It works. It works. It works.
>> That plus one up to that trade like you
mentioned. I think this is something
that's like funny at times. Even though
the text reads one thing,
>> it you can just say action plus one
might you know what I mean? Like that's
that is the effective text here. But we
do have a response with the gust and
Allen's EQ is like all right that's
going to resolve.
>> Uh except the losses resolves too and
that is going to be a four might Raven
Bloom student that is able to take this
battlefield here. That is going to feel
nice to get a hold on Raven Bloom
Conservatory. Obviously, we still have
the fact that Beex could be potentially
holding to seven points next turn. And
>> they conquer.
>> It's kind of difficult to remove Vex
from where it is.
>> Yeah, but uh you know Allen's like, you
know, I know you have Fizz. I know you
have Moonfall in your trash. Right. That
can be a play here and it is going to be
the one we're going to try.
And it is going to be the Moonfall
there. We could have put the Fizz in the
conservatory also since you're moving.
Uh we are the uh defense here. So we get
the plus one might from there. We get to
trigger the top of our deck for
conservatory. We see another Fizz. So
unfortunately we will have to recycle it
there. Yeah.
>> Cole.
>> And then we've got Ride the Wind, which
we get to play for only one due to the
Vex champion ability. Let's
see if there's any reaction to it. But
it definitely doesn't feel great after
you've committed so much to then just
have that Vex moving back to
uh moving somewhere else.
>> Yeah. And and there's also kind of this
weird situation here where uh currently
it's
>> enhanced still, right?
>> It's in combat, right? Uh also our
spells are costing more. Uh if it moves
to the other one then our spells cost
less again. Right. So there is this kind
of weird
>> back and forth uh dance here.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> Consult.
>> Yeah. I believe we just end up moving it
back to base here.
>> Consult has to be titan.
>> And uh we're just going to let the uh
the battle end. We already scored a
point off this battlefield. We're gonna
hide a card underneath the student there
and we're going to pass it back to Alan
ZQ.
>> Yeah, all of these minuses will be
removed from the board. We'll have to
see what ZQ does from here. At least he
doesn't get that hold just yet.
>> Second turn. I mean,
>> Alan ZQ is definitely much closer to
getting to eight than others.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
>> I had no spells though. I don't know if
you just go into it on me though is the
issue.
>> That's
>> Yeah. And and you can tell, again, these
guys play so much together. They're just
talking through their plays like,
>> "And this is what I saw. I didn't see
like there's there's they're already
having this conversation of like, how
did we get to this spot here together?"
Uh, we do have the Vex here. We can win
this turn and get double points from a
double conquer from Allen's EQ. We do
have the student in the conservatory,
which can offer a card draw, and also
there is a hidden card there. So, a lot
to unpack.
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean, it's so cool
seeing the camaraderie between these
players. They're obviously in a very
tense situation being that they're in
top four, but they're still having, you
know, a nice little chat, talking about
their gameplay. Uh, you know, enjoying
the fact that they're playing Riftbound
together.
>> Definitely looks good.
>> All right, I think we've got maybe nine,
uh, for Allen's EQ. We are going to put
the Vex into the conservatory here.
Hidden card is the tide turner.
>> Respond to conservatory.
>> Yeah, I guess. I mean, I should have
conservatored first. I mean, you could
respond still to conservator, so that's
that's okay. You can trigger it.
>> So, conservatory trigger. We do have the
hard bargain there.
>> Does cost a little bit too much now
though because Vex finally coming into
combat once they resolve the beginning
stuff
is going to increase the price of
Dewali's spells as well as decrease the
price of Q's leading the specs to win.
>> Yeah. And it looks like we weren't
moving the tide turner.
>> Ride the wind.
>> But we're going to try to ride the wind
here. And yeah, Dwali is going to pack
it up. And you know, could hard bargain.
We still had the uh runes available to
pay the extra cost. And we're going to
game two. Allen ZQ one win away from our
final.
>> One win away. That's a lot of pressure.
And then we're going to be going into
game two. We'll have to see what of the
battlefields they decide to do here.
What changes will make to try to beat
Allen's EQ?
>> Yeah, and a big point of this one, uh,
you know, I think the Raven Bloom
Conservatory was the difference maker in
that match. It offered a lot of card
draw for Alz specifically and found some
good cards. And now we've got the double
Targon's Peak. Uh, and so everyone's
going to have a couple more runes to
play with this game.
>> Yeah, it's going be really nice. which
uh when you conquer Targon's Peak during
your opponent's next turn, you get two
of your runes ready to gain. So, it'll
be interesting to see just how much many
runes and energy we have to play with.
>> Yeah. The other thing to note, too, is
that, you know, we can have some ride
the winds where we can conquer both of
these Targon's Peaks and then we get
four runes back at the end of the turn.
>> That's just so much flexibility.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and I'm excited to see what
that might mean for some of the
showdowns or and combat because having
extra runes means more spells to play.
>> All right, Jali starting us off with a
Raven Bloom soon. Obviously, one of the
MVPs for these decks here. We're going
to three for Allen ZQ and just again
playing out that Diana just a repeat of
the first game.
>> Yeah, I mean this time I wonder what
changes do I will make. Obviously last
time he was a bit conservative. He kept
holding back. It did seem like Allen ZQ
getting into that conservatory just like
you said uh early so that he could draw
more. It seemed to do so much.
>> Yeah. And one good thing about this
Targon's Peak too is it will offer us a
lot of chances to use our uh champion
ability. We are going to use the
showdown timing to activate our Diana
legend to play a stack deck. Look at the
top three and uh
>> the double singularity
>> and Alen Allen's a little bit less happy
on the three that were on top of there.
>> Yeah, it doesn't seem like he's very
happy.
>> Wanted to see free copies of
>> but still you're further into your deck,
right? So closer to the cards that you
want.
>> All right, making a note there saying,
"Hey, I'm not going to see these cards
anytime soon."
>> It's fine. Sure. It's fine. Copium.
Yeah, you're good. One.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Yeah, it's okay. You know, we're just in
the semi-finals. We'll we'll make it
work, right? That's what he's saying.
>> Exactly. We're going to make it work.
We're going to He's going to try to get
this win so that he can sit happily in
the finals.
>> Yeah. So, uh, some quick shorthand. We
played the Diana for three. Targon's
Peak. We get the two back and moving it
back to Allen's EQ.
I wonder if being more aggressive like
this, moving our units in quicker is
going to do much to change. Obviously,
we're going to get those runes back
here. Uh, but it's not the same card
draw that that Raven Bloom Conservatory
represented.
>> Yeah. One one thing I like about Allan's
EQ when he plays is that when it when he
knows his reaction window, he'll just
look up and stare at you, right? He's
like, "Is there anything? Let me let me
know. I want to I want to be able to use
my ability."
>> Oh, it has to resolve before
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry.
>> Yeah. And yeah, activating. Yeah, cuz
this was uh you know on showdown. Use
the vision. Look at the top card. Uh and
we do have a ride the wind off this
Diana.
>> Thanks.
>> Now we're in the showdown. Now we're
going to use our Diana legend ability
for our own stack deck. The top three
for Dwali
>> pass again after stack deck.
>> Mhm.
>> Let's see. Uh does it look like we are
going to be doing that stack deck as
well? is trying to find one of those
cards that can help us win this game two
and send us to a game three.
>> Mhm.
>> All right, adding the one there. Uh
student uh should be at three might
right now.
>> One.
>> Yeah,
>> one to one. We are going to play out a
Vex there. Very strong. Uh it's going to
be for five, but again, we get the two
back for Targon's Peak. A little bit of
shorthand, but again, these guys have
been playing for a long time, keeping
each others honest as well. and moving
to Dewali with their six rune turn.
>> Yeah, we're just quickly passing back to
Dwalli. So, we're gonna see what he has
here. Maybe something from that stack
deck can help us. I wonder if we're
going to try to get into that other
Targon's Peak. But that being said,
Allan DQ has fully reinforced it with
that Vex.
Allen's thinking about it, looking at
the cards in hand. We've all had those
times. We just look at our cards and
you're like, "All right, what do we do
with these?" Right? I chose these cards.
I put them in the deck. Now I got to use
them.
>> Yeah. I feel like there's two different
options you're feelings you're having
there. Either like, "I can't wait to
play this card. This is going to be my
next turn." Or it's like, "How did I end
up with how did I end up here?
>> How did these end up in my hand? I know
I put them in the deck, but where where
you know how how is this one of the
combinations?"
>> This wasn't how I wanted it to turn out,
but hopefully that's not what Allen's EQ
is feeling right now.
All right. And you know, uh, the VEX
does offer some, you know, reduction in
the combat again when we're so spell
heavy. Obviously, Allen's EQ is a little
bit more spellheavy than Dewali, but you
know, com combat is for playing spells,
right? And but the Vex making them a
little bit more expensive is pretty
hurtful.
>> Development here.
>> The combat uh being for spells is
definitely what Diana thinks.
>> Yes. Yes. And we're just going to play
out the Vex for drop as well as the
Frigid Jewel. And we're going to go back
to LQ holding the two points here.
>> Changes the match up so much.
>> We'll see what happens.
>> Let me see if I didn't draw the card
yet.
>> Yeah. And I think it's really smart just
like moving out of Targon's Peak. It
does kind of free it up for Allen's EQ
to move into potentially, but it does
mean we can also try to take Targon's
Peak this following turn and get more of
those
>> You did. You did. You did.
>> Right. Just making sure. Yeah, you
channelneled your runes, you drew your
cards.
>> We're good to go.
>> Cards in hand. Looks like I think
there's four for Dewali here. We only
have our Diana legend to offer any
interaction.
>> Diana student.
>> Yeah. And there is the singularity. So
using it on the Diana and the student.
Vex gets to live another day. Uh it does
have that deflect. So that additional
recycle might have been a little bit too
expensive, but using one card to get rid
of two of theirs is just great value.
>> Yeah, it is a lot of runes. It does look
like it's the only thing we're going to
be able to do this turn. But it at least
we are clearing out Dwali's board for a
large part. It does kind of mean sadly I
mean it does mean that we really
respected though that deflect cost on
the Vex that Dwali played.
>> All right, we've got eight runes right
now for Dewali. We've got our choice of
which Targon's peak we want to conquer
the most here if we choose to do so. But
that four drop Vex loves to be at a
battlefield
>> that she does. I would agree with that.
>> Promise I too much for the development
to
>> uh we're going to have to see though. I
mean obviously we don't only want that
one unit there. We really do want to
build out the board a bit more. have
more options of things we can move
around. I feel like
>> um especially when you are coming up
against this Vex, you're going to not
want to actually be either be using the
spells early or you're going to want to
be using it uh you're going to want to
have actual might to deal with it.
>> Yeah, the five cost Vex is so good when
you can move into a combat, right? Uh
you really want combat at your timing,
too. So there are ways to, you know,
move uh our own four drop around, get to
Targon's Peak, move it back somehow, but
uh we are just going to look like play
out the Hawaii for five
>> and we'll see what we do from it.
>> Definitely seems like a favorite in
these Diana lists. It seems really
important to get it established. Also
really important to take it off the
board if you're the opponent. Uh so
we'll have to see exactly what NZQ has
for it, but also can we get it somewhere
moving?
>> Yeah, we could use a ride the wind here
uh to get some points, but again it's a
little bit better when we're able to get
like the double Targon's Peak uh and the
you know extra draw, but we're going to
leave three open and pass it back to
Allen's EQ.
>> Yeah, three runes open as well as a
Diana energy. There's really so many
options here for Dewali. Obviously, it
kind of gets crunched by
>> uh you know, it could potentially get
crunched in the future. So, how can we
use it here to help us?
>> No, I wouldn't repeat here when you have
mana.
>> And I think we've got six runes for Q.
It's a little obscured right now. Uh we
can move up our Diana into a Targon's
Peak to get a potential draw off of our
champion effect. Imagine
>> it would definitely be nice to be able
to use that uh
use that ability.
>> Mhm.
Yeah. And then if we're there, we're
able to get like the two runes back,
which then we can use again next turn
for another potential draw. So, not
awful, but you know, we are making sure
that we're not overextending.
>> Yeah, it is so interesting to see how
cautious these players are.
or how Allen seems to dislike his hand.
He does have a large one.
>> Yeah, there are uh a lot of cards to not
like right now. Uh but yeah, we've got I
think what seven cards it looks like uh
in the hand there. Looks like we're
going to move potentially a Vex into one
of these peaks.
Now, uh, one thing to note, we do see a
timer in the bottom left, but we do
essentially have, uh, no time just to
kind of keep track of how long this
match has been going. Uh, there aren't
going to be any time rules for this. So,
we can take our time to make sure that
the decision we want to make is the one
that we do. And, uh, you know, this is
pro probably the most we've seen Allen
think this match by itself.
>> Yeah. I mean, in top I mean, top four
now, not even top eight. Every move you
make is so important. These players are
I mean not only competing for a seat in
the finals but also competing for that
best of Diana. So each action they take
there's a lot writing on it.
>> And it looks like we're thinking about a
double unit play. And that's going to be
a case. It's going to be a Raven Bloom
soon and a four cost Vex of our own and
passing it back to Dewali.
Now, one thing I also like when we're at
this high level, especially if these
guys know exactly what they're doing,
it's almost a different game, right?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. The cards that they're playing and
what they're playing into and playing
around is, you know, at a different
level than, you know, someone you're not
as experienced with. Not necessarily an
inexperienced player, but just someone
you're not experienced playing against.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's so interesting kind
of even just how like the mental game
can be, right? These players, I think
they mentioned, have been playing
potentially hundreds of games together.
They've also just been playing hundreds
of games. I remember from an interview
earlier, Alan ZQ was saying like before
the set even came out, he'd probably had
400 games on Diana. Yeah.
>> So,
>> not only do they know the deck, not only
do they know the matchup, but they also
know their opponent so well.
>> Mhm.
All right. So, I think we've got nine
runes for Dewali. We are going to be uh
tempted for one of these moves here. We
are going to move it to Targon's Peak.
draw.
>> Yep.
>> You're going to get a draw one and
discard one off the Haye effect.
>> We'll have to see what type of card they
decide to discard. Uh based on what we
discard, Hui does have three different
abilities basically, which can be
anything from drawing cards, growing my
readying runes, but I think obviously
with all of our runes made and not being
in combat right now, it's probably going
to be a spell.
>> Yeah, spells would be the best one
generically right now. Uh but that means
that you have to have a spell that you
>> want to get rid of. Uh so that's not
always the case here.
>> And Jack going to think and it's going
to be the supify. So we do get that
additional draw
>> kind of if you want to think about it.
We got a a free draw one off supery
without having to pay the r.
>> Yeah. To some extent sometimes even you
just see players play the supify for
that draw one.
>> Uh so we are just going to get that draw
effect instead from that discard. That's
also the second draw for the turn. So,
we do get the Frigid Jewel given the
plus two might to the Vex. I don't think
it's going to be too important for this
turn specifically, but it can come up in
these later turns.
All right, we're going to be paying two,
it seems,
for potentially I think Ride the Wind
would be pretty important, but it is
going to just be a traveling merchant.
Okay.
>> I mean, Traveling Merchant does
represent a lot of card draw
potentially. So, could be really nice
to, you know, find some of those
different cards that we're going to need
for this matchup.
>> Yeah. And we are going to do the star
cross here. And I like the sequencing on
it. Uh, obviously our uh Diana legend is
a little bit more uh selective of when
you can get that energy. So, making sure
we're doing it in a showdown just so we
can get that discount.
>> Yeah, that is really nice.
Guess I misplayed.
>> No, it's fine. Actually,
>> I feel like that's one thing that's
really cool about these top players. You
see just how well they can maintain uh
how efficient they are with their
resources. So, I mean, they know exactly
what they're doing here.
>> Yeah, we've got five runes left open
here. Uh we will be able to get four
runes back at the end of turn with the
Targon's Peak. So, uh, looks like we are
going to play a merchant again for two
and then we're untapping two and two
passing with seven runes left. Yeah,
seven whole runes, I think. Yeah, for
Dewali, which is a lot.
>> Yeah, I mean, that can mean be so much
as Allen's EQ tries to move up into the
battlefields. I mean, again, just like
you mentioned, he's been playing he
knows his opponent so well. It's kind of
a whole different beast to play against
your friend who you kind of have an idea
when they're going to be bluffing, when
they aren't bluffing. You know probably
their list so well to have not just kind
of a guess, but know exactly what could
those seven runes represent.
>> All right, we're moving uh our Vex and
our student to the Hawaii. Currently six
to five.
Let's see if they have anything.
>> I can think about the action.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. And yeah, thinking about this uh
again, right? Okay. Yeah. So, I'm
thinking
I did something wrong. I assume it's me.
>> Yeah. Seeing what is going on here.
>> So, Hawaii is at five. If we get two
draws this turn off of cards like
stupify, we could get a frigid jeown pay
with Diana maybe.
>> I mean that would be really nice just to
put us over on this showdown.
>> Maybe you want to fight with that much.
>> Yeah, looks like they're just confirming
something that happened on the previous
turn here on the runes.
Plus,
>> no. Okay. I think it is just a
>> five to six.
>> It five to six right now. Do we have
anything to get that
>> get maybe that plus two or some way to
decrease the might on Alen's side?
>> I'm like, damn. Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> Seven runes is a lot to do it with.
>> Yeah. And we we talked about it. Uh I
had a good discussion with Barrett
earlier this week. uh where like yeah
the the numbers in this game can be so
close. Uh you just need one more might
to be able to get the victory and uh
looks like we are passing focus
potentially
>> saying I don't want to commit to this
away uh when I know that I'm likely I'm
not feeling that confident I'm going to
be able to get onto the other side of
it.
Yeah, I mean sometimes you do just have
to like save those runes or more so save
the cards in your hand for the turn that
you need them.
>> Yeah. Okay. Making sure here. I mean
again with us having so many runes left
open, right? You think that there would
be some cards for interaction here.
>> Yeah. Like what is he what is he saving
the runes for? M
>> is that meaning that there's something
else in his hand? Is it largely units
instead? Uh
it looks like there may be a card he's
thinking about playing here, which does
give us a bit of information. It looks
like it's going to be that Moonfall,
which you would think would be adding
might to some extent to that battlefield
if we're bringing Diana uh Diana up to
Targon's Peak. But it also is minus
twoing every single unit at that
battlefield. Almost essentially a minus
six if Diana gets over there.
>> Correct. So uh it would make it a I
think five to three if it resolved with
those three units over there. And we'll
see if Allen's EQ has a response to this
Moonfall.
>> That would be absolutely huge if we
could wipe Allen's EQ's board.
All right, we've got the movement over
>> and I think it's currently five to three
>> and minus two across there. So, the
student is at zero, the Vex is at two
and we do have one for
>> the uh the Diana.
>> Yeah, it does look like your math is
correct. I have to think does there's
also a lot of runes up on Allen's EQ
side. He still has his Diana as well.
Surely he has something here to try. And
it looks like we're going to do the same
type of play. Playing that Moonfall to
bring traveling. I was
>> I'm going to guess traveling merchant.
That's that's going to be my guess, but
not not a guarantee. It does offer a
chance for a discard one draw one.
>> Yeah, but it would at least bring it to
zero might would bring us three to three
if it is traveling merchant. It does
look like it is.
And then we will get that one extra
might from the uh uh the student there.
So it would be a three to four. So once
again, just narrowly beating the the
numbers here.
>> Yeah, I think this could be a really
important moment here as we're playing
these different cards. Dwallian still
has those four runes up. He could make
some more plays here to decrease the
might on Allen ZQ's side. And
>> just slightly different right now. The
>> the might
Yeah, currently three to four. Uh they
don't have the dice on the might there,
but yeah, currently the uh traveling
merchant is at zero. There it is there.
And then we do have the Hawaii that's
currently at three. Three to four.
>> Four to three.
>> Let's see. Four runes up. We saw a
stupify discarded earlier. That might be
something that we would like here.
Putting us back three to three. Uh, but
maybe there's something else as well
that we could use.
>> The biggest thing here is that Allen's
EQ's spells just, you know, ramp so much
better with a student here.
>> Yeah, in a moment like this, you really
can see how strong that Raven Bloom
student is. Every single spell, not only
minus two, is also a plus one. I mean,
it makes every single card in his hand.
Add a little line that says give Bloop
Student that plus one might.
>> Yeah. Uh, and the other thing too is
that both these cards are in gust range.
So, uh, even if there is a way to
increase it, you could gust. And we are
going to try to flash back the Hawaii
and the student here. And we are going
to hard bargain and we're going to play
four. So, they can't even pay the four
to save it.
>> Yeah, we don't have it up. Only two
runes, but that's going to cost so much
as well for that hard bargain. And with
that additional spell, now it's looking
at three to five to try to get this
northern Targon's Peak.
>> Yeah, I mean, Flash seemed great for a
defensive move. Also, both of these
cards do have when moving triggers, so
could be nice to get that extra draw and
discard trying to curate that hand. But
instead, hard bargain making Allen's
EQ's units even bigger.
All right, two more runes left for the
Diwali and we are going to try to use
Ride the Wind here for the Haye.
>> That will resolve
>> and says that will resolve here. So, Hui
will be saved.
>> All right. And sorry, this this was such
a long combat. This combat started with
Allan DQ moving into Targon's speed,
right? Okay. So, this is it. So, they
were the attacker. Uh, and so this is
not again when we get so deep into it, I
want to make sure uh it's it's
understood.
>> Uh, and I think that's the second draw
cuz we moved the merchant and we moved
the Hawaii. So, we get the plus off the
frigid jewel for that. And
I think that's likely what's going to
happen. I'm seeing if Allen's EQ has any
other plays.
Currently, it's uh I think the merchant
is still at zero might as well,
>> I think.
>> Yeah, I'm not fully sure cuz he did have
the minus two on him earlier and it's
been removed.
>> Uh
yeah, so maybe we gave the Frigid Jewel
plus two there and then uh I'd have to
maybe reread the Moonfall. So maybe
because the Hawaii isn't at that
battlefield anymore, it doesn't have the
minus two anymore.
>> Well, he also discarded a unit.
>> Oh, that's right. Cuz we discard the
unit. Okay, that's that's where the plus
came back. Okay, we're we're back for
it. Sorry. This is such an intricate
battle here. So, uh with the traveling
merchant getting the plus two from the
frigid jewel, that does mean we do offer
a potential trade with either the Vex or
uh pretty any much of these units here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you have to wonder which
one is the most important to uh to get
off the board. I was actually surprised
looking at what Volley had discarded.
That's a Baron Nasher, is it not?
>> Yeah. And uh you know, we weren't too
far away from being able to play it
here. Uh we do again have some
additional usage. I mean, I think I do
see a stupify potentially in hand that
will pretty much save everything but the
Diana, but we're saying, you know what,
that's fine. Merchant can take something
down with it. And uh let's see what we
decide to take.
>> Yeah, I mean again every single action
here is important. It could mean a lot
if we if we take Vex or if we take the
Dian out.
>> Yeah, all these are great units to get
rid of. All have their own usages here
and we'll see what Dewali decides to
choose.
Yeah, I mean the Vex obviously is
stunning units that come into like the
turn that they are played.
I'm trying to think if there's too much
that really does obviously forge it must
be important since we're thinking about
it. Um but then obviously that Diana
also has her ability as well.
>> Yeah. What are you more scared of? uh
the might from Ravenloop student, the
kind of uh you know passive slowdown
from the Vex or the potential card draw
from Diana. All of them very valid
>> for sure. And it looks like it's going
to be that Diana card draw.
>> Uh
>> all right. So, uh finally, this combat,
this showdown has finished. We're going
to be at four points for Allen's EQ.
We're going to pass back and we will
have two additional runes active thanks
to Targon's Peak. board. You have killed
them.
>> Yeah, which is going to be obviously
very nice to have, but uh
>> not so great for Dewali who's trying to
figure out how to get in here.
>> All right, currently I believe eight
runes active for Dewali. Uh having a
Hawaii in the base is such a good
benefit here. Uh and definitely after
that combat super close and back and
forth, but I think Dewali has uh you
know is kind of seeing the light at the
end of the tunnel. I don't think it's
>> Yeah, it does seem that way. We at least
are at five points this time versus
Allen's EQ's three.
>> So, we have a bit of a lead and all the
units of Alan ZQ are currently on that
Targon's peak. So, maybe there is
something we can do here to get this
game to win.
>> So, uh we could immediately move the
Hawaii. Uh and if we do so, we will be
able to get not only plus three might
from uh if we discard a unit, but if we
also just use the effect, we do get the
frigid jewel effect. So it would be
immediately like a 10 to six and uh you
know that is quite the deficit just to
start off on a combat with.
>> That would be really nice. Here it does
be moving that way up. I'm interested to
see if we have a unit just for what
you're talking about.
>> Currently five to six, but we do discard
a student here and we get a plus three
and a plus two. So currently 10 to six
on the northern Targon's Peak. Yeah, I
mean that almost doubled its might. So I
mean still multiple runes up here on LZQ
side. It looks like it is going to be a
ride the wind
>> and uh yeah uh curious to see what we're
move and wear, right? Uh it could be a
chance that we just move our Vex back
just to save it. Kind of a more
expensive version of a flash here.
>> Yeah, I mean saving it definitely would
be nice. Uh, and Raven Bloom would go to
three, but three to 10 still not enough.
>> Right, thinking on the play here. We're
going to spend four, it seems, for a
hard bargain and repeating it. So,
>> the R we will not be riding the wind on
this one. And that gets removal of both
the units. We're going to six points for
Dewali. And we just need two more to
round it out. And I think keeping the
Vex here just means we don't have a lot
of interaction for moving cards into the
Targon's Peak. This is a really good
spot.
>> Yeah, this feels fantastic. I mean, what
is Allen's EQ supposed to do to push
these two units off the bases? He's got
no units in base. As you said, they're
going to be stunned even if he could
play any next turn and find some way to
move them into Targon's Peaks. Uh but if
these two units stay where they are
>> next turn I could hold to a win.
>> Yeah. So we're looking at four. Could
have used the I think Diana legend
ability to help pay for the hard bargain
>> which is fine. We are just going to uh
stupify on reaction to Targon's Peak
just to get a draw and use the runes
while we can. And it's going to be back
to Allen ZQ. Six points across the way.
We need to interact with at least one of
these battlefields.
Yeah. And how is he going to do it? I
think it's going to be a huge question.
I feel like I see
>> there are at least obviously some units
here. Uh
>> stupid fight.
>> I mean, we did see the uh singularity uh
I believe sided in. We could have two
copies and that would be able to clear
up both these pots. It would be a little
expensive cuz it would be a deflect cost
on this Vex here, but we're going to
play the Fizz for three.
>> Yeah. Hopefully there's some spell that
we can use. It looks like it's going to
be stacked.
>> No, right. Okay.
>> Uh
trying to find a card that can help us.
>> Yeah. I mean, if we have Starcross, we
could do uh Starcross, Fizz, Starcross.
I think I think we've got six for that.
Another stack deck though, not looking
fantastic.
>> Yeah, I mean, we're really hunting here
for something that can find us a way not
to lose this next turn.
>> All right, we've got four runes left
here.
Yeah, the only thing I could see
potentially in hand is maybe a stupify
Gus, but like that's not feeling great
because it's a double target onto the
Vex. So, we'd have to recycle two to do
so.
>> Yeah. And obviously does not feel good
to lose runes when you're kind of having
these like spell offs to some extent.
Uh, so I mean
it would be nice to put it in range
though, but it could just get played
again.
>> Yeah, and we are going to use the supify
here
>> on the one.
>> Recycling the blue for that. Drawing
one. And uh the Vex is now at three
might.
We've got the gust. We've got the
removal.
We're playing to our outs here. Vex
returns the hand.
>> Yeah. And it kind of also gives us an
idea like we don't have anything that
stops spells right now it appears
because we had so many runes up and that
definitely would be a moment that you'll
be trying to stop that gust.
>> Yeah. And if we have any movement which
we've got the fizz which I believe we do
have a ride the wind that's going to be
enough. And Dewali's forcing a game
three.
>> Yeah. This is so exciting. Again both
these players they obviously know
exactly what they need to do and they
are executing to a te. What are they
going to do for game three though?
>> Yeah, it's going to be tough, man. I
love that that one combat that we had a
lot of back and forth and we saw the
double Targon's peak and now we're going
to see the double abandoned hall. We
already had so many might numbers going
back and forth and with these abandoned
halls, these spells are going to be
very, very important.
>> Yeah, it's going to do put even more
might onto these different units.
>> All right, well, we're just going to
start off with the stack deck on the rip
here. So unfortunately no twocost unit
here for Allen ZQ as they start the I
think this is the first game of this
match going first.
>> Yeah, I think so as well. That does mean
Dwali is going to have uh the ability to
play some of the first units onto the
board which can definitely definitely be
nice. We've seen it kind of feels like
whoever gets that first unit into a
battlefield safely seems to really take
the lead and potentially win the whole
game.
>> Yeah. So playing out the Diana from the
champion zone. We've got a four drop Vex
passing back and forth. Some pretty
automatic plays as we get started for
this one. Going to five runes here for
Dewali.
Could be a way could be another vex
ourselves. Uh but again a little bit of
a different pace from this game compared
to the others.
>> Yeah. And we are currently tapped out as
Allen ZQ, which does kind of mean that
if we could do something to fight later,
it'd be I mean we would know exactly
what they could do, but instead we are
just going to play that Vex like you
said.
>> Awesome. All right, we're going to move
the Vex to the southern abandoned hall
here. Going to get our first point for
our final game of this match here. One
to zero here. We are going to play out
the Anna for three. Yeah. And we're
going to pass it back to Dewali
>> this time with three runes up. So
something to watch out for when we are
going into I mean either of the
abandoned halls.
>> Mhm.
>> All right. Again, currently
one to zero. We've got a four might be
Vex on the southern abandoned hall. Uh
we very much a mirror match, right?
We've got the same legends, champions,
the the units we've played are the same.
The battlefields are playing the same.
Uh the runes are quite similar as well.
And we're going to go to the northern
abandoned hall and going to activate the
uh Diana effect with our Diana Legend.
>> Yeah, getting potentially some card draw
here.
Doesn't look like it's going to be
possible sadly, but we kind of have an
idea at least of what is in our next
turn.
>> Yeah. So, unfortunate that we just spent
one to not find a spell off the top two
of our deck, but we're going to let them
have it. On the board, one to one here,
and we're going to see if we're going to
have our Vex uh fight each other.
>> Yeah, I mean, we do have a lot of runes
up. Sadly, Alenc does have the three as
well as his Diana uh Diana legend, but
instead it looks like we are just going
to reinforce that abandoned hall on the
north side.
>> Yep. And we're going to pass with six
whole runes active. So, uh you know, if
we had that Hawaii, we might wanted to
have played it, but also especially with
these abandoned hall battlefield
triggers, we want to make sure that we
have a lot of room for these spells. So,
we're going to use our Diana into
theirs.
>> And we're going to try to use our Diana
ability.
>> Yeah. And so many runes as well for if
we can get a spell from it.
>> Yeah. Currently 7 to three, but uh if
we're able to even trade Diana's, it's
likely something that we take. Uh if
we're able to uphit and trade with their
Vex, we'll take it.
Yeah, I mean getting any trades here
just to decrease the number of units Joy
has. So him down as well as we try to
make the lead is going to be really
nice.
>> And then the clock is ticking as we're
entering our 80th minute of this match
here. Again, very close game, a lot of
back and forth. Are Diana a little bit
more fortunate being able to find a
flash? And we are going to play a stack
deck for one and see if the there is a
response from Dewali. So look at top
three. This will be able to get us a
plus one might on both of our units at
both of these abandoned halls.
>> Yeah, that's going to be nice to try to
slowly build this Diana up. Obviously, I
mean that is already making us I believe
a four. Uh so I mean we could kill that
Vex.
>> Yeah, these these halls are looking
anything but abandoned right now, right?
I mean, they do seem to have a lot of
units at them. I don't know why they
named it that.
>> All right, Dewali with the six open once
again. Do we care to save our Vex? Do we
need to play the spell? I mean, we
passed with six open, so we kind of want
to use our runes uh that we left open as
well.
Yeah, I also like, you know, Allan just
mentally saying, "All right, I'm at, you
know, it's four to seven right now."
making sure the numbers are just known.
Uh, no confusion either.
>> One more.
>> Yeah, I think these players have done
such a great job at making sure every
single thing is shown with these
markers. Uh, making sure that each other
has exactly, you know, the correct order
of things. Remember, even earlier,
Dwall's make sure that Allan had
channeled his ruins for the turn.
>> All right. And uh, yeah, we do have the
plus ones once again. So plus two on the
uh Vex as well as the
>> Diana
>> Stubify as well going to potentially I
mean decrease the might of what they're
up going up against. And this Diana I
mean kind of seems small as a three unit
but it just seems to be growing and
growing in these abandoned halls.
>> Yeah and with the stupify on the
abandoned hall we do get a plus one for
our Diana and a minus one on their
Diana. So it will tie at six a piece.
>> That is going to be really nice for
Allen's EQ. And now it kind of feels
like not only is it just picking off a
unit, but potentially this could be
huge.
>> Yeah.
>> Again, if we're able to uh you know,
we've used three stack decks. We see
them at the top there. Uh and we've
really just kind of spent three of our
runes to trade with two of their units
here, but we will activate the flash.
I wonder if we'll have anything in
response to this flash. Obviously, this
defensive flash would be really nice. I
mean, it looks like it will uh resolve
and that means that we save both of
those units, but all we really committed
to it, as you said, were those stack
decks, which made our hand nicer, and
nicer.
>> One to three.
>> Yeah. So, one to three here. Uh I also
know that what Allen's EQ, I think,
found a flash off their own Diana moving
up. So, it's something that's available
to us as well. And uh with five runes
left open, we'll see if Allen's feeling
confident enough to play anything else.
>> I think getting more units on board is
going to be really nice. Obviously, we
have a lot of those spells and we are
going to want to use them to continue to
grow even during Dewali's turn. So,
honestly, I could see either here. Would
be nice though, just to make sure in
case something does happen that we have
a unit base. Yeah, I do think we've got
uh the signature spell potentially uh to
get some interaction and some removal,
but you really want to find the perfect
time, right? If you're able to use that
to really uh remove a lot of cards on
their board, we want to do that. And
instead, we're just going to move our
Vex safely back into base and back to
Dewali.
>> Yeah. And it's going to be just making
sure our Vex isn't vulnerable to dying
uh at least from a combat. I mean now on
Dwalli's side it looks I mean obviously
we have a good number of runes
we want to start taking back some of
these points because we are you know
Allen's EQ is getting ahead of us here.
>> Yeah and again this is kind of the back
and forth and you in the first game uh
wasn't anything major but Allen was able
to slowly creep to six points and then
get the double conquer to end it. So
we'll see if uh Dwali is going to let
him do it again this one. Yeah, each
point feels so important in this
matchup.
>> All right, we've got, I believe, nine
runes for Dewali to play with, right?
Uh,
I don't think we've really even had to
recycle any, but we do have the
singularity. We did see this come down
from Allen's EQ, and we will be
recycling three if we want to target the
Vax as well. And it seems like that is
what we're doing. I think we saw three
get recycled. I mean, if we have any
response to it, it would be really
strong. Basically saying, actually,
Dolly, you don't have a turn, but I'm
not sure we're going to have an answer.
>> Yeah. And uh potentially hard bargain.
There is the decision of playing either
two or four for it. If we play it for
four, we know that they're not going to
be able to use it. Uh and that will also
be another spell to make our Diana, that
one mower, stronger.
>> Yeah. I mean, that would be huge if we
did have a hard bargain here. I would
definitely love to see that.
>> Starcross, the Vex, Diana.
>> All right, we're going to say star cross
on Vex and Diana.
>> Slow down their uh their tempo and also
save our Vex as well.
>> Yeah, and I mean that does feel nice. It
It doesn't feel great for Dwey, right?
Like we still got to kill the Diana.
We paid for that deflect and instead
that Vex is safely in Allen's EQ's hand,
meaning we kind of lost that power
>> into the void.
>> Yeah, two to three.
>> Now we are going to move our Vex to the
northern abandoned hall there going to
two points for the Wall-E. Currently
three runes open and we still have our
legend ability. So four during
showdowns. We're going to replay out the
Diana and we're going to pass it back to
Alan ZQ.
Yeah, I mean, slow and steady is what
wins the race here.
>> All right, looks like we've got, I
believe, nine runes now for Allen's EQ
if we have our own copy of Singularity.
I think it'd also be a fantastic time to
play it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, I definitely agree. Just clearing
out Dewali's board and kind of just
resetting our own, right? Getting our
units built up, making sure Dewali can't
do anything. Definitely a singularity
would be nice, but instead it looks like
it will be a Fizz and I'm interested to
see what spell they use. It's going to
be stack deck.
>> I mean, we've played it three times
already this game, so let's do it a
fourth time.
>> Can we make it a fifth?
>> We could. We definitely could. I mean,
with Starcross and Fizz, we could. Um, I
mean, again, I think Singularity is
definitely a card we're aiming for. It
would be a clean cleanup for this
current field, but Allan ZQ would be a
little bit more knowledgeable on what
exactly they're looking for there.
>> Yeah, I mean definitely we're looking
for something. We are in the lead, so
it's not too big of a deal, but instead
we're just going to develop that Vex to
give us four more might on our board.
>> Yeah. So, Alensq passing. We've got two
runes open and we still have our legend
effect.
>> Three points for Dewali. who could make
it a fourth by moving Diana to the other
abandoned hall.
>> I mean, what do you do here? Obviously,
you do have some units build up for
Dwali.
I mean, we got a hold, but do you take
the the Vex back now and try to protect
it or are you trying to get that lead,
you know?
>> Yep. Uh, you know, do we want to chance
the card draw with our Diana, too? Um,
that is always an option. We do have to
be careful about Gus, but when we know
that both these B fields are Oh, another
singularity.
This is tough to see.
>> Yeah. Uh, and it's going to be that
deflect cost again if we're hitting into
Vex on Allen ZQ's board, which I assume
we are. It looks like we did recycle
that third rune. And Allen's EQ is going
to need to do something to protect these
units or we could very well lose them
both to the trash.
>> Now, we could use a hard bargain here,
but they've got the two open uh to pay
the cost. So, really not doing much
besides just discarding one. The double
singularity is very tough here. Yeah,
like if you pay it now, obviously Dwali
could choose to just pay their two since
we don't have what it would need to
repeat it for four. And then it kind of
decreases your chances as well of being
able to react to anything else. Looks
like we're just going to let these units
die and they're going to the trash.
>> Yep. So, we do have our Diana move up.
Uh we are going to attempt to stupify
it.
>> Yeah,
>> it does let us draw.
Let's see. Is that still in response to
this?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Stupify Diana again.
>> Another stupify. So, we've seen three
stupifies and three copies of
>> that. We are going to try to pay one.
And we are still looking at the top card
of our deck. Diana has not been very
good vision wise, but we do get a flash
for
>> Yeah.
>> And unfortunately, no Gust here.
>> Yeah. Very fortunate though for Dewali.
I mean, it is nice to just slowly get
that lead. Make sure LZQ doesn't have
any way in. And with that Vex aphathetic
up in that top abandoned hall now,
anything coming in will be stunned, but
that will be stopped by our own
singularity.
>> Yeah, and I think that was the top deck.
It looked like immediately like finally
we're going to play it out. I do think
that maybe we were also using the super
just to dig deeper for it. Could have
also been for August, but we are going
to play our student for two. And the
game's kind of reset here.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. Dwali is going
to need a unit here to hopefully to make
sure they get back onto the board as
well. This Raven Bloom student could,
you know, tie us back up again next
turn.
All right, once again, seven runes
available.
We've got seven on the other side for
Allen's EQ. We've got three open if you
want to consider the Diana Legend
ability.
Yeah, I mean it is a lot to consider and
like what do you exactly want here,
right? Obviously, you want to find a way
to take that Raven Bloom off the board.
You need to find a way to build up your
own board as well. And right now, I
think we're at seven runes for this.
>> All right, we're just going to play out
the Hawaii. uh now that uh you know a
singularity has passed, we feel a little
bit safer to establish it, but
>> one
>> we'll see. Uh we'll see what Allen's
EQ's answer for is
>> and also with the double singularity
gone, we feel less scared. But if we've
got a Fizz and a Starross, which I think
we do,
>> this has been a really good consistent
answer to the Hawaii here. Yeah, I mean
Starcross just keeps sending the way
away to the hand and uh Fizz is safe
back in hand as well, meaning Raven
Bloom taking another point potentially
here and
>> we have nothing to answer for it next
turn unless we have more of those damage
spells.
>> We're going to play our own way here for
five. Uh we do have
>> one rune open and our Diana legend
ability and passing it back to Dewali.
No way.
>> Honestly, I love the way puns.
>> I I they they are fantastic.
>> Four stock decks.
>> It's just uh
>> like I had to play the stack deck four
times to find this card. Uh I think
triple stupify. So, we got the draw and
we eventually found what we needed. But
>> you can definitely tell Allan's like,
"Okay, I had some rough turns here. I'm
feeling a little bit more confident
here." taking a drink of water and now
Dewali is on the back foot.
>> Yeah. After four stack decks and three
stupifies, I think the odds are worse
for not hitting
>> Yeah. any of these. Yeah,
>> exactly.
And we've got, I believe, eight runes
open for Dwali. We know that there is a
copy of Hawaii in there.
Yeah, I mean are we just going to play
Huay again? I wonder for Dwali.
I feel like to some extent you need to
because obviously Huayi feels like such
a strong part of our deck and it is what
we're going to do. But when it just
keeps getting potentially pushed back to
hand, you're spending runes to get the
card back in your hand.
>> Yeah. And we are going to use Ride the
Wind here and uh this is going to offer
a ability
>> Yeah.
Uh, I'll Yeah, move trigger resolves.
There's no showdown yet.
>> Yeah, using the move trigger first for
Hawaii. Getting to draw one, discard
one, and then once we're in the
showdown, Allan might have something to
say about it.
>> And while he's looking at his hand, I'm
like,
I got to get rid of one of these. But I
couldn't tell you immediately what it
is. Yeah, I feel like sometimes the
space is definitely the how did I get
here with this hand?
>> Yeah. Yeah. There there are the there
are these questionable looks of what is
the play here, but so far being able to
make a path for the correct ones, but
man, this this is a tough spot.
>> Yeah, you make it to the top four.
You're in that game three right now. I
mean, I'm sure there's definitely a
level of mental exhaustion after all
these games every day. And you're the
players still know exactly what to do
and are trying to make the best decision
possible.
>> All right, we're going to attempt to
flash the student and we will be met
with a hard bargain. So, goodbye student
here.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And with no runes open, no answer
for it. Hawaii readied from that ride.
The wind is able to safely move back
home.
>> Yeah. But uh issue is that we have no
runes open and we've already used our
Diana Legend ability. So we're in a
tough spot here. Allen's going to be
able to move their HA next turn. Uh if
we have our own Ride the Wind, the
double uh conquer and move back and
offer a lot of flexibility and card draw
and points and then Dwali is going to
have to be, you know, afraid of a
potential double point conquer again.
>> Yeah, and that does not feel good. I
mean that would bring them up kind of at
that special number of six.
>> I mean
>> both of these players can be putting out
so much pressure. It's there is so much
stress to make sure we're making the
best decisions here.
>> Yeah. And we were thinking about the
discard is going to be the star cross.
If we did have a gear for the additional
two runes that could be important here.
But passing it back to Allen and uh you
definitely see him a little bit more
chipper here. I think he's uh he's
feeling a little confident for sure.
>> Yeah, a lot more confident than he was
earlier. I mean, we are going to take
that abandoned hall. He has so many
runes either to develop his board to
potentially move his way back to safety
or as you said could do that double
conquer which would be great for Tempo.
>> Yeah. So, uh, likely this is going to be
a conqueror just deciding to finalize
the move trigger on what card we're
going to be discarding. I think
generically right here when there's
nothing better to do, the spell is great
because it does offer another draw. So,
net plus one in card advantage there.
And uh, you know, especially I think we
have a fizz in hand. So, even if it's a
star cross, we can discard it and then
we can play fizz again to answer their
>> discard draw.
to five. Yeah,
>> right. Going to five. Yeah,
>> we do have ride the wind.
>> Yeah, and with no runes up on Dwali's
side, there is no answer to stop it.
>> So, another draw one discard one could
be another spell for another plus one,
but it's going to be the way. So, plus
three here.
>> Oh, I have to wonder then if we are
going to be going to combat. Yep,
there's going to be that moonfall. Oh
yeah, and that's going to be huge here.
So, they are going to be able to move
the Hawaii
>> move trigger.
>> They do have the move trigger here
>> to draw one and discard one potentially.
If we discard a gear, we could have some
interaction with these runes here, but
it's going to be a uh unfortunately
Yeah,
>> going away.
>> Yep.
>> Go to six.
>> I had to join in.
>> You did. You did. I Yes. This this may
be our last punt of the day, so got to
do it.
drop.
>> Yeah. And we're going to have that use
that same ready to retreat back to the
base again. I mean, Hua being safe in
base is exactly where we wanted,
especially when I mean that board is
empty.
>> Yeah. I mean, just being able to do a
full lap around the board, right?
Getting two points, getting the removal
of their Haye, and we're going to play a
tie turner for two.
Definitely doesn't feel bad to play that
and getting that traveling merchant as
well. Just getting more units on board.
>> Yeah, at this point we just want to have
more units to be able to move and
contest these battlefields. Dewali on
potentially their last turn for this
game, for this match, for this
tournament. And we're going to have to
see if they have an answer to this
board.
>> Yeah, we this could be, as you said, the
last moments here. I mean, hopefully Twi
has an answer. Hopefully, we can do
something to prolong this and
potentially pull into the lead.
>> All right, eight runes to work with.
Again, in this game, we've have this
kind of situation where both of us just
had so many cards to work with. And uh
you know, it's never been about the
amount of cards. It's the cards that we
end up using.
>> Yeah,
it's the cards we use on the way.
>> Okay, you have to
>> Okay, I'll stop.
You don't have to. I'm just
>> awesome.
>> These are our last chances.
>> I know the these are these are uh I do
know that there is another top four
match on the other side. I'm not sure
what we're going to be able to to look
at there. There is a Rengar versus
either a Mastery or a Aelia. So, that's
on the other side. Uh but, you know, we
do know that there will be a Diana in
the finals, which makes me very happy.
>> Yeah, I'm not so happy about it. I will
be honest. Uh and I just want to clarify
I totally meant to put Rengar.
>> Yeah, it was, you know, sometimes these
uh these spelling mistakes happen. So
>> yeah, Rengar, Leblanc, they are very
closely.
>> They they almost share domain.
>> They almost share domain. They almost
are the same word. You never know. Uh
>> yeah, Dewali here definitely in the
think tank.
>> Just don't know which one. Oh no, you
don't have singularity anymore. Yeah,
need to make sure I think you know
obviously these players both know each
other's decks. So saying what could be
the answer here and
>> I don't I can't imagine combination of
cards that can be
>> trust me I can't either.
>> Yeah,
>> I I love the answer between the players.
I know I know I don't think there's any
options here actually to win and the
other player like yep I agree. Yeah, and
with these kind of situations where the
deck lists are open, you're like, man,
you're out of singularities, uh, like,
sure, you have this Fizz, which we don't
love to see, but with us having two
units on the board, it can just be an
easy push to forward. And again, Allen
ZQ asking to look for the trash.
>> Yeah, I mean, also just these, as you
mentioned earlier, the players know each
other so well. So, I mean, it's not the
first time they're playing as each
other. they have an idea of how they've
been practicing, what their deck is,
even if it uh even they didn't have
access to it. And so,
>> yeah, we're just going to pay two
likely uh like tie turner student
usually a unit, I would imagine. Uh
I mean, we have three runes up. We
potentially could do something here
maybe to
>> I could see Gus being very valuable
here. Uh that's an option for it. Uh I
don't think the signature spell can
activate really since we don't have any
units at any battlefields.
We'll see what we have optionwise here.
I mean starcross can maybe buy us
another turn, but I don't know to what
ends. And we're going to start off with
the traveling merchant traveling to the
southern abandoned hall.
Yeah, I mean just good sequencing,
making sure that with traveling merchant
we we have access potentially to
different cards that could help us. Uh
and then obviously we are going to see
if Dwali has any answers here.
>> All right. And we are going to use two
for the ride the wind and we are going
to immediately hard bargain asking
Dwali, do you feel comfortable enough
using
>> uh the rest of your
>> I'm going to pay two more than you're
going to hit me with a second one?
>> Yes.
And yeah, asking, do you have a second
one? Yes, we do. And Allen's EQ ends in
2-1 with that play getting us to the
finals.
>> I was
>> Yeah, what a fantastic job by Alan.
Fantastic by both players here. Balance
Q making sure he's got a spot in this
final. Potentially our first two time
winner.
>> Yep. So, fantastic game. Glad we were
able not able to watch it, but being
able to be right there in the action, be
able to cast it. And well done by
Allen's EQ.
>> 100%. What a great job. I mean, I cannot
wait. Obviously, we'll see if we do get
to see the other top four, but I mean,
what fantastic games today.
>> Yeah. So, uh, if in case you guys forgot
what we look like, I'm the Eggman. I'm
joined by Ursa Day. Uh, you know, this
is really wrapping up this weekend. Uh,
you know, we did have a Diana Mir match.
just get right down to the end of it and
we do have another top four match. Uh,
and we're going to see who's going to be
able to get to the finals.
>> Yeah, that's going to be so exciting. I
do know the last time I had checked, I
think it was at least the Rengar. Uh,
and the question is going to be who
ended up being the opponent.
>> Yeah. So, I think we're going to go
jumping over there. I'm not sure if
we're going to see the full top four or
not, but we're going to start off with
uh, you know, the secret sauce. Houses
are big. This will be, I think, the
third game that we've been able to cast
here. And, uh, maybe we're their lucky
charms. Maybe. So, actually, you never
know. I mean, this Y list, I think, is
just so unique. Uh, and I'm excited to
see if they have any answers for that
hyper aggro rankar list.
>> Yeah. So, uh, we have been seeing some
unique ads such as the Ashon in the
main, very good for Aurora builds, which
I don't believe there's any left here,
but, uh, could be good for that. Uh, we
also did have the primal strength that
you mentioned be a lot of value for just
four runes. Yeah, I think it can
hopefully get some, you know, use here
up against that uh against Rengar. We'll
have to see just if it can, but plus
seven can really get over so many
different units.
>> Yep. And then on the other side, we've
got the Ranggar. So, it's going to be a
battle of the body domains. We have Sam
Sherman, one of our previous uh regional
qualifier champions, trying to make it
two champion wins.
>> Yeah, that would be fantastic. And it is
so cool to see a Rengar, especially one
that is not Aurora. And it's just such a
hyper aggro list. I think we saw this
deck very early in day one, but so cool
to see it make it this far.
>> Yeah. So, we do see a lot of unique ads.
Something also that both players are
playing is that Emperor's Das, a
battlefield from Spirit Forge that is
getting a lot of usage when you do have
these, you know, a battlefield that can
play a unit does activate the Rengar
Legend ability and can be super
flexible. Yeah, 100%. I mean, it's going
to be so nice just increasing that might
from that Rengar ability. And also,
there's just so many different ways to
bounce and play units. I mean, that Grim
Apothecary can bounce units as well.
>> All right, so we're going to go back to
the match. Uh, and I think we're going
to uh go Yeah, here they are. Sammy
Sherman returning. This is going to be
game three and the winner takes all and
gets to fight Alen ZQ in the
championship match.
>> I am so excited to watch game three. It
is going to be Starring versus Starring
on these battlefields. I am excited to
see really how Ye plays into Rengar. And
something to note is I don't think many
of these top players really know or
really haven't practiced their decks in
Dengar itself. Yeah, I mean this was
probably of the top eight. The most
unusual legend to get there, but not an
unusual player to get into this top
eight with Sammy Sherman again trying to
defend their title to get the 2. And
again, we do have the secret sauce
houses are big here. Their team had a
fantastic showing this weekend. And you
know, we're going to see if they can
take it all.
>> Yeah, I mean, they seemed very confident
when we talked to them earlier today.
Uh, so the secret sauce could very well
have the secret sauce.
>> Yeah. And we're gonna go back to the
bracket real quick so you guys can see
it just in case you guys are just tuning
in. Also, we have been playing a little
bit of catchup. But this will be a live
match for the third game and then it
will be a live finals as well for the
grand finals. But we do see this top
eight of the secret sauce. Houses are
big with master. We have Balboas with
the Aurelia. We have Rockio with the
Azir. Sami Sherman with the Rengar.
Allen's EQ with the Deanna. We have Arto
with the Aurelia, Dewali with the
Deanna, as well as Swag Yellow 420 Yat
with the Civer.
>> I mean, what a diverse top eight that we
got to watch here today. It was so much
fun.
>> Yeah, six different legends across eight
different players. And even with like
the builds of Diana for Allen's EQ and
Dewali, they have these different cores
that make them different in my eyes.
>> Yeah, I definitely agree. So many I mean
so many different decks, so many
different ways that you play some of
these same decks. But we are going to be
getting back to this Master Yi as well
as this Rengar list. I am so excited to
see really what Rengar can do into
Master Yi if Master Yi has answers. And
honestly, since they're both one and one
right now, it does seem like this could
be an even match.
>> Yeah, and these decks do have a lot of
similarities. We're both using the body
domain. I would say Rengar is a little
bit more on the aggressive edge and then
we have Mastery on a little bit more of
the defensive edge, but that's also seen
on like using a lot of the same
battlefield. Star Spring here very
useful helping some movement that we
might be lacking otherwise. And uh you
know, again, another battlefield game
here.
>> Yeah, I mean I think really with Sammy
Sherman's list, he built it so hyper
aggro, really leaning into that uh that
aggressiveness that you were mentioning.
And I'm what is he going to do with it?
I mean, he seems to be piling it
fantastically.
>> Yeah. And we do have the pit rookie on
the other side. We have the irresistible
faolk. Two on two. And we're passing
back to houses are big.
>> Yeah. I mean, in this fa folk, it kind
of I mean, the ability is so
interesting. When I move to battlefield,
you can move an enemy unit to that
battlefield. It's kind of a just a
charm, right? which can be really
helpful to control your battles, be able
to bring your opponent's units to you
and make them fight on your in where you
are.
>> Mhm. All right. So, uh we're going to
see the pit rookie. Also, something
really useful with uh both of these
being starrings is you can move the
faith folk to one and you can ambush,
you can move it back, keep it safe for
later, and then you still be able to win
these combats. So houses are big kind of
saying, "Man,
>> what do I do here? Which which which of
these star springs should I go to? Which
one? Do you think the north one or the
south one?"
>> H I mean, it felt like in the last match
we saw going to the southern one was the
choice. So, I'm going to say northern
one.
>> Okay. We're going to see if the uh if we
decide to go to the northern battlefield
here.
We don't also have to go to a
battlefield either, but you know, if
we're trying to get there, if we're
trying to activate our champion ability
to get that plus two might when we
defend alone, we better be at a place
where we can defend.
>> Yeah, that is a good point. We want to
really use that plus two might. We want
to use our leader ability cuz we know
Rengar is going to be able to. Also,
when you're kind of up against a really
aggressive list, maybe it's smart to go
on and get into a battlefield, get an
early point. Instead, we pass back to
Sham Sam D. Sherman.
>> Yep. And so we've got the Fay Folk here.
Again, if we have any of these ambushes,
we can get some good interactions here.
>> Does leave ourselves a little bit open,
but
>> I mean, we can move Fay Folk to
Starring, we can play the Rengar in our
champion, move it back at one
>> and uh that could be pretty aggressive
there.
Yeah, I assume if we're going to be
wanting to use this charm uh the charm
ability, then we definitely kind of need
to get more units that have more might.
But luckily, Rengar's list has a lot of
ambush units that can help it join uh
join their resistable faithful at the
battlefield. And yep, bringing that
Master Yi up. Rengar comes in and we
win.
>> Yeah, I mean, yeah, I'm happy I
preloaded that that interaction because
we went pretty quickly through it. But
once again, Fay Folk brings in the
Master Yi. We play out the Rengar, the
Starring moves back the uh Fa Folk, and
then it was a seven to four getting rid
of the Yei.
>> Yeah, I feel like that's really nice for
70 Sherman. Kind of showcases why that
card's in the deck. Now, uh we would be
uh if if we were trying to get like a
perfect hand here, I think we are
missing a card that we could hide at
that spar star spring if we did have
like an ambush like a hidden unit we can
play to either one move our Rengar back
safely or be able to get enough power to
contest and attack here. Uh that could
be the case. But looks like we are going
to move the pit rookie to the northern
>> and we'll see if it gets there.
>> Yes.
Yeah, bringing that pokey into that
northern star spring now.
>> I do like this. So, uh, couple
interactions. We got the first mate,
which is going to push back the pit
rookie and then also going to let it be
active. So, we are at one point. We are
going to play another pit rookie. Going
to use it on the first mate. So, it's
going to have six might when defending
with a combination of the plus one might
from the buff and the legend ability.
And we've got the charm. is going to be
six to six.
>> Blood bath.
>> Yeah, and we get the full trade there.
>> Yeah, I mean it's going to be nice to
remove the Rengar. It was such a big
unit, but now we are just going to try
to take that other point. Go going up to
two now.
>> Yeah, and obviously we probably were
hoping for maybe like if we had an
Unguard onstead of this pit rookie could
have been a better trade for us, but we
used what we had and this is a really
good position for houses are big.
>> Yeah, two to one. All right, so
So currently two to one. Uh if we have
another ambush unit, we can kind of do
the same play. Uh especially because we
could move the pit rookie with the other
one. We don't get the defending alone.
>> We're playing three two drops.
>> And uh we are going to buff up this fa
folk here.
>> Yeah, you suck your
>> Yeah, I mean it is so nice getting all
of those rangard triggers. Each unit
that you play can be a plus one to any
of the units that you have. So even
though it's irresistible faithful reads
a one, it became a four. A five.
>> Yeah, it came. Yeah, it became a five
with the pit rookie. I know the they're
going a little bit fast. I think these
interactions have happened a lot in the
games we haven't been able to see. But
uh since we moved over the uh pit
rookie, that also means they're not
defending alone. So it's four and we're
just putting out the Rengar. Uh yeah,
it's really just showing off all of
these good body cards. Yeah, I mean it
seems like both of these players really
are enjoying playing their Rengars
getting uh I mean both of them are
getting a lot of use from it and I love
seeing these two players because they're
really just having fun with this match.
I mean s houses are big. I echoed what
he said but uh he roared as he played
his rankar.
>> I mean it's kind of I feel like you kind
of have to right uh just toss it on to
the star spring say hey I need to uh I
need to take this point. We've got the
Zanya's hourglass that we're just
instead of hiding playing out for the
two. Currently three points for two for
houses are big here.
>> Yeah, I mean getting the zonies down
also is just going to keep this Rengar
safe. Even if it is able to be killed by
Sam Sherman, it will return back to
base. Yeah, and there could be some
trickiness where we move like a pit
rookie to one, then we move the fay folk
to move the Rengar and then get the
other point. But that will cost us to
lose a lot of units on board. So likely
trying to find a better way to do so.
>> Yeah, and we do also have a lot of runes
up. Each of the units that we play also
are kind of plus ones. And Inferno will
get assault potentially if we decide to
use her. So just some hidden might in
there with that assault text.
>> Yeah, currently the Rengar is at six
might at the southern star spring. We
will get an additional plus two if we
are defending alone. So eight is a
little bit much currently. Uh if we had
access to something like a punch first.
Again, we've seen that the Rengar
ability is not a once per turn either.
So if you have a bunch more units to
keep stacking up the value,
>> we can get that value there. But again,
the Zua's hourglass saving the Rengar is
very scary
>> for sure. It's I mean, as long as that
Rengar is by itself, I mean, and there's
no other units on the board, that zoning
is hourglass is kind of reading as
another Rengar once it dies.
>> All right, so only one card in hand left
for House. We are going to use the
sabotage to get rid of the Defy. And we
know that there is a first mate left in
hand, which is a little terrifying.
We'll have some good interactions with
this Rengar next turn.
We could just try to get a third point
and uh try to just hang out in the back.
But something with Rengar in particular,
uh you have to be really careful when
you play your units because sometimes
you need that might at later turns too,
right?
>> Mhm. Yeah. I mean that is a great point.
Like trying to figure out when you're
going to play it is really important.
But I mean I feel like these cards at
least in the Ringard side are so
flexible since so many of them do have
ambush. Even if you don't play them
early, uh you can play them both almost
kind of I don't say as like a half
discipline because of the ring guard.
>> Yeah. So it looks like uh thinking about
playing the pit rookie it looks like to
the star spring.
>> I had three points
>> going to three.
>> Yeah, they're even in points again here.
Still trying to figure out what to do
about the Rengar on houses. Our big
side.
Yeah, but unfortunately our card draws a
little bit low here and we've got three
cards in hand. We're just passing with
seven whole runes. So really
intimidating. There could be uh
potentially another ambush card coming
down and we'll see what Sandy Sherman
>> I get to pick this up
>> tries to do.
has he
what's I mean Ye is now at let's see
eight runes up here while we're trying
to make this decision.
>> Yeah, we've got eight runes, four
points. We do know we've got two cards
in hand. One of them was the first mate
that we saw from the sabotage
>> and we're just straight passing here.
>> Wow.
>> It's pretty interesting when you did
nothing last turn.
both players like ah man we've got so
low resources I don't want to overextend
and you know really afraid of you know
what these ambushes what these runes can
really uh signify but if I mean if
you're ahead on E you don't really need
to do anything here uh you will kind of
slowly hold to eight and you're going to
be doing so a little bit faster than Sam
Sherman's going to do
>> yeah definitely where we're standing
right now Sam Sherman is the one that's
going to have to I mean attack in and
push that Rengar off the battlefield
currently
Since I mean houses are being lead happy
to sit there, right?
>> Yeah. Now, we could do something like
move the pit rookie back and then we
could use the irresistible fay folk to
move it open. We do have the niti here.
>> Learned his lesson
>> and uh we're going to pass it back.
>> Let's see. Yeah, we're just slowly
building the base. I feel like you may
think this Rengar list you be playing it
a lot of these units directly to the
battlefield, but it looks like you can
also just build your base like a normal
riftbound game.
>> Yeah. And uh you know, Nidi specifically
uh when I win a combat, I get to draw
one. Uh and you know, I think they were
hoping that there was something to react
with last turn to be able to play the
Niti on their opponent's turn, but uh
without that being the case, they kind
of just passed all their runes, right?
>> Yeah. It's it's interesting to see. We
saw it as well between Dwali and Allen
ZQ just how cautious these soft players
are of each other. They are, you know,
they're both so seasoned. They have to
be very respect respectful of the number
of runes that are up, the number of
cards that they have. Every resource
means so much.
>> No question about it.
>> Yeah. And uh you know, they're just
saying, man, it's just this irresistible
faith folk is just offering so much
control potential here. We're at five
points here and a lot of runes
>> for both players here.
>> The Jin held hostage by that card right
there.
be nice to get to six this turn.
>> Now, something we could do is that we
could push everything to the northern
battlefield and Rengar would be the
attacker, right? Since the irresistible
move, so
>> I don't have anything in my hand, but
>> that could be potential there. Uh,
obviously with the zonas, you can just
get it back so you're not as worried
about it.
>> Yeah, I mean, it would not be as bad.
They still would want to find a way to
try to get into that bottom battlefield
afterwards instead of that ring guard
just moving up. But yet trying at least
popping the zonas would be a start in
trying to get the trying to get houses
to be behind the points instead of kind
of ahead.
>> And just looking in there, I'm thinking
I can see the hand as well. Uh
potentially like in Italy. Uh we'll see
the rest.
>> Oh, that's great.
>> As we get it there. Yeah, I think needy
challenge potentially.
>> Yeah, but just thinking about here.
Yeah, we just kind of it's a starown. I
mean, this has been so much passing back
and forth. Houses are big has three
cards, so two unknowns after the first
mate that was revealed after the
sabotage.
And Sam is just thinking here, you know,
do we can we afford to use runes? Do we
need to be, you know, respectful of when
our ambush triggers are going to happen?
>> Yeah, I mean,
we really want to get in there. I do
think that's what Sam is thinking about.
Is this the turn to do it? Obviously, we
don't lose just yet if we wait because
max that houses could get to if somehow
they can get to that northern
battlefield is only to seven this
following turn. So maybe I have time to
wait, but we're getting close.
>> Yeah. And I think the the decision here
is that we could, you know, again, when
it matters when we play these units and
we get the plus ones, right? Like
>> that is important.
>> And this Pike is, I think, such a strong
and interesting card in the deck. It can
also be played as hidden. Obviously, it
is not right now, but Pike can be a five
at times. Right now, it is four. Uh they
did play that extra rune to be able to
get plus two and instead of putting that
plus one onto the pike, they are going
to be putting it onto Niti instead. But
>> yeah, and now we're moving over here.
We're a big nine
>> to the eight here. So we do have plus
four, plus three, plus two.
And again, these one might differences
can offer such a difference here.
>> Bystander.
>> Yeah, but I mean, obvious I do think
this is something that Yi has the
potential to deal with. We know that
Primal Strength is a card that this Yi
player does run, especially in their
main deck. That's a plus seven, and
we're only one above right now.
Obviously, we do have seven runes as
well on Sam D. German side, but we have,
you know, both these players can make
these units a lot bigger.
>> Yeah. And again, with like the body uh
domain, there are so many of these ways
to increase the might of our units.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> And again, so with the pike, we did have
ganking and the plus two. Uh and again,
I do like being able to use the uh star
spring to offer some movement.
Yeah, I think that is so nice. It starts
springing almost also gives that pseudo
gang gang. Uh I believe it's pit rookie
that was up there that because it was
ready pushing it back by putting pike to
that top battlefield. It is still ready
when it's in base and they can all move
up together.
>> I mean obviously we do have to think
here. We saw earlier houses are big was
low on cards. So every single card that
he plays is going to be so important.
>> Yeah. And
>> we're in this weird spot again. They're
talking about the irresistible faithful
kind of holding them hostage, right? The
fact that you know if you play out a
unit fault would move it and then you
pop the zas so it doesn't work on the
Rengar anymore. Uh so it's been really
really tough to play around it. Yeah, I
definitely agree. And there's going to
be that primal strength. Uh Sam was not
happy to see it come down. It is going
to be a plus seven, making us I think
15.
>> Oh boy.
>> Uh so you're what 15 total?
>> I'm 15 total.
>> Yeah, 15 to 19 right now. Does Sam have
any response?
>> Well, there there's been the the visible
response uh to that card being played
right. But we'll see if there's one in
the game cuz that was probably a little
bit more might than we were hoping to
see on that rank. Yeah, on that opposing
rankar.
>> Yeah, I will say I do think how big is
playing one up if I completely if I
remember correctly. So, you know, maybe
you you know, you take that bet. This is
he has a very small hand. Hopefully, it
will not be that primal strength. It'll
be something like discipline or on guard
instead uh and maybe has to overcome
that. But plus seven is
a lot.
>> It's it's a lot. Yeah. It's it's almost
a comical amount uh for this game in
these situations. And yeah, how how are
you going to get over this six might
deficit?
>> I mean, it seems like Sam D. Sherman is
asking that same question right now.
Hopefully, they have something here,
though, because they've committed three
units to this.
Yep. And this is just very tough here.
>> It's not going to be easy.
>> Two left.
>> Two cards left in hand. We know one of
them is a first mate. The other is an
unknown to Sam D. Sherman here. We've
got seven whole runes to play with.
>> Oh, yes.
>> All right.
>> And he says, "All right, you got me."
>> That is going to hurt.
>> He's too big of a boy.
>> I'm just gonna pass.
>> I actually find this a really
six here.
>> Yeah,
>> I for a second I thought the one six was
because it's 16 might, but it's 15
might. Never mind.
>> All right. Well, we're going to get two
more runes here.
>> Yeah, there's no other response. Rengar
survives. Doesn't even have to pop that
zonas. And we have so many runes on
House of our big side though. Only three
cards.
>> Yeah. And again, we are so disentivized
to playing out a unit cuz it can just
get removed very easily.
>> Yeah. And honestly, we kind of don't
want to. If it's anything smaller than
that Rengar, then Sandy Sherman could
actually purposely kill that unit to pop
zonas.
>> Yeah. And also potentially get a draw
from Niti if it survives the combat,
too.
>> That too. And we I mean, Sandy Sherman
does have a larger hand size, I believe,
than houses, but you don't want to give
him more cards.
Yeah. Uh we could do uh potentially play
a unit at the Starring, move back to
Rengar, go to the other one, have a
double hold at seven, and if both held,
we end up winning.
Yeah, very tense here. Again, we are so
close on these point totals too that if
we overextend, it could just be an easy
double conquer on Sandy Sherman's side.
But looks like we are going to play our
lonely Porro here. Going to use the Star
Spring to move back to Rengar. Going to
move into the other Starring. Going to
take it six points to seven now. And
with one hold, houses are big can find
themselves in the finals.
>> Yeah, this is going to I mean be really
difficult for Sam Sherman. needs to
clear out both of these battlefields
potentially next turn. Uh because I mean
if this if this showdown completes and
that Rengar is able to take that second
battle.
>> Yeah,
>> I have two cards in my hand.
>> Confirming there. Two cards in hand
again. Sam Sherman should know one of
them is a first mate.
>> Does he have an answer? Because seven
points is a very hard spot to be in for
Sam.
Yeah, it is going to be very tough here.
>> Yeah, I mean we could react with uh an
ambush unit into our uh
>> into our base as well if we're afraid of
a charm. Yeah,
>> I'll go to seven.
>> Going to seven.
>> Okay, and up to seven we are. They
didn't have any reaction and now we have
to clear out both of these sides.
>> Three in hand, you said.
>> Yeah. Three in hand for Sandy Sherman.
Two in hand for houses are big.
>> Yeah. And still we have I think it's
nine runes up here which is going to I
mean a lot to work with. Our hand size
is very small. But I mean,
we want to make sure that we can win
here, but also we do know that even if
Sam can clear both these sides, we have
another turn to potentially come in. And
it does look like first mate is going to
get played into that bottom star spring.
>> All right, so offering some more
defense. One card in hand for houses are
big. I don't believe I know what it is.
I don't believe Sandy Sherman does
either. We've got a whole lot of runes
and we're going to have to try to
conquer both of these battlefields.
>> We're in that top four game three here.
And this could very well be the last
turn that decides our final player in
the finals.
>> Yeah, and I think we just drew a Darius.
Something that could be incremental for
helping us get this double conquer here.
Yeah, I mean Darius is so nice. If
Darius uh when you play your second card
that turn, you can ready Darius and give
it a plus two. So it can make it I mean
both
very large uh but also you know able to
move in this turn.
>> Yep. Looks like we are going to play the
Darius for five here.
>> We will need a second card though to
ready it. Yeah, but I think we've got a
challenge as well. If we play the
challenge, we could use it on the
Rengar, get the plus two uh to the
might, and that could be enough to not
only get rid of the Rengar at the top,
but then pressure the bottom and clear
the first mate and lonely Porro.
>> That would be so nice. And by doing the
challenge as well, we would not get that
plus two from the Master Yi, which will
be really important here.
>> Now, we do have to play around the Za's
hourglass. are really incentivized to
get rid of one of these smaller units
first.
>> Yeah, and it looks like that's something
we are looking at here. Right now
though, we are one might to five, but
it's bringing Rengar down into that
bottom battlefield.
>> Pump Darius with this. Send this back.
>> Ready, Darius.
>> All right, so we are going to ambush
with the inferna here. So, we are
attacking. So, it's currently three.
This is a three at this time. Is that
right?
>> Yeah. 3 to uh I believe it's 11 on this
uh this battle field here.
>> Yeah. Currently
I mean currently that is potentially
killing the first mate or the lonely
porro. Lonely por won't get the death
nail cuz it's not by itself and whoever
dies will pop that zonas instead of the
rangar.
>> Now uh and that that is a little bit
unfortunate here. One car in hand for
houses are big.
>> I think this is going to happen.
>> Yeah, it is definitely unfortunate for
it not to be the Rengar, but at least we
will potentially have a unit even if
they are able to clear out this
battlefield.
>> Yeah, and then on the other side uh with
the Rengar and Lonely Porro, that will
be a total of eight might and that nine.
>> So that's exhaustive
>> might for the Darius could clear the
bottom battlefield.
potentially finding his foothold
foothold here.
>> I mean, houses are big is just trying to
figure out what is the best way to deal
with this. We have one card. Is it
something that can help us here is a
huge question.
>> Yeah. And you know, there could be so
many different solutions here. And yeah,
it's going to go down.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. Yeah, I assume that's
>> pop the Zagna's hourglass. Yeah, first
mate stays around. Not necessarily the
one we'd want, but it's the one we get.
>> He's still three might.
>> He's Yeah, he's still around. He's not
He's not terrible, but uh we definitely
would love a little bit more protection
on our Rengar here. So, currently on the
Southern Battlefield, we do have a
Rengar and Lonely Porro. Uh with the
combined might total of eight since we
aren't alone for either of them. We have
our Darius that is active with nine
might. So that can pressure the bottom
battlefield very uh successfully and
we'll see what Sammy Sherman decides to
do.
>> Yeah, I mean right now that is enough.
We won't get that Master U because there
are two units at the bottom battlefield.
That does mean right that Darius is just
a little bit bigger but
>> potentially we still have might
increasing card a might increasing card
in hand.
>> Yeah. So we do have to be aware of those
interactions for sure.
But we are going to move Darius all the
way to the star spring and we'll have to
see what the last card in hand for
houses are big if it can interact with
this eight might to nine.
>> Right. You haven't scored this turn.
That's right.
>> Eight to nine right now. Something like
a discipline would just slightly put us
over that Darius and like an ong guard
would as well. I mean this going to be
super nice. It would let us draw too.
Um,
>> but I believe Sammy Sherman does get the
first options here.
>> Yeah, two cards in hand.
>> We do have the punch first.
>> Holding this till the very end here.
>> That is a lot of might.
>> Do your worst.
>> You have 13. I have nine.
>> 13 to nine.
>> We're going to play out the Ni here. So
that's going to offer us not only four
more might but an additional fifth one.
>> That is going to be enough.
>> Got to figure out which to kill. You got
one card in hand.
>> Yeah.
>> And yeah, do we want to get rid of the
Niti or the Darius? If we get rid of the
Darius, we do get a draw from the Niti,
right? Uh but obviously Darius is kind
of the scarier card, too. So no great
answer immediately.
Yeah, I mean Darius can also just like
ready itself every every sec second card
of a turn. It can ready itself. So you
could see it move a lot. That is a
really scary unit. But do you want to
give him cards? Such a great question to
act. I mean not a question I would be
wanting to go through at this moment.
>> Yeah. So going to get rid of the Darius.
Niti will activate a draw one here for
Sam D. Sherman. Six points to seven. We
can still conquer the northern
battlefield. uh tough game. Yeah, for
sure.
>> Yeah, I mean I have a feeling that I
mean San Die is going to want to try to
take that upper battlefield just so that
uh those who don't know you cannot win
the game simply off of conquering one
battlefield to eight points, but you do
get a draw off it. You have to have
control of both battlefields to get that
ace point or hold
>> here.
>> Yeah. So, we'll see what the card draw
off. Houses are big just like the house.
It's got to be a big one. And we'll see
if we can interact with these Nitles.
>> Yeah. What will this one card be?
>> I guess that could
>> This is the last turn essentially.
>> Mhm.
>> So, we're both at seven.
>> Seven and seven.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> We've got the charm. Okay. So, this will
offer us a draw one.
>> Yeah.
>> Because we're at seven here.
>> Yep. We get the draw. going to be
Rangar.
>> No. No.
>> What is it?
>> It still might be.
>> Uhoh.
>> All right, we've got the scuttle crab.
>> Okay,
>> houses are big.
>> That's a I mean, that's a draw.
>> That is a draw.
>> Figure out if I need to swing this.
>> All right, moving back the first mate.
Next card.
>> Oh,
>> looking unlikely now.
>> I want to see what's in your hand.
>> Yeah, going to see the card in hand. We
see a challenge. We do get to rip it off
with the sabotage here. And that's going
to be it. Sam Sherman going to make it
to the finals once again. And it's going
to be a battle of the Rengar versus
Diana.
>> Oh my gosh, what a fantastic game though
in between that Ye player and Rengar.
>> I played around.
>> And it was Sandy Surman that did win
that game. Houses are big. Uh will be
finishing with a fantastic top four
finish especially for the secret sauce.
They had a fantastic run today, but Sam
Sherman will be our winner with Rengar.
>> Yeah. Did you expect a Rengar going into
finals today?
>> Yeah. I mean, seeing it in top 64,
seeing it in top eight, seeing it in the
finals. It's made it all the way here,
and I can't wait to see how it goes.
>> It's going to be absolutely awesome to
see how it can really interact with
Diana. I mean, such a, you know, unit
heavy deck versus a spellheavy deck. Who
will come out on top?
>> Yeah. And we'll have to see if you know
Allen's EQ if this was a match up they
were expecting and it's going to be a
fantastic one.
>> If it was one they were expecting. I
mean I think Allen's EQ prepared better
than anyone.
>> Yeah. So uh that is going to be what our
finals for our event here in Vancouver
is going to be Allen's EQ on Diana
versus Sam Sherman on the Rengar. And
also we will confirm have our first
twotime regional qualifier champion.
Yeah, I think that is something I am so
excited to look I mean to get to see
coming up. Sam D Sherman the winner of
the RQ Las Vegas was with a Draven list
and then obviously that RQ Bolognia
winner which is Allen ZQ who won with
Ezreal.
Like this is kind of a match between two
huge bosses right of our game so far.
>> Yeah. And we're going to look at the
standings one more time. We're going to
see what the top eight looked like and
how we got here. So, we're going to
switch to that real soon. But here we
go. We've got Sam Destruing once again
on Rengar and Allen's EQ with the Diana.
>> And both these players had such a
fantastic run through this top eight.
Obviously, we had so many great names in
it. Three of our RQ winners. Allan ZQ,
Dewal, Dewali, Sam D. Sherman running a
lot of different decks up here as well.
TSS houses are big. Balboas, Rocklo,
Arrio, and the Swagilo 420. Yeah, all in
our top eight. But now it's going to be
Allen ZQ versus Sammy Sherman.
>> So really excited about that. And before
we do, we're going to get some
interviews as we get into there. We've
got one with Allen ZQ and let's see how
he's feeling.
I once again have the most absolute
pleasure to be joined with Allan ZQ, our
first lockedin finalist for the
Vancouver regional qualifier. Allan,
what a spectacular match. I'm sure you
could feel it. We all felt it. We all
watched it. We could hear you both. And
wow. I I just want to hear your opinions
on that match as a whole. you and
Dewali's relationship of play testing
and preparing this deck because at the
end of the day, this is a a prolific
moment not just for you moving on to
finals, but playing against Dwali in the
semis, playing a deck that you have both
been helping each other make better
players. So, can you please speak to
that?
>> Yeah, first and foremost, uh I took my
revenge for Houston.
>> That is true. This time I did not miss
my triggers.
But yeah, uh all seriousness, we prepped
with the Sean together. Sean needed a
bit of the preps overall because he felt
like uh he was a bit short coming short
on the air. He was coming and he asked
for the help and uh absolutely I'm
always down to practice with the good
people which also helped me to tune the
deck the way it was. that the both
versions mine and Sean's was prepared
through together which shown an absolute
dominance across we both were undefeated
and just I did twice before the top cut
and now we just like we had to just meet
meet each other once again and
unfortunately one of us had to go was
hoping that we get to face each other in
the finals but had to be sooner and yeah
it was just wonderful be free uh back
and forth at at the end I drew who
slightly better was a bit despair in the
game three when I didn't draw neither of
the two drop and then I I knew that he
has a singularity in hand based on how
the game was going and like I knew that
I will lose if I don't draw my
singularity and the turn where I had to
de with stupifies and I finally found it
after four stack decks and so much card
draw that I was relieved that the game
is still playable
>> and it absolutely was and you know I
even think about it too because you
you're right you there was a hope even
from me that you two would have gone
against each other in the finals and you
were literally waiting for the results
of one other match leading into this top
eight and you two could have been
potentially first and second seed and it
just didn't fall that way in the cards
but instead we got to spectate an
immaculate match between two immaculate
players and I have said it once already
today but I will say it again Allan you
could be and quite frankly might very
well be our first ever twotime regional
qualifier champion just overall all
letting that sink in. That could be you
in a couple of minutes, an hour in this
amount of time. That could be you. How
does it feel to potentially take that
sort of title?
>> I mean, it's bound to happen. Don't know
if it's going to be today or the other
one. But I'm here to just make the best
possible lines and uh if that's enough
to win out, then I'm all for it.
>> I know the fans are cheering you on,
Alan. I know everyone at home is going
to be excited to watch who your opponent
will be in this grand finals here at the
Vancouver Regional Qualifier.
Allan, I wish you the best of luck once
again and we'll see you sitting at that
table. But for now, send it away. All
right, that is one of our finalists. And
now we also have another interview from
the other side. We got Sammy Sherman
just nearly winning that game against
Mastery with Houses are big and let's
see their thoughts going into this
finals.
here now with our second attempt at a
twotime regional qualifier champion with
Sam D. Sherman after that incredible
performance we just saw. I've got to ask
you, as I've already asked Allan today,
you are now going to be sitting in that
finals chair against him. No matter
what, we will have a repeat champion and
it could be you, Sam. How does that
feel?
>> It's very exciting. Uh I it would be
pretty crazy if it's me. It seems like,
you know, Allan's been in the top eight
a bazillion times already, so it
wouldn't be surprising at all if it's
him. But uh yeah, I'd love to be me.
>> That's very humble of you to say. But I
mean, the fact that you both have
brought us to such high levels of
ripbound, not once, but twice now, and
we're going to see that second time. And
I think regardless of who the winner is,
a story is being cemented today for both
of you because you it is so hard to play
at this high level and then to do it
again and take home a crown let alone
sit in that chair again. So I mean we've
talked about this already, right? You
know, having come from other card games
and trying and trying and trying and
that skill transfers here to Riftbound
to such a difficult card game and you're
you're pulling it off. You're doing
you're doing it live
and I'm so proud that it's on a legend
like Rengar. I don't think anyone
thought that was going to happen and
you're playing it so strategically well.
I've got to just ask I mean did you
really think your Rengar deck could sit
here in this finals chair?
>> It was not the plan. Uh actually ran
into Allan earlier today and he he said
who are these people that you're playing
that you're beating them with Rengar?
He like he he he he said he actually
practiced against almost my exact deck
list a b a b a b a b a b a b a b a b a b
a b a bunch and he he thought it was not
a very good deck. So um hopefully I can
make him eat his words but uh I think he
might be right to be honest. I
appreciate the honesty Sam but I'm a big
fan. I know the people out there want to
see Rengar take it home the thrill of
the hunt. I hope you can feel it and
send us the thrill at home. Sam, I wish
you the best of luck in the finals. It's
going to be one for the ages because two
immaculate players will be sitting in
those chairs. We're going to send it
back so you can have some time to
prepare.
>> All right, and thank you very much for
that interview. Love to hear Sam's
thoughts going on into it. Maybe not
necessarily optimistic, but definitely
uh you know optimistic that they are in
that finals.
>> I thought that was absolutely hilarious
for the record. I mean, and Sam
obviously took it very well, and it's so
cool to see these players interact. They
are friendly with each other, and it's
going to be a fantastic finals.
>> Yes. And as we get to this finals, this
is going to be our final cast. So, I
really appreciate the opportunity to
work with you, Ursa Day, and everyone
else for this production. It was a
fantastic weekend, and one I'm going to
remember always.
>> Yeah, I think for sure. I had so much
fun casting with you. I think the games
were so much fun and obviously
production, everyone, Riot, they did so
great this weekend.
>> Yes. So, we're gonna take one final
break before the finals, but you guys
don't want to go anywhere. We're going
to send it to Alex and Silverfuse once
they get there and looking forward to
it. So, we'll be right back.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hey everybody.
Silver, can you believe that the finals
are finally here? We have Allen versus
Sam D. Sherman, Rengar versus Diana. And
listen, what's amazing about this is we
are going to potentially have, well,
we're going to have the first ever
Riftbound twotime regional champion. And
that's what I love about this game is we
can have over a thousand players
competing and still see those same names
and faces because of their dominance,
how much effort they have put in
practicing these decks, becoming the
best they can possibly be and be able to
perform time and time again.
>> We've said it so many times over this
weekend that the skill expression of of
Riftbound is absolutely through the
roof. And we're seeing it here. You're
seeing a very consistent pattern of some
of these absolute best players putting
on incredible performances. and we are
going to be seeing an absolutely
remarkable finals.
>> Yeah, on top of that, these players are
also playing decks that they didn't win
with previously. So, that's really cool
to see the way that our meta has
evolved. Now, let's take a look at the
bracket. Um, this has been a very
interesting ride to the finals here. Um,
of course, we had the Master Yi losing
out to Sam D Sherman in the semifinals.
What were your thoughts on the Master E
deck?
>> I mean, overall it is a strong mid-range
strategy. However, Sam piloted that deck
to perfection once again. The Rengar
just being able to get just enough might
all the time to get over the Master Yi
holds.
>> Now, Aurelia was a absolute favorite to
be one of the potentially championship
decks, but ultimately it has not gone
into the finals. What were you thinking
about perhaps what kind of caused
Aurelia to stumble a little bit moving
into this top eight? Well, funny enough
is some of the gear hate that hits the
Aurora decks also hits the Aurelia.
Being able to take away those guardian
angels is really big overall. And so if
you didn't have a way to really protect
your Aurelia, there are ways to
essentially for Aurelia just to fall
over and lose because of that.
>> And you do bring up Aurora. We only had
one Aurora in the top eight. That was
Swag Yolo 420. Yeah. And they ultimately
weren't able to get to the finals. Now
Aurora tends to be a contentious topic
in the world of Earthbound. What are
your thoughts on the results that we've
seen here?
>> It doesn't really surprise me. I mean,
Swag 420 Ya is one of the best pilots of
Aurora as we've seen them get best of
Civer multiple times. So, the fact that
they are in the top eight isn't
surprising, but seeing other decks being
able to overcome it is what we expected
here, I would say.
>> Now, what we've got next is what
everyone has been waiting for. We're
getting prepared to start the finals,
and we're going to start by discussing
the deck list of both Sam Sherman and
Allen. First, we're going to start with
Allan ZQ's Diana deck. Now, this is one
that we have become increasingly more
familiar with throughout the weekend
here. Is there anything that you want to
point out?
>> Well, first off, this matchup, something
about it is there is no gear for Sam
Sherman. So, these acceptable losses are
actually just going to be dead cards in
the first game until they can be
sideboarded out because there is no gear
in the deck for the Rangguard. A really
smart move by Sam because expecting all
the gear hate in the main, you're
getting matches like this where
potentially your opponent draws two dead
cards.
>> Now, I do need your opinion on Vex
Apathetic. There is a two of in the main
deck for Allen ZQ. Vex Apathetic is of
course going to be extremely problematic
for the likes of Sam D. Sherman. It's
going to shut down those ambush
mechanics and a lot of the accelerate
that uh is uh kind of the basis of the
Fury strategy. What are some of the ways
that Sam can kind of work around this
Vex apathetic?
>> A lot of it's going to come down to
developing a wide base and then being
able to go in afterwards and that's
going to be the biggest thing overall.
If Allen is able to get a Vex apathetic
stuck on the board, it could be a quick
game. We'll have to see what happens
though.
>> And similar to acceptable losses, it's
also worth knowing you do have a turn to
dust in the main deck as well. Let's
take a look at Sam Sherman's deck, the
Rengar, which has taken everyone by
surprise. We had spoke at great lengths
about how whether or not Fury was going
to have a presence in the top brackets
here, and it has made its way all the
way to the finals in Rengar, no less.
>> So, the biggest thing that we've seen is
irresistible fay folk perform over and
over again. And this is just such a
smart inclusion by Sam D. German saying,
"You know what? I can be an aggressive
deck, but I can also be a bit proactive
and take control of the game by buffing
up my irresistible fay folks or other
units." And then being able to pull my
opponent's enemy units over and saying,
"Okay, we're going to get a favorable
trade and then I'm going to push my
advantage after that." I love this shout
out a lot because I feel like
irresistible fa folk was a card that was
hyped up quite a bit leading into the
pre-release and then once the release
came out with Fury not having the best
results the irresistible fa folk and
well obviously it's a it's a body card
but it was being played in these
aggressive style decks it wasn't getting
the love it deserves and finally Sami
Sherman is showcasing to the world just
how good this card is and Sam Sherman
seems to be a master of these mid-range
decks we talked about it in the past
when it was the victory in Las Vegas he
brought the Draven mid-range deck where
it was the Draven Miracle decks that a
lot of people were expecting to do well.
>> Yeah, we don't always know what up what
is up Sam Sherman's sleeve. But I also
want to note that Thrill the Hunt seeing
that being used as what I would say its
intention potentially of being able to
conquer battlefields early and then
blink it over to another battlefield
instead of just saying I'm going to get
the ability from a unit. We are actually
using it to get extra points as well.
It's a very efficient tool for this
deck.
>> The moment you've all been waiting for
is finally here. It's time that we go to
the table and crown our champion in
Vancouver. Allan ZQ Sam D. Sherman ready
to face off for the championship here in
Vancouver.
>> I'm so excited for this matchup. We've
been waiting all weekend for it. These
players are both amazing players. So, I
can't wait to see the way that they
pilot these decks, the key decisions
that they make. There's so much that can
go right, so much that can go wrong, and
we're about to get into the action.
>> One thing worth noting here that you
know, you at home listening, first of
all, welcome. You might be nice and
comfortable on a coach, these players
have been playing literally for days.
You had the Friday events where they
were practicing and getting prepared.
You had the Saturday events, and then
finally, we have game one of the finals.
So, of course, from Allen, we have the
Raven Bloom Conservatory. This is a
really important battlefield in this
matchup because Sandy Sherman does not
have that many spells in the list. We do
have the Thrill of the Hunt that we
talked about earlier, but overall Allen
could potentially generate so much value
from these Raven Bloom Conservatory.
>> Yeah, it's it's one of those
battlefields that realistically Sam D.
Sherman doesn't really care all that
much about. Allen ZQ is going to be able
to generate a ton of value from it. Uh
similarly though you do have the
emperor's uh deis and that there is
going to be one that Sam Sherman does
want to take advantage of might be some
limited use for Allen getting that two
uh that two might sand soldier is of
value but Sam Sherman is of course going
to be able to put that to greater
effectiveness.
So we do see the Fizz mold back here
because it isn't going to be grabbing
anything out of the trash. We have the
Raven Bloom student for Allen's EQ. So
we'll be able to have a two drop. Uh it
is to note that Allen is the higher seed
here at that third seed. So he will be
playing first.
>> Both these decks are relatively
aggressive. In the prior games, Sam was
absolutely trying to score points early.
Let's see how we start off here. One of
the amazing things about Diana as well,
whether you go first or second, Diana
does have amazing plays on either end,
especially with that chosen champion,
which really does start the game off
well going second. So Allen definitely
is in a strong position here to go
first, establish a board, and take
advantage of the early tempo.
>> And I want to note that we already do
have that Vex Apathetic in hand, a card
that we said would be a key card in this
matchup, being able to delay Sam
Sherman. On top of that, we also have
Gust, a very high tempmpo card that we
see frequently in these chaos decks.
It's something that Allen didn't
actually run in Sydney at all. It was on
his sideboard. And now we have three of
them in the main board and could
potentially be really good against Sam.
Here
>> we also see the hard bargain here. Now,
not many spells into the deck for Sam,
but could become uh particularly useful
in the case of Thrill the Hunt.
Allen considering their play here. Raven
uh Raven Bloom student into the
conservatory is likely what you're going
to consider. Take a look at the top of
the deck. Perhaps a spell will be
present.
>> Yes, looking to go into that Raven Bloom
Conservatory because he does want to get
the the defend trigger because drawing
spells and getting more here is so
important. On top of that, we do get the
Vex apathetic setup set up. So, this
will slow down Sam Determine quite a
bit. Sam's going to have to develop a
board that's going to be able to take
this Vex Apathetic down, but that's a
hard thing to do, especially with the
Raven Bloom Conservatory, giving Allen
more cards potentially and also Raven
Bloom Student being able to be buffed up
in the future as well.
>> Vex on turn two is extremely difficult
for not just the Rengar of Sam D
Sherman, but of course for Fury as a
whole. It completely shuts down these
aggressive play patterns that Fury's
known for. It's going to make it very
difficult to get past that uh that
battlefield there.
>> Yeah, as Sam you almost have to
consider, do I have to punch first here?
And that might be an option. We are
going to see the buff from pit rookie.
>> I would not be of course we can go in
for four here and maybe take care of
this Vex. Allen is tapped out, so we are
going to see likely see a contest here
on this Vex. Punch first can be saved or
maybe played for a potential solid
trade.
>> Well, you have the buff. You also have
the pride stalker uh plus one might as
well. You do have the assault plus two.
>> So, there's actually quite a bit more
happening here. Defend trigger reveals a
>> and not what Allen wants to see here at
all. The Vex will be gone. Still holding
on to the battlefield here
>> and it's going to go through. That is
exactly what Sam Sherman had to do. You
have to remove that Vex. It costs you an
Inferna. Pit rookie is on the field of
play here. It did its job. It provided
the buff and now it's going to be able
to perhaps score a point.
>> Yeah, Inferno swinging in there for a
full nine might
come.
>> Yep.
>> So, really good uh setting this up for
the future. Diana, the traveling
merchant is able to filter through the
hand a lot more. Of course, uh Sam
Sherman getting on the board nice and
early. Not really what Allan wants to
see here.
Sam's in a position here where he's
going to be able to start to develop a
board. That Vex Apathetic being out of
play is absolutely huge.
It was a two of in the main board
though, so perhaps Allen will be able to
bring it back out, but it will have to
sit in a battlefield of course to have
its effect, which does make it
vulnerable to some counterplay. Two
points scored by Sami Sherman.
>> You might have wondered why Allen did
decide to play that Vex so early. And a
big question is there aren't a lot of
things that buff up. Uh the punch first
is one of the few options here that
actually gave Sam Sherman enough might.
And that's one of the gamles that Allen
said, you know, this is worth taking. I
can still win even if the punch first
does happen. So, we'll have to see what
he does to get back into this game.
>> There's the irresistible faith folk. We
talked at length about the effectiveness
of this card throughout the tournament.
Sam Sherman is going to bring out
another pit rookie, provide a buff to
the irresistible faith folk
or perhaps to the sand soldier.
>> I like that even better here trying to
hold this a little bit more. Uh buff
trigger
cast here.
>> Oh no, that was already plus four.
>> No, no, to the buff trigger.
>> Oh, with the Okay, that's fine.
>> Okay, a little bit of confusion there
with the timing.
>> Your turn.
>> Yeah. So, what happened here was the
pride stalker was giving buffs to the
sand soldier, and what Alan was trying
to do was respond to the buff trigger
there, which would allow the gust to
happen. But because the pride stalker
was putting on that additional might
throughout it, it was still there at the
time because the turn had not ended.
>> Allen considering their play here.
>> You got it.
>> We're going to go to the Raven Bloom
Conservatory.
Technically, a non-combat showdown does
begin.
And that's a stack deck added to Hint.
>> Good piece for Allen here. Overall, will
be able to find more utility as this
game goes on. Sam has had a very
aggressive line, but it hasn't been
anything that isn't unstoppable.
>> Traveling merchant comes into contest.
>> Discards the hard bargain
>> and Gust will be applied to the sand
soldier.
>> Because it's a token, it completely
dissipates. Does not go to him.
>> Two and then three. Yeah, Alan will get
the
And that high tempo play mattering a lot
here once again
soldiers
>> there going to pay one produce a sand
soldier
>> and bring that traveling merchant back
into hand
and back to the field of play.
>> So this tells me that Allen probably is
wanting to dig through his deck a bit
more. Obviously not finding the pieces
that he quite wants. We did see that
wave get flipped earlier and not being
able to be played. Um, we will have to
see what else Allen can do here as this
is pretty low tempo overall is
representing a Moonfall potentially as
that could be a big blowout card in some
of these matches. But of course, uh, Sam
is definitely aware of that potential as
well.
>> We're seeing a sabotage be played here.
>> Waiting for the resolution. Allen does
reveal the hand. We have a stack deck.
We have well two stack decks actually.
We have a gust, a ride the wind and
>> a smoke screen.
>> Smoke screen.
>> So that smokec screen is a one of in the
list and could have been a little bit of
a surprise factor card uh that's now no
longer available. I like how Allen
hasn't been using these stack decks yet.
And because of this, we have less
information from this sabotage that Sam
would have gained so much knowledge if
both these stack decks would have been
played by Allen. Allen was going for a
bit of a bluff here with these four
runes up and that has now been countered
essentially. So, I really like the
sabotage from Sam because we get so much
information from it.
>> At the same time, the stack decks are
fair targets here. Perhaps not the ideal
if you're trying to be aggressive. Are
you gonna target the gust, the ride the
wind? Like what are your thoughts on
this?
>> It's tough to say. Ride the wind is such
a key piece of the deck overall because
of the movement ability and on top of
that. Uh the gust is pretty high tempo.
So I would look at potentially doing
that stack deck can find lots of pieces.
Although I guess a smoke screen has to
be thought about as well. This is really
a tough decision for Sam. I understand
why he is taking the time that he is.
Uh, you have to really think about
what's in your hand and what your game
plan is and what Allen wants to do to
try to stop that game plan. And
smokeokescreen is probably a potential
on top of the Gus. But like I said, ride
the wind is more proactive for Allen's
game plan. So you have to decide, are
you worried about Allen disrupting your
game plan or are you worried about Allen
doing his own game plan instead?
>> Sam taking his time to think this
through here. Has developed a decent
board.
It is such a tough decision here. Really
have to find the line here potentially.
>> And each decision it has a cascading
effect. You're in the finals of the Vanc
uh Vancouver regional tournament.
You want to make every correct choice
possible. So taking the time to ensure
that you're considering all the options
is absolutely necessary.
Yeah, looks like we do see a niti in
hand for Sami Sherman here. So, that's
one of the pieces that we have to
consider
>> and a throw of hunt.
>> Yes,
thrill of the hunt being a large piece
here. Um, it's something that
>> All right, ride the wind. Okay, I think
this is a great choice because it does
give Allen a lot of value potentially.
Uh we know that he doesn't love his hand
at the time, but it could become a love
the hand if these stack decks hit what
he's looking for. So it stops something
like if he hits stack deck and plays
away from it.
>> Start a showdown then bring Diana over
here.
>> Okay, the irresistible fate folk is
going to bring Diana. It sounds like
what the call was made there. Inferna is
going to get uh the assault plus two.
Diana comes in. Showdown begins. Uh
>> five to five.
pass.
>> Focus has been passed.
>> It'll be a trade
>> and Allen opts not to play anything
there.
>> Now the pit rookie would be a great
option here for the Emperor's Das.
Trying to get a look into that hand
there. Is that another gust potentially?
It's hard to see.
Pretty
quick decision there.
>> They're good, man.
>> Just out of habit, Allan going ahead and
shuffling those last cards. Even though
typically it is August. Yes.
>> Trying to stop that point from being a
conqueror there.
>> And Grim Apothecary does come down on
the chain.
Gust goes back.
>> Brings it back.
>> Um, okay. Conquer.
>> Gust is no longer having a valid target.
Stack deck is played.
>> Allan being very careful not to show us
what cards he is looking at.
>> Yeah, those are the most close to 90
degree cards I have seen yet.
>> Another fairly quick choice here from
Allen.
And it's, would you believe it,
>> a third stacked deck
>> or Sammy even smiling a little bit
there.
>> It's such a quick choice from Allen
here, too. Very proficient on this deck.
Has played it a lot. Unsure how much
he's played against Rengar, though.
>> I will play the pit.
>> I don't think too many people have too
much experience playing Rengar, but we
do have a buff being applied to the sand
soldier. The emperor's deis doing a
fantastic job. The pit rookie a great
option back hand. I mean, in this case,
it was the Grim Apothecary uh to to
bring it back to save it from the Gust,
but regardless, an excellent play
overall by Sami Sherman.
>> So, we do have the Star Cross in hand.
It looked like we might have had a
stupify in there as well. The question
is, what units do we have available? Are
we going to look at using this merchant
to go ahead and discard and draw new
cards if we don't like our hand overall?
>> Still have that smoke screen in there.
Allen has focus.
He's going to discard the Raven Bloom
student draw a card
>> and gets ride the wind there, which is
something that Sandy Sherman discarded
earlier. So that's a really nice hit for
Allen CQ here.
>> The affforementioned smokec screen
utilized. It's going to be enough for
the traveling merchant to take the
emperor's deis.
Hey,
>> Allan's going to bounce it back,
generate the sand soldier token, and
perhaps consider replaying the traveling
merchant, continue searching through the
deck. Might be looking for a Hay. Now,
we did see Hay to get recycled earlier
on. So, it's probably searching for that
next one. Traveling Merchant does come
down once again. It's been really
interesting because a lot of people
wouldn't be able to find value in this
Emperor's Das because that's likely why
Sam leads off with it as a neutral
battlefield. It works really well for
him, but not usually for his opponents.
But Alan said, "You know what? This is
actually kind of good for me, too. I can
play a traveling merchant over and over
again. I can go through my deck and find
the cards that I need." It's been a good
resource for him as well. And I like how
he's taken advantage of it. It's also a
consistent two might body that has to be
contended with at the very least because
we have seen throughout the course of
this tournament some Diana's run out of
steam and so it does maintain a little
bit of a presence on the board while
maintaining a bit of a hand. Yeah, it's
a card that a lot of Diana have kind of
moved away from. It looks like we will
have a fry the wind merchant will be
able to filter through our deck just a
little bit more and potentially we'll
have another combat trick here to
contest this pit rookie.
>> Just getting clarification here if it is
in fact the traveling merchant that was
selected. Sam is considering a response.
We'll have to see here. Yeah, something
interesting he could consider is a
Thrill of the Hunt or a Niti. Uh there
are some options here, but he likely
waits here until the ride the wind has
resolved.
>> Trigger.
>> Yeah, it is the traveling merchant.
You'll get the discard draw trigger
and it is ready still. It is a move
effect to start.
>> Uh, defender trigger.
>> Yeah.
>> Nice.
>> Acceptable losses.
>> Your action.
>> Yeah. Um,
>> and acceptable losses is one of those
cards that we talked about not being
useful in this matchup. It is just a
dead card.
>> Buff.
>> We'll have to see if there's a response
plan. It's stupify. So Allan's going to
uh reduce the might of the pit rookie
and get another card.
>> Sam D. Sherman considering a response as
focus is passed.
>> Yes. And because this Rengar was played
at reaction speed, we actually did get
that pride soccer buff onto the pit
rookie. So it is a two to2 here on the
might.
Both players carefully considering their
next moves.
So much is on the line here.
>> Yep. It is currently Sam's action. There
are cards in the deck that could be
played here. I know he does have access
to the Niti potentially is something
that he has to be considering here.
How many cards?
>> Niti does curve out perfectly with the
three runes available.
>> Winning a combat with Niti, provided it
survives, does provide additional card
draw, which is of course valuable to
aggressive decks.
>> It's the growth carry instead.
>> Another ambush unit. If I target with
the return, I have to return it when it
resolves, right? I can't like choose not
to use it.
>> Yes.
>> Getting some rules clarification here.
>> Um, all right. So, what I want to do, I
think
going to have to apply that pridealker
buff is
I'll buff the apothecary and return the
pit rookie.
So, pit rookie being targeted with the
bounce back from the grim apothecary.
Grim apothecary goes to four might.
>> Conquer to five.
>> Other showdown.
>> Now we have our secondary showdown and
it is going to be the Rengar
>> securing. So, it's six to four
>> battlefield.
>> All right, you're done.
>> Great play from Sam D Sherman here. Now,
we have to see what Allen can do. We
know that the ride the wind was spent,
so we'll have to see if we have ways to
contest this battlefield. And it looks
like no, we will be scooping and going
on to the next game.
>> Wow. Okay, here we go. Game one taken by
Sam D. Sherman with absolutely
remarkable plays. You saw the Rengar and
the reaction there.
>> Well done. very well done overall to
make sure that you contested both
Battlefield secured a vital two points
on that turn, taking you to six,
threatening the win on that next turn.
And Allan said, "You know what? Let's
just go next. Let me get some of the
stuff out of my main deck and get
prepared for game number two. Sam
Sherman moves to one game away from
repeating a championship."
>> One of the first things that you saw
there was Allan ZQ put a turn to dust
down and then on top of that a star
cross. likely going to think be things
that he is taking and putting into the
sideboard instead of you know taking out
of his main deck putting to the
sideboard instead. He had multiple dead
cards in this matchup. So is likely
after sidebar we're going to see a
little bit more from him will be going
first in this next turn game as well.
Most likely he does get the choice since
he lost the previous game.
>> There is so much on the line in this
game. both players formal former
regional championship
>> um players and as a result whoever wins
this match will be Riftbound's first
ever
>> repeat champion for the regionals. So
there's just so much on the line here.
SamD Sherman and Allen EQ carefully
considering each other's decks and
determining what they wish to sideboard
in for this second game.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of options here
overall.
of course getting those star crossed out
potentially.
>> We saw those acceptable losses there
being taken out there. We got a new
camera angle here.
>> Oh, let's go.
>> Where has this been all day?
>> So, Singularity is one of the cards.
There's actually two of them on the
sideboard. Starcross looking at
potentially taking out. Looks like we're
going to keep them in. Uh can't do
really well against the Rengar Trophy
Hunter. So, Starcross is decent against
that. Anything that has the high amount
of cost is nice. And is that the did I
just see the Baron? The ultimate Baron
there as well.
>> That might have been the ultimate Baron
Nasher.
>> And it is at a two. Let's go.
>> So the acceptable losses are back in the
sideboard here for instance. Just like I
said, a dead draw that we had to get out
of the deck for sure.
Now, in this given circumstance here,
both players do have access to each
other's deck list, including sideboard.
So, they're able to make more informed
decisions with regards to what cards
they wish to select. This really does
help in this second game to ensure that
they're best prepared to deal with the
matchup. As in game one, they do have to
come in with their main deck as they've
used throughout the course of this
tournament.
As always, it's going to be very
interesting to see what decisions
they've made throughout the course of
the sideboarding. We won't see until we
have the actual game in progress here.
Sam still considering what to sideboard
in and out.
>> Yeah, Sam actually has a lot of things
in his sideboard that are anti- Aurora
in general. And Allen isn't running any
gear, so it's actually kind of in a
different spot than Allen. Instead of
saying like, oh, I have gear in the
main, he has it in the sideboard, but
Allen's deck doesn't really take
advantage of that. For example, we have
Oxon in the sideboard. There's a three
up of that. There is also sabotage which
can hit multiple things and it can be a
consideration of adding another one of
those especially if you want to hit
spells such as moonfall. There is
unyielding spirit which if he sees that
Allen has access to singularity is a
possibility. Unyielding spirit could be
an absolute blowout card in the right
situation
>> if I think that one of the things you
could absolutely consider. Now you do
have two of of challenge in the main
deck for Sam D Sherman. There is a third
in the sideboard.
Challenge is a very effective way of
dealing with Vex apathetic. Um it's it's
one of the key ways that you can kind of
remove it from the field without having
to try to like contest the battlefield
altogether. So that might be something
worth considering if Sam is trying to
really consider limiting the impact of
Vex Apathetic specifically.
>> And another consideration from Sam D.
Sherman is Brineer Thunders Song. a card
that lets the player not be able to play
any more cards after that reaction
window. We've seen Allen hold up four or
more runes very consistently. And with
the potential of a Briner coming down,
Allen maybe not having the same choices
anymore if he does leave up a lot of
runes. So, that's another consideration
that needs to be made by Sam Sherman
here.
>> One thing absolutely worth considering
here as well, and all throughout this
tournament, we have seen Fury be very uh
successful. This game did not feature
Kai'Sa survivor. Kai'Sa seemed to have
been a core component of the value
generation for Fury. And in this game,
if Sam D. Sherman is able to start
establishing the Kai'Sa survivor and
getting that value, it might turn the
tide into his favor.
>> And it looks like we do have the
battlefields in for game number two.
Allen opting for the Targon's Peak. a
great battlefield for when you're going
first as you often conquer first and
you're able to ready two ruins after
that. So, a lot of reaction ability
here. Starring we've seen used to great
effectiveness here being able to
reposition your board and essentially
allow one of your units to be at your
base ready to then conquer perhaps on
that next turn.
>> Yes, essentially giving it a ganking
ability in a lot of ways. Just to think
about it, Sam has so many lowc cost
units, so is always able to activate
that star spring very efficiently while
also buffing up with Pride Stalker as
well. Just a really smart choice from
him overall.
>> Yeah, very effective way to get a
readyied unit back into the base that
you can then use to challenge the other
battlefield. It looks like the
sideboarding has been done. We have game
two getting ready here. We are in the
finals here. There is a chance that we
will be crowning our Vancouver regional
champion here if Sam D. Sherman is able
to win this second game, but Allen's EQ
certainly has other plans.
>> One stage.
>> Yeah, Sam has two irresistible fay folks
there. Looking at getting rid of one
potentially. It looks like a Niti and a
Kai'Sa are going to be staying in the
hand.
>> Very quick mulligan there.
It looks like we're getting ready to
begin.
Allen ZQ does elect to go first and it's
going to be a traveling merchant.
>> And we do have that two drop
irresistible fay folk for Sam D Sherman
here as well. Very quick turn ones from
each of these players.
>> Both very well practiced with their
decks.
>> We're going to get the movement discard
trigger.
>> It's a ride the wind discarded.
>> Point is scored.
And do we have it looks like a gust in
hand from Allen ZQ here.
>> And it's Vex apathetic in the beast.
>> Yeah,
>> interesting. Not wanting to take a risk
here against a punch first, which we saw
was a blowout card in that previous
game.
>> It looks like Allen's recognizing that
Vex Apathetic is going to be a core
component to his potential victory here.
wants to perhaps plan a strategy to
ensure that it can survive and even
protect it.
It is notable it has to be out of
battlefield to get the effect.
We have now added that sabotage to hand
for Sam Sherman as well.
Little bit awkward here. Has to decide,
you know, of course the specs being in
the backline is something you have to be
thinking about. uh makes Niti a little
bit awkward at times.
>> You could Okay, I was just going to say
you could sabotage. Take a look at what
is in the hand. Try to determine what
your next course of action is. Okay,
>> so we have Singularity, Gust, Raven
Bloom, Student, and Stupify.
>> Now Gust of course being an excellent
tempo card. Stupify it. Fantastic for
that additional draw. And of course,
early trades with the the might debuff.
A lot of good uh options here. And we
have seen Raven Bloom Student
successfully carry Diana to victory
despite only being a two cost. It just
it has that scaling might that you look
for in a deck that loves to cast spells.
So Sam has to be eyeing most likely the
Gust here because of how high tempo it
is or potentially the singularity as it
can clear two units and just not having
to think about it is really nice but
also knows that at least one was
sideboarded in and usually if one is
sideboarded in typically two are so Sam
knows about one of them and has the
other one on his radar now as well. One
of the fortunate things about Rengar as
well is the Rengar trophy hunter from
the champion zone. When it comes in, can
apply the pride stalker buff to itself,
send itself to seven might, which would
protect it from a singularity,
but still it is absolutely a spell worth
considering taking out, especially since
it can target the battlefield, it can
target the base. Very versatile from
that standpoint.
>> And it looks like we also have Pike in
our hand as well. So, another unit that
could potentially be targeted by a
singularity. Uh, not as worried about
the Gust here. We do have Kai'Sa and
Pike are two units that are a bit more
resistant to Gust. And then on top of
that, because we can buff our units
through Pride Stalker, Gust is a little
bit less of a concern. So, I feel like
we might see the Singularity as the
choice here.
>> It's also worth noting that Allen ZQ did
choose to discard the ride the win on
the move trigger with the traveling
merchant
>> and does not have a way Battlefield
>> and targets Vex to bring it in. And then
he gave in response.
>> Ability will still move, right? Yeah.
>> I'm certain.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Me, too.
>> Sam is considering using the
irresistible faithful to perhaps
challenge the Vex to combat.
>> Uh, that's what I'm hearing here as
well.
>> You don't have to.
>> Well, I'm going to hit the stupify.
>> You can leave Vex alone if you want.
Allan suggests
>> singularity.
>> So, it's um
>> stupify
the one. I I think he's looking at a
pretty thin hand and says, "You know
what? I don't want you to find new
cards.
>> Let's go with Pike here.
>> Plus two." And then Pride Stalker.
>> Pride Stalker buff.
>> So, send Pike up to five.
>> Now, all of a sudden, it's looking kind
of scary here. Pike goes in.
Focus on Sami Sherman.
>> Focus has been passed and the traveling
merchant is in the trash.
>> All right. And I'm going to
>> Great play here from Sam Sherman.
>> Now here we coming on in.
>> Focus on Sam Sherman.
>> Orange
faith folk.
>> Yeah,
>> faith folks dead as is the Vex.
apathetic and then all on top
>> down to two runes but holding a battle.
>> That's right.
>> So that fact is something that Allen
definitely really wanted to keep alive
here of they wasn't at a battlefield. So
Pike was able to be readied with the red
power being paid for here and Sam
breathing a bit of a sigh of relief here
being able to get rid of that Vex. It
was very costly to do so not only in
playing the sabotage but also in runes.
So, if Allen is maybe able to
reestablish here and then continue to
put pressure on the board, we'll have to
see if removing this vex. We know that
typically it's worth it, but it was very
costly to do so in very low tempo.
>> We also have the option here. Pike can
gank to the other battlefield here.
Score an additional point. Go to uh
three here. We did hold for a point for
Sam. Allan choosing a bit of a
development turn here with the Raven
Bloom student into Diana.
Sam only down to four runes. So has paid
a little bit of a price with the Damp.
Yeah, I'm a bit surprised to not see him
look at this gank over right away.
However, because you can also do things
with the Starring, however, might want
to try to save the spike instead. uh
knowing that Allen is developed here. So
I I can see why we aren't taking that
aggressive point here. Instead, saving
Pike.
>> Sam taking the long game here, choosing
not to go over. Protects the Pike,
bringing it back into the battle uh into
the base there. Diana is going to go
into Targon's Peak. Starcross pulled
into hand. Conquer.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> Yep. A quick conquer there for Allen ZQ.
And there's the Hi.
>> He found it. A very important piece of
this deck overall. As we've talked about
several times, Hayi is the engine of
this deck overall. And it allows you to
just have so much utility being able to
discard spells to draw gear to ready
runes, which we don't have gear. And
then also the unit as well, being able
to get plus three might. So much utility
here. And if we is able to stick, we
might just find the value we're looking
for in this game to offset Sami
Sherman's tempo.
>> This has turned into a very different
game. And again, I'm just going to note
here, we did have an early discard of
Ride the Wind, which tends to be comboed
alongside Weey. But regardless, Allen's
hand's going to be primarily spells and
can uh Weey can be used to start
generating value from that standpoint.
You discard a spell, you get to draw
three. And we'll see an unacelerated
Kai'Sa here giving the pride soccer buff
to Inferna. So she is at four might
right now against Diana's three. And we
see the Diana trigger go off. And
unfortunately it's just no spell. We
will have a Vex cheerless as the top
deck.
>> Might four to three
>> favoring Sandy Sherman
>> and Diana will go to the trash.
Allen still with several runes up and
available here.
>> Going to four points here will allow Sam
to consider going to six points on the
next turn. Then threatening to win the
championship.
>> Two rooms remain up.
Vex apathetic not on the board.
Therefore allowing Sam Sherman to
perhaps have some reaction capabilities
in defense of these battlefields. If
there were be a time for Allen to
stabilize, it would be right now. Uh the
way is a big piece here. But of course,
we know Sam Sherman does have punch
first. So, we'll have to see what Allen
draws and decides to discard here and
see Sam Sherman's reaction to it. The
Vex tier list is the discard that we
saw. So, we have plus three might on
this way.
>> He's got Sam Sherman determining that
I'm not going to be able to deal with
that. You can have the point.
And the Raven Bloom student comes in to
challenge Inferna.
>> Yep.
>> Sam cutting his losses.
>> Yeah,
>> being able to clear this very
effectively makes a huge difference in
this matchup. Allen now has all of his
runes to work with. Can develop in the
backboard or also save some. Oh, another
way.
>> That's a second way.
Allan is coming online here.
>> Is considering maybe playing this way on
a battlefield instead.
>> And you're triggering that movement
there.
>> Yep. Star spring trigger.
Sam making sure to take
some thoughts here. Yep.
>> Play resolves.
Sarcross is discarded, allowing for the
draw.
>> This has suddenly turned into a very
different game two.
Two ways on the board.
>> Yeah. Uh that's a really scary thing to
have to deal with as Sam Sherman because
these waves can be pumped with so much
might. The pride stalker of Rengar
doesn't feel nearly as strong because we
can almost always achieve might in one
way or the other. We see the Fizz come
down as well and we are recycling two
runes here. So we will see a star cross
come out.
>> Yes, F and Kaisa.
>> Looking at likely Kai'Sa
>> going back to base and we'll see what
the selection is here and it's going to
be a thrill to hunt. This is going to
banish the card which removes it from
being targeted. Let's just see how this
plays out here.
>> Yes. And where does he want this Kaiso
to go as well?
>> Throw the hunt in some ways kind of
breaks the targeting as the card does
get banished
>> and then returns it into the field of
play.
>> That's a two, right?
>> Yeah. I'm going to throw the
>> And it's important to note that it says
at any battlefield. It does not say at
base. So, it looks like we'll be looking
to go onto that Targon's Peak here.
>> Allan now only has one rune up to deal
with what potentially might be a Kai'Sa
going onto this Raven Bloom student
can resolve
>> and potentially scoring a point here as
well.
>> It resolves.
Did you do it in the response to the
this being on the chain or when I was
beginning from the graveyard?
>> In response to the star cross.
>> Okay.
>> So that chain will have to resolve here.
Uh when student is uh right now plus one
>> careful consideration from both players
here taking the diligent notes
>> and it's important note here that this
Diana legend is still up so flash can be
played here and we are targeting both
units saving this Raven Bloom student
also getting another draw discard with
our away as Well,
>> Alan CQ wants to keep a board presence,
not willing to sacrifice any of the
cards.
>> Yes. And although Thrill did not score
right away, it will score on the hold
most likely here.
>> Gust has been discarded.
>> Uh result. Okay, conquer with Kai'Sa.
I'm at five. Draw a card.
>> Does right away.
had to wait for all of the chain to
resolve for the conquer to happen.
>> It's still a turn two turn game here
regardless of the conquer point,
>> but every point matters when you're
chasing a championship.
>> Uh yeah.
>> Okay. I hold six.
>> Yeah.
And that's the power thrill of the hunt
there is not only can you conquer on
your opponent's turn, then you also get
the hold right away.
>> You hold to six, can potentially go to
seven.
We have a couple options. Of course,
there's Niti punch first. We have Kinko
initiate as well. And of course, Rengar
is still in the champion zone, although
not wanting to be used here. Really does
want to try to push some points.
The Kaiso will likely be retreated.
This is still a tough spot for Sam
despite really great play. The double
way is just so hard to deal with. It's
going to be doing a lot on these
battlefields in the near future. The
punch first might be a key component of
how we're able to get over
>> the wizard.
Taking a look at the trash pile here.
>> Very important when your opponent is
playing Fizz.
Not only Fizz, it's just also being able
to keep track of everything that has
been being played because as an
aggressive deck, you really can't have
many if any slip ups because you just
run out of resources pretty quickly. Of
course, the Kinko Initiate helps with
that because you can draw. But you have
to be so careful with these aggressive
lists because one misstep can just make
the difference between scoring only
seven points versus actually getting
that eighth point and final point. You
do have the buff being applied to Kai'Sa
raising it to five might.
Initiate comes down. That will trigger a
draw.
>> A lot of might coming down here for Sam
Sherman. A lot of options as well with
that draw. And because we had
we'll have to see
what Allen can do here.
>> Got two rooms left up. Sami Sherman
preparing a board to perhaps attempt a
double conquer on the next turn.
Rengar trophy hunter is still available
from the champion zone.
>> Yeah, that's a key component here for
sure. Allan has a lot that he has to
navigate here
>> and the ways are the R5 might but
it's going to be tricky here because if
you want to Yeah, I don't know. I don't
know what you do here for your Allen.
>> Moonfall and then Fizz would be really
nice if we had that option
and just being able to play Moonfall,
but I don't know if we have Moonfall in
hand or not.
This is one of those turns that uh
Allen's going to take his time on. It's
going to be a singularity. He's going to
target the Initiate and Kai'Sa.
>> Is there a response from Sam? There is
no response. No one unyielding Spirit. A
sigh of relief there for sure.
>> That is a big play there.
>> A significant D ramp, but you survive
another day.
>> Not only survive, but I I would even
argue thrive here because that's so much
might removed from the board. And we
have these waves that are going to be
coming in getting a lot of value and
potentially finding Allen exactly what
he needs to do to try to stabilize in
this game. Notable that the singularity
did uh did come in from the sideboard
for Allen ZQ
wasn't available in game one.
Still want to note that we do have
access to Rengar here which is a big
piece. However, if Allen does have
there's a couple cards you can find to
uh negate it. you know, whether it be
Stupify
would be a nice one for sure. There's
just so many card options here that
Allen has to make really tough decisions
on what he draws and discards. And he
goes ahead and discards a Fizz, which
I'm a bit surprised to see.
>> Fizz does give Quake plus three.
>> That is only going to be for this turn.
A tough choice here of what to do with
this Raven Bloom student. Whether it be
try to conquer on the other side or do
we have to reinforce instead because we
do have to think about the Rengar trophy
hunter. And of course, one of these ways
we'll probably die at some point, but we
will go ahead and go for that star
spring here. Getting that other conquer
point to six. And we are reinforcing
with this way. But of course, we get the
move trigger first, which we get to draw
and then decide what we want to discard
here.
We're in a very critical junction here
in game two of the Vancouver regional
finals.
>> Every single move
absolutely critical
>> and we will be able to ready two runes
at the end of this turn
>> and pass on top.
>> Two runes ready with Targon's Peak.
Sam D. Sherman takes over the turn.
>> So, we do have access to it looks like a
sabotage there. Can gain hand
information this way.
>> Uh we've seen Sam D. Sherman use that
very well in the past to make decisions
before his plays, but of course has to
make sure that we have the amount of
energy necessary to make the plays that
we want to do.
>> You're going to want to reserve some
energy for that Rengar.
However, the information provided by
Sabotage is simply too great
to find Dance in hand.
So, the Moonfall is there. That is the
card that we were really wanting to look
out for. We do have another Fizz for the
future and part of the reason we saw
that was the discard of the Fizz is
because we already have one. And of
course, stack deck and stupify offering
a lot of options here. The moonfall
though, especially starcross.
Starcross against the rangar. This makes
it a really tough choice because the
moonfall is not what you wanted to see.
And the star cross is not what you
wanted to see. It's two things that kind
of just keep you out of the game a
little bit.
>> Just laughing to myself. Been such a
long day. I'm pretty sure I said define
dance instead of moonfall.
As much as there were a lot of Aurelia,
we have seen now Diana and Rengar are
the are the champions that we have here
instead.
>> Sam D. Sherman carefully considering and
we've seen him do this very uh
consistent here. Very very careful, very
uh cerebral with the decisions around
what to discard with the sabotage.
>> Yeah, the information here gained is
just massive overall as well.
H this is How do you find a line to get
through both of these? If you could just
get through one battlefield on a conquer
and win, okay, that's easy to do. But
getting through all this might on the
Targon's Peak is just exceptionally
hard.
>> Those Quays have been an absolute
godsend for Allen's EQ. This game was
running away from him and they brought
him back into it.
>> And I absolutely love Allen's poker face
that he has here. I wonder if it's
because he's tired or if he is just
having a poker face.
>> He's staring into Sam's soul.
But let's see what Sam does here.
He's got the runes.
>> He's got a decision first.
>> It's true. That's right. He still has
not chosen the uh discard here. And it
is a very important decision.
>> See trash can.
A big thing is he does have the punch
first in hand. So the star cross could
potentially be a little bit more
unfavorable for him because of the
Rengar and Punch first being an option
where the Moonfall, yes, it gives minus
two might, but maybe that's what I mean
that has to probably be likely the two
decisions. I'd be surprised if we saw
something else discarded, but of course
uh these players are much better than I
am. So I want to see this decision that
is well thought out as much as Sam
Sherman is doing right now. And on top
of that, because sabotage is a
however, we can't only hit the uh the
spells here. So, Fizz is not an option.
>> I don't even know what I would have
decided.
>> I mean, most players would say like, oh,
Moonfall, it's a signature spell, but
Starcross just offers so much
versatility and utility here. Overall,
the downside of it, of course, is Oh,
actually starcross as well because of
Fizz just having that recursion is so
good as well.
>> Take Starross.
>> And you called it. Starcross being
removed.
>> Let me write that down.
>> Sam Sherman carefully considering his
options here and determining that
Starcross had to go.
>> This is the last turn.
And Allan goes, "It's the last turn, so
I'm just going to leave my hand open."
You know what it is. We're both tired.
We want to play the best game possible.
>> And maybe it could be a little bit of a
mind game, too. Just adding a little
extra pressure of like,
>> hey, if you got it, you got it. If you
don't, you don't.
>> Is this the biggest taunt in TCG history
here? An open hand in the championship.
>> Last turn is what he says.
Stack deck being played on the chains.
Searching for options here. He does only
have four runes up.
>> I like how quick Allen makes these
decisions on these stack decks. Very
well practiced.
So much is at stake here.
It's the Rengar on the Raven Bloom
studio.
>> It looks like Rengar is going to be
successful.
We go to seven. Can Sam Sherman find a
way to upend Targon's Peak and secure
the Riftbound Vancouver Regional
Championship?
And the issue is that this Fizz is just
going to offer so much utility for this
next turn. On top of that, the Moonfall
being available as well. Uh so even with
the development here, it's going to be
really tough. Punch first will probably
need to be represented. So Allen will
have to play around that.
>> Four runes up for Allen. Three for Sandy
Sherman.
>> And that was another thrill of the hunt
in hand as well.
Notable here that Allen's deciding not
you know what that card I got from seven
>> from stack deck. You don't get to see
that one. That's a surprise.
>> That would be a true taunt if you just
flip that over. Be like actually I have
this too.
>> That one you have to try to figure out
what it is. The other ones though you
can know.
>> Never mind.
This is unbelievable.
Never a dull moment in Riftbound
regional championships.
>> So, I want to say that we actually put
in the trash very early on the ride the
wind. And part of the reason why that
was such a quick decision for Allen here
is because Fizz is able to get it back
so easily. So, likely here what we're
going to see when they it comes back, we
heard Allen say, "Hey, this is the last
turn. I'll just play open-handed because
you saw the sabotage already." But we're
likely going to see a ride the win.
Going for the win here.
>> Very good eye there. Sam carefully
considering what to do here.
>> We do have that punch first. Looks like
maybe as well.
>> Time, but an auction.
>> I can only see a little sliver of it.
>> I mean, Sam Sherman knows about this
ride the wind as well. He knows the fizz
is there. There's just a lot of options
here overall for Allen. So, is there a
way for Sam to get around this?
>> Also notable, Stupify does provide a
draw. Allen would have three additional
runes to perhaps respond with whatever
Stupify may bring. Sandy Sherman's
making a move.
>> Wait, actually, sorry. Hold on. Uh
little bit of a
>> sorry takes you back there.
>> I am
losing my mind.
>> These players are under a tremendous
amount of pressure. They've been playing
Riftbound for three days straight and it
culminates in this moment.
>> Yeah, I I'll I'll do that. Okay, looks
like we are going back here and we will
see that
>> here. Rangard comes over. Hard bargain.
>> That was the face down card.
>> What a great choice from Allen here.
>> Unbelievable.
Hard bargain.
That might be that might actually hold
off this press from Sami Sherman.
>> It's going to do exactly that. And as I
said earlier, we have access to ride the
wind through this Fizz to be able to
contest this Rengar. Um, the only
question though is we don't have any
unit to discard here.
>> I can't believe it.
>> Open hand. Allen's EQ uses stack decks.
No, no, no. You don't get to see this
one. And it is exactly what he needs
>> to stall the attack from Sandy Sandy
Sherman. Absolutely unbelievable.
>> And it looks like that was a third way
that we potentially got. Oh, we can also
just use flash as well from Fizz. That
also works. That's even more efficient
here because both these waves are ready.
And it looks like we will be getting
that conquer and going to our game
three.
>> This is unbelievable.
Game three in the finals in Vancouver.
I am still in shock at how that game two
ended.
>> What a great game from Allen there. The
stack deck knowing exactly what he was
looking for. a counter spell there and
saying you know the way that I lose is
potentially something really funny
happening with thrill the hunt even
though it would be the second one played
we saw the value that that generated for
us earlier it's one of the very few
spells so Allen specifically had to have
taken that with the idea that I'm going
to counter thrill the hunt that's one of
the ways that I lose this game a well
calculated precise play from Allen's EQ
>> I am just completely floored that in the
championship we saw open hand. Allan
calling. This is the last turn.
Stack decks. A hard bargain. Keeps that
one face down.
Secures the win. Oh my. It's just you
can you couldn't write a better script
that it's just it's truly remarkable.
>> So, we did see all the sentries get
moved to the front of the deck there.
They're at the bottom of the deck
currently. Maybe things that we're
looking at potentially sideboarding out.
There are Darius getting put back into
the deck. It looks like
>> determined Sentry we haven't seen yet.
It looks like they may be side uh
sideboarded here.
>> Ren thunders songs available. It looks
like they're remaining in the sideboard
as well.
>> So I don't think we saw the unyielding
spirit in the sideboard. I wonder if it
is been brought into the main board to
deal with the singularities potential.
There it is right there. Yes.
>> Yeah. Yep.
>> That could have been a potential blowout
card in that last game. I am loving this
camera angle.
>> A great view. Thank you so much to our
production team for this.
>> I have to tell you, the production team
has been absolutely incredible this
weekend. No one has worked harder and we
are seeing the fruits of that labor
right now as Sam Sherman considers their
sideboard.
>> Thinking about these Kinko initiates as
well because the reality is that you're
not really going to outv value through
the draw that often. Oh, more
>> are coming back.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, wait, wait.
>> Yes.
>> It is a tough decision here.
>> Are they all just back in
>> 43 card deck? Let's go.
>> Don't mind us. Just casting the side.
It's Niti going out.
>> Worried about Vex potentially.
>> Sam has very effectively dealt with Vex.
I think that's been a key component of
his success thus far. But Vex does have
the ability to completely shut down his
attack.
>> So something that we've seen the last
two games is actually Ni has been stuck
in hand almost the entire time. And I
think that's what he's realized is this
Niti started my hand and it ended in my
hand which is never something you really
want to see especially when you're
aggressive deck and you aren't able to
get that win. So, I like the idea that
Niti was just not worth it and that we
have better things to do. Keeping the
sentries in there from what we can tell
because they can be that part of that
aggressive game plan and adding that
might. We know Allen is running triple
gust. So, those sentries are a very
efficient way to add might to our board.
>> We're going to be having abandoned hall
game three from Allen CQ. And it is an
arena's greatest game to close out the
Vancouver Regional Championships.
>> Can I use
>> arguably these are two of these players
best battlefields for this game three?
>> Allan says I don't need headphones and I
don't need my phone. Bathroom break
time.
Can I get up?
All right, let's take a quick little
break here. So, first of all, I have to
say that game was so good. I don't blame
them for taking a break. We are going
into one of the most intense moments in
their careers. Both of which can be the
first ever two-time champion in
Riftbound history. So, there is so much
on the line.
>> Yeah. So, both these players have been
in this position before. They know that
sometimes it is good to take a break,
clear your head, make sure you're ready
for every single thing that can come by.
and maybe think it looks like their
sideboards had been decided already. So
the phones were left there so we can't
be looking anything up in between the
game. So that's a really great thing
just getting a nice clear head ready to
go for this final game.
>> What's crazy about it too is it's an
arena's greatest game. This could be
over in a blink of a an eye. So do not
leave. Stay tuned. But I've got great
news. We have a highlight reel of our
best ofves. That is one of the things
that makes Riftbound so unique. You come
to these regional championships and we
celebrate each and every legend. So
check out this clip for the best of us.
I'm Bryant and I'm joined here with Pog
Chungus, a coveted player as you have
now added a trophy to your trophy wall.
That's right. You've taken home the best
of Draven. Really proving to everybody
that you are the winner of the League of
Draven. How does it feel? Uh, honestly
it feels kind of surreal. Like I didn't
have any expectations to actually take
it home, but day one like I had I was
playing pretty well. I made like very
few misplays and I managed to dodge
Auroras. Aurora is not a good match up
for Draven, but I only played against
one Aurora in day one. So,
>> well, I think that's the story to kind
of touch here, right? Is that a lot of
people have thought that or that
Draven's just not very strong anymore.
And not only that, but a phenomenal day
one performance. cuz I know you're kind
of underelling it here because your day
one performance was so good that we got
to basically follow you along a lot for
day two as well. Really solidifying that
Draven still has a place to stay and you
know I I hear you're also
>> uh a Canadian as well and you know
representing uh yeah I'm from Toronto.
Um we all go to Black Girls Hobbies at
in Toronto. It's our local game store
and yeah we have a lot of strong players
here in Toronto like you know Chris Matt
Dewali right now he's in the top eight.
I'm rooting for him. And I really want
the Canadian boys to bring it home,
especially in Canada.
>> And you got and can you guys Canadians
in general have done such a good job
here at this uh this regional qualifier
just taking home so many best of as well
as the top cut representation. I've had
a pleasure to meet so many of them this
weekend and you're one of them as well.
I appreciate it. Congratulations. And
you know, I hope this is maybe just the
first of many. And to really kind of
prove that just because you think a
legend is down and out, you can still
sling some spinning axes. And
>> with that, Draven out.
I'm Bar Bryant and I'm joined here with
the magnificent Gail Winds and of course
people know who you are because you
already have a best of, but we're here
to talk about
>> I got to talk to you yesterday. Of
course, we got to showcase your Lilia
deck and now we're here to showcase your
brand new addition to your trophy wall,
>> the best of Lilia. How does it feel to
take home such a coveted prize?
>> It feels great. I put a lot of time into
perfecting this deck. I had to go
against the grain for what everyone
thought she was. Uh people think that
she's an unchecked power deck and I had
to go against the grain on that and
fight for my idea on it. I think it's
still correct and I think we've proven
it today.
>> No, you absolutely did. And not only
that, representing of course team secret
sauce.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Bringing home a a best of here. And not
only that, you guys have brought home
three of them.
>> Three total. Yeah. We got Poppy by No
Veggies. We got Ye by House is our big
who is still in top eight. He's going to
win the whole thing. I have no doubt.
And then of course me with Lilia. So
that's our three for this tournament.
Fantastic turnout for us. I couldn't be
more happy of my guys
>> and hopefully the first of many as well,
right? Gail wins. Now, I've got to ask
you one last question really just for a
quick little summarize. You guys are
obviously working together as a team and
so I want to ask you the kind of process
and the going into these tournaments. I
can only imagine how many hours y'all
put into practicing for this. And not
only do you have representation in top
cuts, but the representation of taking
on these best of. And let's be real,
Noveis was also this close.
>> He was He's He's always this close. He's
like our best bubbler. Uh he was like
what was he ninth in Vegas or something?
He was so close every time. So he'll get
his top eight one day soon. I believe
it. And maybe one day I'll get mine as
well.
>> Absolutely. With hard work comes the
fruits of those labors of course.
Gailwind. Congratulations to a
successful Vancouver regional qualifier
and we hope to see some more soon.
>> Yeah. See you guys.
>> The moment you've all been waiting for
is finally here. We get to crown the
champion of the Vancouver regional. But
first, we got to find out who wins in
this last game. Let's cut to the game.
Game number three of the finals. Here we
go. Allen ZQ, Sam D. Sherman. This is
going to be an arena's greatest game.
And as a result, it might be a quick
one, but it is going to be one of the
most impactful ones you will ever see.
>> As both our players here are waiting to
mulligan, getting some instructions from
our judges.
All right, good luck.
>> Good luck.
>> Uh, so I'm going first. We're both uh
Sherman determined to go first.
>> And already said the arena's greatest
trigger here as well is what it looks
like.
>> See a fizz in hand as well for Allen CQ.
Starcross,
>> Moonfall, Stupify.
>> I have a judge question. and I'd like to
ask away from the table.
>> Judge question from Sam.
>> Okay, looks like we're going to be
conferring with the judges as Allen
decides his mulligan here.
So Allen, this does actually give him
information as well. So what he's doing
is he is thinking about what kind of
question is my opponent asking the judge
before their mulligan. He has to be
thinking about this. That is the level
of player that Allen's EQ is. And so if
you have a very experienced player like
Sam Sherman asking a judge question
beforehand, then of course Allen has to
be thinking what kind of complex
interaction is he asking about? And it
looks like the judge might be looking up
something as well as listening as well.
So looks like we are getting some
clarification there.
>> That looks like an I'm going to go find
out for you.
>> I might have seen a throw the hunt in
his hand because that card is one of the
newer cards. Maybe that is the a
question that he has about it in that
interaction perhaps.
>> We're going to wait a moment here. Allan
being patient
trying to stay warm.
>> Yes. Um has So Allen doesn't have to
decide his mulligan yet either. The
player who goes first can decide their
mulligan first. So internally, Allen
might already know what he wants to
mulligan, but he wants to see how much
cards Sam decides to mulligan. So when
your opponent mulligans two, then you
know they're not very happy with their
hand, but they're they mulligan one or
zero, then you know that they're happier
with their hand. And against aggressive
list, whenever they don't mulligan mini
cards, you have to be a little bit
afraid. However, it looked like Allen
did have really solid resources in his
hand. We'll have to see if he finds a
two drop or not, but we do have the
stupify and moonfall as potential. And
we're playing on abandoned hall, so
those cards are getting even more value
here.
>> Sam is back here. And you are right.
When uh when your opponent decides to
keep their full four, it is a little
intimidating here. Do get a little peak
into the hand.
>> Irresistible faolk was one that we were
looking at potentially. Was that a
Darius in hand? Maybe.
>> Looks like one was mulligan ultimately
here. Sam D. Sherman elects to go first.
Two runes up.
>> Turn one is the irresistible faith folk.
>> We got hard bargain and Vex cheerless in
the hand for Allen as well as a star
cross.
Yep.
>> Not entirely sure if the arena's grace
point was declared there.
four runes on Sam D. Sherman and it goes
up. So it is 1-1.
>> So is going to look to have potentially
an aggressive line here, but the
irresistible faithful can usually get
more value than I mean to figure out if
he can buff it up to the point where he
can actually kill this Diana would be
ideal. However, Diana can still get the
trigger if if possible from the Diana
herself. But I'm getting a little bit
ahead of myself here. Oh, actually, we
will see the buff and we will also get
the price stalker as well. Yep,
>> that is a quickly powerful faith folk
here and the determined sentry which is
going to allow the additional pride
stalker buff onto the irresistible faith
folk.
>> No trigger on.
>> There's not many options here.
Mhm.
>> Stupify played card draw and it looks
like we are going to get a trade.
>> Yes. Isn't able to take advantage of the
bandit hall with the stupify but getting
the trade here. We use so many resources
from Sam Sherman here. And we could
potentially gas out if we don't find the
right parts of our deck here. We did
have the Darius which is a little bit,
you know. Oh, we have Kai'Sa in hand. I
just saw that as well. So, we're not as
concerned about gassing out here. But
using all these cards is still h wasn't
ideal. And we do have a thrill of the
hunt in hand as well. A few utility
pieces there.
>> Sam looking particularly good here.
Kais is going to be one of those key p
uh pieces you're going to want to get
out there ASAP.
>> Determined sentry going in is going to
score the point. We go to two
>> and the pit rookie to three.
Some quick points here with the Kai'Sa
not accelerated as well. Building a
strong board here. The Vex cheerless is
ready to go and we'll have to see what
Allen could do. What options do we have?
>> Saward Bargain there.
We do have Moonfall.
>> Vex Cheerless is going to go in to
challenge that battlefield. Moonfall is
going to bring Kai'Sa in.
And important to note that the minus two
might is for all units at the
battlefield. And on top of that, it is
not to a minimum of zero. So it actually
does go down.
>> It's not to a minimum of one. I should
clarify. And it can't go down to zero.
>> Vex cheerless now in combat.
>> So we have six to two here. Uh two.
Yeah, two.
>> Losing Kai'Sa would be devastating
>> and it looks like Kai'Sa has been lost.
>> Huge play there from Allen. And we did
see potentially the Fizz earlier. So
having access to Moonfall once again in
the near future if needed. And those
control tools are so critical in this
game overall. It's one of the ways that
Allen can actually uh have a great way
of competing in this game. The Raven
Balloon Student being ready as well with
all the spells available on top of the
abandoned hall in the future. Uh, Raven
Bloom Student is just a key piece of
this deck.
>> Allen passes turn. Three runes up.
>> Sam Sherman holds to four points.
>> So, we could potentially see Rengar in
the future. However, we do see that star
cross in hand. So, that would be a very
low tempo play. SamD Sherman is going to
have to look for a higher tempo play to
potentially deal with this Vex as well
as continue his game plan of scoring and
just being able to take advantage of
lower tempo plays of Diana. But,
however, we haven't had those low temple
tempo plays because Moonfall is such a
great card.
Thankfully, that is Vex Cheerless, which
for Sam Sherman is, if you had to pick
one of the two, the one you'd probably
want at the battlefield.
But let's see what this next play holds
in store as Sam carefully considers his
next move.
So much on the line here in the
championship.
>> Yeah, and it's hard to say what the next
move will be here. Uh, we used so many
resources at the start of this game to
get rid of that Diana just to end up
doing a trade because stupify was in
hand. Something that Allen kept from the
get-go, of course, because abandoned
Hall is very good with. And on top of
that, of course, those small might
trades against a deck that is so might
dependent. Really doesn't have many
spells to help it out. So, those just
absolutely critical.
And the challenge as well is that
Allen's up uh his runes, they reach a
little further if you happen to try to
combat that Vex. The discounts applied
and therefore he just might have a few
more extra tricks up his sleeve than
usual thanks to that Vex cheerless.
>> Yeah, this is a tricky spot for Sam
Sherman overall.
Like I said, that very beginning of this
game, that trade with the irresistible
faith folk not going in Sam's direction
because if that trade does happen, it's
a very different looking game here.
>> And we did talk about before losing
Kai'Sa is devastating. It's one of the
engines. It's going to be Rengar into
the uh the Vex tier list here. The
additional might will be applied to
Rengar itself. And this will likely be a
pretty quick star cross here from Allen
because it is just oh it's a smoke
screen. We didn't even see that in the
hand. Also a great reaction to the
Rengar. Instead of saying, "Oh, we're
going to bounce something back." We
might just be able to kill it here.
>> That's negative
four on the unit.
>> Really tough here. Abandoned Hall giving
us that extra buff to Vex as well.
Actually,
>> you do have the pride stucker uh stalker
buff being applied as well, which was
why you saw the negative.
>> Thrill of the hunt.
>> Thrill the hunt on Rengar.
>> And we'll have to pay two runes here.
>> And hard bargain does come down.
>> Yes.
>> Wow.
>> Okay, your turn.
>> A great hard bargain. This is putting
Allen's EQ in a dominant position. You
can kind of see how Sam was like, "All
right, your turn." Uh, you know, this
hard bargain has been all the right
answers against the thrill of the hunt
overall.
>> That was devastating. It looked like Sam
D. Sherman was trying to replay the
Rengar back into the Vex cheerless
battlefield and by banishing it perhaps
trying to dodge that smoke screen.
>> And Allen still having plenty of options
there. It looks like a stack deck and a
starcross. Uh we know that sabotage is
in the board for Sami Sherman. So stack
deck is able to be protected a little
bit by playing stack deck when you want
to actually find what you want are
wanting to play. It also allows you to
have a little bit of an element of
surprise as we saw stack deck into hard
bargain the previous game. I love how
Allen does save and hold on to his stack
decks a little bit longer than what we
see a lot of players do because we've
seen why it is so beneficial and
personally it's going to be something
I'm going to take away for my own games.
>> Pit rookie comes in four to two might
stack deck that is going to provide the
Raven Bloom student with an additional
might.
>> Allan with the the quick selection
there.
>> One more stock deck. Another stack deck.
Raven Bloom student goes to four might.
>> And will we find another spell here? It
looks like there's a ride the wind that
will be put back into the deck. I didn't
see quite what he selected.
>> We do see a star crossed here.
>> And it will resolve.
>> We go to damage. The arena's greatest
has been cleared.
Yeah, the biggest thing to note here is
Allen does only have two going on three
cards in hand. So, he will have to find
some type of value here because Sam does
have ways to draw cards. However,
though, we do have a nice unit setup and
we have the traveling merchant which can
help us filter through our deck a bit
more. And it looks like we might have
had a Vex apathetic drawn here.
>> Likely going to be looking for that Hoy.
We do have the Gust. Very high tempo.
very good at protecting these
battlefields in particular against these
smaller might units of SamD Sherman.
>> Yep.
>> Vex cheerless re-enters the abandoned
hall
>> and we're going to see this Vex
Apathetic join the twin here of Vex
cheerless. And this will actually stop
so much from Sami Sherman on any of
those ambushes. For instance, uh, of
course, Vex been a key player in the
entire weekend as she does stun a unit
whenever it is played and they cannot
move anymore.
>> It's an absolutely devastating card for
Sam D. Sherman to have to try to
overcome
two cards.
>> And Allen is here at six points. if he
is able to hold these battlefields,
might just become our first repeat
champion.
>> Sam Sherman's going to have to very
carefully consider this because of the
Vex apathetic. You either have to clear
that Vex before trying to make like some
sort of accelerated or ambush move.
Yeah, there's always a little bit of an
option here where the irresistible fault
can move the traveling merchant off this
battlefield. So, a double hold may not
happen. However, we know that Allen does
have access to ride the wind, I believe.
Um, as well as potentially
a moonfall from Fizz are actually having
a hard time remembering exactly what his
hand looked like here. We'll have to
take a look at it soon. cards in hand.
>> One card in hand.
We have the three might determined
century against the two might traveling
merchant.
>> It's a Gust.
Is there a response?
>> Gus being a huge card here. So high
tempo and with one card in hand, is
there a response to it? Was that a
thrill of the hunt?
>> I think we've had Thrill of the Hunt in
our hand for a bit now. So, I wouldn't
be surprised if that's what it is.
But remember, this Inferna and Pike are
both stunned units right now.
And actually that's that's a very
important consideration because any unit
replayed by Therim will also be stunned.
>> Exactly.
I think Sam might be thinking about what
else he could have potentially done
here.
>> Now if you thrill the hunt one of the
other units like the inferna for
instance, you could pride stalker buff
the sentry.
Could that be an option?
>> Certainly could be.
>> Supposed to have three in hand thinking
about
>> now. That's of course assuming that it
is Thrill the Hunt.
>> Allan patiently waiting. Probably
feeling pretty confident right now, but
you can't feel too confident until any
handshakes are made.
Sam very carefully considering this here
championship on the line.
Single card in hand has to take one
battlefield here.
>> It looks like Thrill will be coming
down.
>> I'll do.
>> It is Thrill of the Hunt on Pike.
Pride Stalker buff sends the determined
sentry to four might.
>> The pike will be played there.
>> Buff this.
>> It is stunned.
>> Yeah,
>> I'll starcross Vex and this
>> star cross being played in reaction. Uh
this one.
>> Okay.
>> Vex cheerless being selected.
Uh
yeah, that that happens.
That resolves. Determined sentry back.
>> Goes back to my base.
>> Yes,
>> that bounces. Um
two open room.
>> You have just one card in hand. It's
back
>> with a determined sentry in hand.
>> Okay.
Because we can note the irresistible
fate folk does still have the option to
move a unit off a battlefield when it
attacks in.
>> Yes,
>> determined sentry is played. You can
buff by one the uh
>> the irresistible faith folk.
>> And that just might be what we see here.
Traveling merchant does move. You will
get a discard draw. Yeah,
>> that's good.
>> Okay. Kill a merchant. Yeah,
>> and well played by Allen there taking
back that Vex before that merchant
trigger because the Vex isn't really
that useful anymore. The next card is
much more. And we do have a tide turner
and that
>> that is going to be the game. Allan ZQ
has won the Vancouver Riftbound Regional
Championship. The first ever second time
winner of a regional championship.
Absolutely unbelievable carrying Diana
to the championship. Congratulations to
Allen and Sam D. Sherman on an
absolutely remarkable finals.
This is one of those moments that these
players live for. They have worked so
hard this weekend. There's the hug.
Absolutely remarkable.
The skill expression of Riftbound is
absolutely off the charts. Allen has
showcased that once again as he lifts
the championship trophy.
>> You know what's better than one trophy?
>> Two trophies.
>> Exactly.
Here
we are at the final moments after that
immaculate match between you, Allen ZQ
and Sam D. Sherman. Allan, I've got to
ask you, as our first ever twotime
regional qualifier champion, how do you
feel in this moment?
>> Absolutely amazing. Uh, I think some
played better than me. I think I
misplayed game one especially that cost
me the the game. But at the end I had a
better match up into the sam which
resulted into me winning despite of
everything and I had perfect answers to
whatever he was doing in game three
which was uh noticeable and then just
like it was due like the last game it
was just like it felt like fate with all
the draws.
Fate indeed. And you sure did give Sam a
hard bargain there in that game two. And
then for game three to turn the tides
and bring it all the way home for the
second time ever. Allen ZQ,
congratulations not just for your second
win at a regional qualifier, but for
winning it here in Vancouver. And with
that folks, we're going to sum up our
entire weekend. And Allen's EQ is gonna
bra soak in the glory. That is the
victory.
It's been a wonderful weekend here in
Vancouver with the spirit of Riftbound
being unleashed for the world to see.
The energy in the building has been
electric all weekend long with players
celebrating the best of what Riftbound
has to offer. In one of the most meta
diverse championships we've ever seen,
Allen CQ has ultimately earned the title
of champion in the Riftbound Vancouver
regional. And who knows, maybe next time
it'll be you at home who lifts the
trophy at a future regional event. A
champion has been crowned. Legends have
been forged. And from myself and the
rest of the team here in Vancouver, we'd
like to say thank you for joining us and
we will continue this journey together
in Utrift.
Heat.
Allison. Heat.